all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things youtube channel to
start i want to apologize for this like
line around
my camera i cannot figure out how to
make it go away i can't
if you guys know how to do that in
stream yards drop me a dm because i
can't figure it out and i didn't have
enough time before the show to figure it
out
okay so today the topic that we're going
to talk about and i wanted to talk to
you guys about is
body count okay
and the reason i thought of this topic
is because i always hear the manosphere
talk about cheating like the only like
if a man loves you he's never gonna let
you find out about your cheating right
do you guys think it's the same with
body count if a woman loves you she'll
never let you find out about her body
count one and two
does it matter
what a girl's body count is if you never
find out just like the question it's
like a double-sided question
does it matter what if a guy cheats if
the girl never finds out
like if you marry a girl right let's say
her body counts 500
100 whatever is like crazy to you
um
and you go through life she's a great
way she doesn't engage in that whole
[__] she doesn't do all that stuff and
one day after like 50 years you find out
you thought her body count was one you
thought it was she was you were the
first guy she'd been with
okay so someone said and then you find
out she slept with
five guys
on the lacrosse team and you're like one
lacrosse
it couldn't lacrosse
it matters because it's like look i
agree with you
it matters because it's lying i'm 100
with you but
but
do you feel the same way for guys with
cheating
i feel that way because she's been with
everyone right but you wouldn't know
so i'm saying you never find out
body count doesn't matter it's when they
lie about it that's the thing i used to
not care about a woman's sexual history
i had a change of heart last year to me
it goes both ways for me personally it
goes both ways i don't like lying in
general like personally i just rather
live a life like if i'm going to pick a
life partner i don't want to be with
someone where i feel like i have to hide
things from them
yeah so
but you'll say she bought it like i'm
sorry
she better be honest as
like you're never gonna know for sure
ever
you know never ever ever um you might
have indications but that's what i said
if you never find out
doesn't matter what a girl's body count
is if you never so you never in a
million years
she doesn't i gotta pin oh i can't pin
this comment
but call in guys this is supposed to be
a conversation
like i'm gonna put though i'll put the
link in the chat again
oh no did this fall
i think it's okay
like if she acts feminine she
you never even meet the guys she slept
with they're
you never meet them never see them
ever in your life you will never in a
million years down
doesn't matter
now my personal opinion is
it matters both ways so it matters if a
guy
cheats and doesn't tell his wife because
you're lying
but a lot of people in the manosphere
would disagree
and
even i was on donovan sharp show and he
told me
that his advice for women would be to
lie about their body count
um but to me that's like cheating almost
not cheating against the guy but it's
like cutting corners to get something
you want it's almost like stealing
okay new age ninja cop says if i never
find out about a body count i'm cool
like i'm saying you
you never even meet a guy
she was randoms
on on
tinder in another state only
not she
no guy you would ever come into contact
with ever a million years
doesn't matter if she's a great wife
does every single thing you ask
you you there's no trace
oh god i can't breathe
sorry
it's like
i'm trying to learn to breathe out of my
nose sorry i need to
it's not going well um
i want to laugh at pearl and like call
me out for what i said earlier i don't
even know what you said earlier i'm
gonna be honest
i i have no idea what you said at all
not even a little bit
that's why sleeping around isn't good
it's like a soul time i agree i'm like i
am with you
like
i do believe in soul ties
i don't believe that sleeping around is
good i think it has a lot of
consequences especially for women
but
we're in the world we're in right
you know that
this stuff happens
and girls lie about that stuff all the
time
sorry okay
now
knowing that
focus
i'll do what i want on my show
now knowing that knowing that if
you're dating a girl and you never find
out doesn't matter
does it guys i need someone to call in
so i can talk to you
does pearl have any particular ground
rules
none that i've thought of maybe i should
i've never had anyone go crazy on my
live um
i mean don't call me ugly please
don't call anyone i have on my channel
ugly
um
like i think once you're in a
relationship body count is irrelevant
unless it's lied about
it's about growing with your partner at
that point
um the fact that people are crushed by
being cheated on tells people it's wrong
i agree
that's the question because i just want
to know if the manosphere is consistent
because the idea that
cheating is okay if she doesn't find out
about it is is common i won't say like
the entire manosphere believes that but
it's common right
so
like are we are we playing fair
you know like is it is would you say
it's the same for women if the dude
never finds out
does it matter
how many bodies does one need to rack up
that's that that question you can only
ask yourself
because every single person even girls
have a number that it's like
i know i know the manosphere believes
like the more bodies you have like the
better
you are to a girl but that there's a
point where you get kind of gross where
i'm like oh
i'm good i'm good on that i brought like
i'm i'm okay i'm
like damn the whole you slept with my
whole team
everyone like
yeah so
there there is a point where
everyone has that men and women maybe
maybe some women don't but
every man has a number that in their
head takes that girl off of wife
material now that number could be five
i've heard five i've heard ten i've
heard 20 i've heard 30 40 50. i've heard
a lot
you can only ask that for yourself so
whatever number would be too many bodies
for you whatever that first number is
if she lied
and told you it was less
and
she's a great wife and you never find
out does it matter
i feel like i'm just repeating myself
i feel like i'm just anything about
seven or eight is gross
okay
so yeah that's that would be the number
so seven or eight
more than five is too much that is
certainly not something your grandma did
okay five what whatever your number is
the the show is not it is not to talk
about
what that number is only you know
every single person knows in their heart
of hearts
what that number is for them
everyone
i i'm i'm not gonna tell you right like
i i will never in a million years tell
you who to date and what
you should find acceptable in life like
i am not one of those girls that's going
to say body count doesn't matter and it
has no consequences
like um
that's that's not me
but what i will tell you
is that is not the idea we're debating
tonight
but
guys leave a like on this video if
you're not gonna call in i'm gonna
i can't figure out how to pin this i'm
gonna see if i can pin it for my phone
um
[Music]
oh i don't know why
how do i pin this
can i not pin it maybe i can't i don't
know
we don't want loose pure tight keyword
um yeah body count matters because
nobody wants loose worn out okay why are
we so angry
have you not heard the way i presented
this argument
oh my gosh what are you doing sir
um the more woman asks the more her
[__]
uh
and we hate okay that's
i don't think that's factually true i'm
gonna be honest um
i'm gonna just be real i that doesn't
sound
true because i thought i thought it was
a muscle i you know but i don't really
care
i'm not
body count that is not the question
like body count matters and i think
there's studies to prove it like yes it
does matter
yeah it absolutely matters but
the question is if you never find out do
you care
like if if this girl acts
like like she does all the wifely things
she's a great wife does everything you
ask does it not matter and on that same
token
if you believe that it does then what
about cheating
why do i think body count matters okay
um
i think it matters but for like
different reasons um
i i think that it's hard
to discount
all of the overwhelming evidence that
says it matters now do i think
you know there's study after study after
study that says it matters
um it's not good for women
the more partners she has the harder
like it is to bond you know i'm
do i think i'm smarter than scientists
who have proven this
but no
but
i can't
but i i'm just someone who i think of
arguments and i always hear that it's
not like donovan will say on his show i
i
it's not cheating
it's like having sex that's what he says
the show and
if that's true
if you never find out about body count
like doesn't matter
so
but that's what i'm saying she doesn't
cheat on you she doesn't
like in this hypothetical situation just
like the guy that's cheating doesn't
take away resources he's a loving
husband he he's there for her
right now the second girl this is this
girl this hypothetical situation she
does all the things she's supposed to
she's not thoughtting around she's not
doing all of that
she is a great wife to you she's there
for the kids she's nurturing she's all
the things so whatever your list is of
like things you look for in a girl she
is but she lied to you about her body
count
but you never find out
i don't know
i might have to i'm going to texas torso
to call into the show because
i am not getting anyone porsha
is she live tell me if she's live
call in
to my show
no one is calling in
oh yay okay
what
i went on a date with a girl and she
literally told me she slept with a
hundred guys she told me she hated
herself i immediately left great she
told me on a first date
oh my god okay
hi
okay what's up
oh you want someone to call in so i'm
here
thank you um
do you know who i am
do i know who you are um
your voice sounds familiar have you
called in before
uh not to your show i'm uh
i moderate for torsha that's right
yeah she calls me her head mod i'm not
sure if that holds any weight but
it's nice i guess
okay let me know do you think
you you i'm sure you heard my intro do
you think body count
matters first and if so does it matter
if you never find out what it is
oh yeah yeah did you see my comment in
the chat before when you asked that
question oh sorry i don't remember who
comments what um
so it's all good
uh
do you have any particular ground rules
was before after that yeah it was way
before it was like at the very beginning
okay so
uh exactly more i used to not care about
a woman's sexual history but you had a
change of heart last year why
uh
most of it was because of a discovery
red pill content it got me thinking
about a few things
okay mainly that uh
yeah
let's get the obvious out of the way you
know the
you know questioning whether there's
someone but she's been with someone
that's better than you in some way or
multiple people in multiple ways
uh-huh and just admittedly you can get
past that which
yeah it's kind of hard to answer at this
point
so um do you think it still matters if
she's a good like wife to you and you
never find out
and do you and what do you also think
about cheating if a guy cheats and she
never finds out doesn't matter
uh
prior to 2021 i would have said
it doesn't matter to the first question
the second no cheating that's always
going to be the deal breaker
okay so you're kind of consistent then
at least i try to be
yeah no that's um
i just kind of imagined when i asked
this question the majority probably
would be inconsistent just based on like
what i've seen in the manosphere if that
makes sense
uh what have you seen i'm not familiar
with you or your channel
okay no i
no i listened to donovan sharp like he's
one person and he always said it's not
cheating it's having sex
um and even like kevin samuels will talk
about exercising options
yeah a lot of them seem to say that i
noticed myron kind of has the same
opinion like if a man doesn't it's okay
if a woman does it's the ultimate
betrayal yeah
no and i do think that men and women
cheating are different like i do agree
with that
um but it's like still wrong like i
don't think like we should be
yeah like anyone who's in a who is in a
committed relationship with someone they
want to build a life with shouldn't be
doing this
okay one person says it matters because
we need to ensure paternity but that's
the thing guys you never find out so
that means the kids are yours
you never find out like
you guys are giving all these situations
and
that's what i'm saying this scenario you
never find out just like in the scenario
they give like the guy never the girl
never finds out about the cheating
hey pearl how's it going
hi i'm good how are you i'm good
oh god
hey zach how's it going buddy hey man
good to see you uh i
i it's so weird because
back when people got together when they
were younger and they were building
together and you know got together
younger and had longer
relationships
i say body count well
i'm a a couple different minds
um
it's like people
go through the the younger phase and
then move to like well just a lot of
women and then move to like relationship
mindset later on
and so
i don't know if body count matters
uh
i don't know if body count when they're
younger will affect them trying to go
into like a relationship type of deal
um because you could argue maybe like a
lot the the trauma from having a high
body count will affect
when they you know when they have to
settle down when they hit the wall
um
but you're right you're you're really
never gonna know
um the only way
that you might know is maybe like
picking not picked up on certain
behaviors of a woman
yeah but i don't know man like body
count doesn't really
matter to me as much as like attitude
as much as
the kind of trauma that they're bringing
into like the relationship
you are never really going to know i
mean
i um
this is a really good question and this
is like a tough one
um
so i'm trying to think about what i
would do if i were in like a committed
relationship
and a woman or god forsaken married and
then you know you were to hang out with
a bunch of her college friends and
everybody oh yeah she slept with the
whole football team yeah yeah
yeah
but i mean if she were if i were in a
relationship or maybe this woman she
would do it everything that i wanted
you know that was good for our
relationship i don't think i would still
mind i i don't know that
that's a tough one
do you do you agree with like the
cheating doesn't count for guys
basically like it's not cheating it's
exercising options
it it depends
i think
it's on how much
you have to lose
um i think there are circumstances where
you and your significant other
um have
had such a good thing going on or a good
understanding that having another person
either the man or the woman or like mess
it up
um so
that's kind of where where i would see
with that
but
i mean i think
she really depends on having like an
understanding i don't think that she in
all circumstances is wrong
i think
because you never really know what's
going on between two people i understand
what i'm saying
well you don't know if she's like hasn't
had sex with him in three years or
something like yeah you're saying yeah
exactly and yeah you know it would be
dumb for some woman to say hey you know
i'm not going to have sex with
my husband if he can't have sex with
like anybody else it's been it's been
two and a half years and he's been
paying the bills and then he cheats well
that's a whole different thing but
um
yeah i mean there's so much gray area
now
uh yeah
i've never seen it myself
um
i don't care what anybody says
and i wonder what women have to think
about this but i've always been
a type of guy with like
balancing one woman is enough let alone
two
yeah
i've had friends with like a
full rotation and i don't know how they
it was always in times where they had
nothing else going on in their lives and
they could put all their time and i'm
not saying that they weren't successful
they just kind of took a cooling period
from their from their professional
development and moving forward so they
kind of took effort away from that and
put it into having like a rotation but
in my opinion most guys that have
a rotation are putting too much effort
into all into the whole woman thing
because it's a lot of work balancing
multiple women it's a lot of work
especially when they don't know about
each other so
and like i've always wanted that about
women
have you had any friends who've had like
a full-blown
rotation and how much work did they say
that they had to do
oh god um
i don't know if i know anyone that's had
like a full blown rotation i know i know
a girl that cheated on her boyfriend all
the time but
that was like pretty easy because he
wanted her for nothing but sex and i
think she would have left her boyfriend
for that guy if if he wanted it you know
what i mean wait wait wait it was like a
girl in college that i knew oh okay
i've talked about her on the channel she
had a boyfriend that like bought her a
house and did all this stuff for her and
she would cheat on him with um an x of
hers that i think
she would have been with like had she
gotten had he wanted her but he just
like wanted to sleep with her yeah
yeah so i'd say but it was pretty easy
for her to balance because
the old guy like didn't want to date her
so it wasn't like oh okay you know what
i'm saying like he wasn't gonna say
anything then he'd stop getting sex
yeah i'm not saying it was okay i
actually thought it was really [__] up
but she was just on my team in college
i have a question about that when you
get a chance yeah go ahead just about
rotations uh do you know who kevin sabo
is
if not it's okay
i feel like torsha asked me f mary kell
with him
that's that's the the rap guy right the
mommy thoughts okay
yeah that's him yeah
well uh
on the subject of rotations he was
talking about how in his experience
when it's a woman that has you know a
bunch of men on the side they all want
to just kind of
fulfill that role so they're real quiet
about it she's like you know i have a
man you know we're doing this on this
side and they're like okay
they said that for women it's like you
know the side girls want to
kind of undermine what he's trying to do
they'll talk to the side the other side
chicks and then
he said they always kind of find out
that's why guys always get caught
cheating because the girls get jealous
and like that that was basically his
point yeah
oh we lost him
yeah i think i think his wife i think
that guy's he's called him before i
think his wi-fi is always bad
hey what was the question again cuz i
just came in
okay so the question is um
does body count matter if you never find
out
so she's like i don't know whatever this
is gonna differ for every guy but
whatever your ideal girl is
uh
has all the qualities you look for it
takes care of the kids whatever
you wife her
but you never find out about her body
count
and if it does matter do you feel like
it's the same for men and cheating
i feel like it matters because like
no man wants some like
some rant through as one you know so
like
even if you don't know type [__] like at
least
she can't be like ran through you feel
me somebody really
don't matter but they do at the same
time like it's kind of like tricky
so like what about sorry go ahead go
ahead i feel like
their body counts are like master a's
like you can't be 21 with like
30 bodies and [__] for them because
you're gonna get older you're gonna be
dating around from you gonna
start talking to other people so it's
gonna be like
three times then what
what the average would uh would be
okay so what about um cheating do you
think it matters if a guy cheats if the
girl never finds out
like all right see that with that it's
like
it's like
you know you hear all the time it's like
whenever like a god cheese it's not
necessary or yeah whenever a guy has
like
sex with another girl
it's not really like intimate it's not
like no oh i'ma just leave you and i'm
gonna start a whole new relationship
with her it's like nah like you just
just [__] one time like that's it
so um
but i mean regardless i feel like you're
still cheating if like you do whatever
you're doing that's not in front of her
that you wouldn't do in front of her i
feel like that's cheating
like
text this girl you wouldn't
do anything with this girl like be
touched on and stuff like that in front
of your girl and like that's cheating
but if she's aware of everything it's
like nah it's not you
okay no i would agree yeah
because some girls like will stay and
they don't really care if the guy cheats
as long as they get the resources
yeah because that's not even shameful if
she's aware like you know yeah
comes to terms with that like that's
okay like that's how y'all operating
then
i wouldn't say necessarily cheating for
um okay but so it wouldn't matter to you
if you did if even if you never found
out like it never came up you never even
met a guy she slept with
as long as she's not ran through it now
but how do you know if you don't know
sorry
yeah
okay so like not that's true that's true
so like
i don't know i feel like you know how
you would talk to a girl and
you kind of have like some sort of
neutral friends or like her name would
be known around
i feel like that's the only way you
could really know
if she's like ran through or not so it's
you just rolling on the dice real and
trying to make the best decision that
you can
hey there's something i'd like to add to
both parts of the question when you get
a chance yeah go ahead i think the major
exception to um
actually caring about the body count is
if
say if yours is equally high and you
know you can so you can say to her you
know you've been with hotter guys i've
been with hotter girls and they were
both kind of
settling down with each other
i think that makes it a lot better
it alleviates a lot of that uh
insecurity
same thing with the cheating like if
we're both doing it
then i mean i mean we're both doing it
we both know about it it's just just how
we are
yeah
i mean
would you guys be cool with a girl with
the same body count that you have
yes
yeah what about you sean i don't know
like
it could be like all right mine's if
mine's like 10 i would want hers in like
five like if minds are that fifteen
dollars are like
ten eight types so you know
you gotta be relationships for me but
you like you know you kind of close
yeah
would either of you wait till you got
married if you found a girl that was a
virgin absolutely not
no like way for me to have sex yeah
that's a bad idea sorry i'm not now
i'm not doing that for like the only
reason because
the relationship don't really start
until like
y'all [__] because
yeah if you want a long-term
relationship you got to make sure that
everything is okay like you don't want
to be
a year deep in two years deep
and like
you gotta end [__] because this isn't
right like this isn't good for me and
like you know it's just a waste of time
you don't want to waste time so yeah
would you guys follow up would you guys
break up with a girl if the sex was bad
yeah i mean you i could like teach you
only so much like so about you know
trying to die here and she's still
not like satisfying me yeah we gotta end
[__]
i'm kind of the same yeah you give her a
chance to improve if it isn't working i
mean it's a short coming you know you
can't get past
huh
interesting
um
okay what i'm trying to think of another
question because you guys kind of
answered everything that i had
um
so if um
because i could kind of see the argument
of like the
because personally i would never want to
be in a relationship with someone where
i feel like i have to keep stuff from
them you know
but i do see the argument that people
make where if like you never find out
about the cheating or about the body
count that it doesn't matter because you
never find out
i mean i guess they say you know what
you don't know won't hurt you but yeah
how far does that really go
i mean my whole thing with it is you
know
what's going on in her head
what's going on in her head yeah like is
she cool with you is it
or is she thinking about this other guy
from the lacrosse team like you said
earlier in that example
the lacrosse team yeah i guess you're
thinking about the lacrosse team when
you're on top of her if she is it's a
problem whether you know about it or not
do you think you have this one thing
with her and for her is totally
different
what do you think of this comment if you
want a skilled woman with a low body
count good luck
what do you
what do you guys think of that
that's going to be rare
skilled or not that's going to be rare
i mean it's like
you like
huh let me read the question he said a
skill one with a little buddy
i'm you like nobody really expects no
virgin to be
top tier on some porn stuff [__] like
nobody like realistically expects that
but
unless you're the one that's gonna be
like she can be decent start off decent
and over time y'all together y'all finna
make sure that's what i was gonna say
like
yeah
unless you're the one that trained her
then it's not going to happen
yeah exactly not a virgin that's that's
the whole point
you're a beginner
what about this comment you don't need
to worry about body count if she
genuinely desires you
you know that's true for me personally
like
because honestly like really because i
was just thinking about it again and
[__] it's like
you really
you're just truly not gonna know i just
i just don't want her to be like so ran
through that it shows on her body type
[__] like you just like you look at that
[__] that [__] just looks destroyed like
that she just looks crucified type [__]
what is that what does that mean i was
gonna ask the same thing
because i know i know some girls that i
ran through and they look great like
they look like english better than i'll
ever look what i just said maybe it's
just genetics like
no um i just met like physically like
that i did too physically like you know
some people some people drink they do
all these other things they look like
crap
yeah that's your partying partying does
take a toll on you
but some people it doesn't at least not
until later so how do you tell
someone
yeah yeah sean how do you tell
that's the tricky part like sometimes
you can tell sometimes you can't so it's
like you just wrote like where
everything you will on a dice type [__]
but
you just you just gotta make the best
decision that you can
would you be more accepting of a high
body count if you knew that the guys
were like far far away
like she went to school in
hawaii
and you'll never meet
what they still live in her head no
matter how far away they are
okay what about you
she just can't be no hoe like
like she just can't be in a hole and
have like whole tendencies that's what i
like
um if a woman expects monies or favors
she doesn't desire you
kiki who's kiki clout i don't know who
that is she's an adult film actress he's
been a guest on fresh and fit that's all
i know
i don't know oh yeah i've heard of it
do you guys care about tattoos that's
another question
depends on where they ordered
no it says multiple tattoos equals ran
through
no this is not see [__] like that like
that'll be like
like in real life [__] cuz like
sometimes you gotta like
you know like you still gotta be aware
of like
female nature and [__] but in real life
bro when you actually experience [__]
you actually talking to females like
none of this [__] like people be talking
about be actually like
happening as far as like oh this many
tattoos equals like but that [__]
i mean what where are the tattoos first
of all and what are they of
i'm trying to think yeah my friends
tattoos have higher body count like like
thinking i mean last year i talked to a
woman she uh i asked her if she had
anything i'm saying you know not even on
your lower back she looks me dead in the
eye and says you mean a [__] stamp
like that is what they call it i mean
get a sense of humor about it but yeah
i'm trying to think
my friends with tattoos versus i
actually have one friend that waited
until she was married i have a couple
friends that waited till they their
married devsex
they are both really happy actually
um
neither have tattoos actually that might
be true
i don't think about it
though like so like how you say how you
ask early if um we would like [__] with
like well if we were like wait to
marriage or whatever if
if a dude is on that same type of path
and the girls on the same type of path
and they meet and they
you know start their relationship like
that could work like that can actually
work
but if it's if one of them's not on the
same page like it's not gonna work
but if two people want to wait till
mary's like that she can it can play out
they have to actually want it though it
can't be you know one once and the other
one wants to get with her so he's gonna
put up with it yeah exactly yeah
now you've signed legal papers and
before you even find it if you're
compatible in bed
yeah exactly well i think there were
both virgins in both cases to be honest
they're pretty religious
um
that works for them it works
how many baby daddies or mamas no none
of my friends that i'm talking about had
baby daddies
um
i don't actually
i don't have a single friend that got
pregnant young
congratulations not married i can't even
think of one um
a man's sexual past is not a concern of
mine
no no
cat but i have difficulty attracting
more conservative girls who have more in
common with and woke tattooed chicks
well i mean it's probably going to be
easier to attract the girls that have
less takers
like duh
it's really
vice versa
it's really on youtube you just gotta
like
you know it depends on like your
location like where you're meeting them
you know all that all those little
things matter
you can't be like going to nightclubs
and [__] expecting like some
wholesome female
would you guys rather would you guys
rather have
a girl with a higher body count that you
had more in common with or a girl with a
lower body count than less in common
with
um
give or take say five bodies or three
five i'm gonna say five
uh depending on how high the count is i
don't think that's that bad
yeah
because if she has a hundred and i have
ninety five i mean what's the damn
difference then
how much compatibility like
plays into it for you guys because a lot
of times the manosphere makes it like a
metric like if she's this hot this this
low of a body count this this and this
but what i've seen in real life is that
it's a lot more about stuff you have in
common with people
yeah like so for example right like if
i had 25 bodies and like she got 20
and we like we highly compatible
then i'm just [__] with it all right and
she's not a hope but she just
you know just
like body kind just
equally as high as mine is like
are we compatible yeah i'm a [__]
in common what are you teenagers
you're not supposed to have a lot in
common with the person you marry
are you guys crazy you should have
something in common
like it don't got to be everything but
you got to be suitable because
suitability and compatibility are two
different things like when you suitable
with somebody
even through rough patches and
disagreements and [__] like that y'all
could still push through it and it's a
bonus if you have some you know some
sort of compatibility with it too which
is you know common interest and [__]
like that
or even when i think of my parents like
part of the reason they work is because
they're both like catholic they both
grew up in like
similar like environments you know they
just had like a lot of stuff that other
same politics like stuff other couples
would argue about like how to raise the
kids they didn't never had to argue
about they just
hadn't commented you know
commonality helps a lot
i'd say it's not essential but it does
help
um
it's so weird that people in here want a
woman with experience
with a low body what's the thing that
people always have about that
it's like the comments saying uh ladies
something oh well what is it a lady in
the street to freaking the she said it
that's the one thank you
yeah someone else says that you look
like tim poole
is everybody going to say that no matter
where i go on youtube
i think it's your hat i think if you
change the hat it wouldn't be as much
well i mean when i took the picture it
was black friday it was cold outside so
yeah
you have to be agree on common virtues
it's good that spouses are different i
agree
and maybe virtues are essential because
it's like if you disagree on what's
right and wrong
how can you possibly be like partners
you know what i mean yeah
yeah you know
i agree
what
what do you think
is worse a girl lying on her body count
or a guy cheating what's worse
guy cheating
well if it's committed
yeah i can say that yeah if it's like
committed and like it's some [__] that
she's not aware of yeah i'll say that's
the worst yeah if it's a rotation she's
arbitrarily gets pissed about it i mean
you know what like do you have to stand
on there i am so surprised by you guys
responses i totally thought i was going
to get different answers to these
questions
which part or just all of it
all of it um i really thought that the
answer i would get is that if a guy
cheats it's not really cheating which
sean alluded to a little bit but not i i
know what you were trying to say
and that is because real life is so
different like people yeah they'd be so
focused on like red pushing like
like entirely like way too like maybe
max like maximus and [__] with it
yeah it doesn't uh
i don't rely on all things rental i
don't think anybody does really but
that's one of the things i kind of put
my foot down like cheating is cheating
like don't do it or if you do at least
own it
admit that you're doing something wrong
yeah because you can easily be like i've
done it before like you can easily tell
a girl like what's up like from the from
day one type [__] and you never know
like you never
you never know what type of response
you're gonna get so
it's like you might as well just like
keep it a buck from day one at least
with the lie about the body kind of like
they don't owe you an explanation
it'd be nice to have one but
yeah exactly yeah so you have no power
in that type of [__] yeah that's why
you're actually cheating you're actually
breaking a commitment that you've made
to this person
yeah if that's the relationship you're
in
only the so called high value man can
get away with cheating
yeah that's what i said like most guys
i don't think have the option to cheat
would you guys agree or disagree
yeah i agree
i would say like some dude like working
at gamestop does not have the power as
like
i mean i think you can but the frequency
is going to be a lot lower i mean you
know yeah the woman you're seeing she
can go out and get 100 guys in a week if
she wants you know can you say the same
yeah sure
i mean well i mean i think it depends
but for a girl i think
her ability to cheat is like the numbers
of guys she could get in a week that she
actually wants
because i don't think most girls are
gonna just sleep with
like or cheat on you with anyone they'll
cheat on you with someone like that's
why like they say cheating for women and
men is different because when a girl
cheats on you she's cheating with
someone she actually wants we're a guy
he's just cheating with someone who is
there
and interested
yeah like like a guy with a debt with
good ass cheat on
or they would that ass like
[__] some girl like they wouldn't even
be out seeing getting coffee with type
[__] but a girl will actually like
make a
make a thoughtful decision like yep like
this is right i'ma [__] with him tell me
like
they actually put thought into it
hey have you ever seen the movie
marriage story
i haven't with uh scarlett johansson and
adam driver
no well it's basically about a couple
getting divorced
and a big part of that is because the
guy cheated with one of his co-workers
and they're having an argument in the
midst of it he says you know well you
really
you know you should be more mad not that
i slept with her but that i had a laugh
with her that i had a good time
she gave me something
not physical that you couldn't
oh my god did she just you just want to
destroy her self-esteem my god dude they
don't even say he says something about
like he wishes he would just die so that
he could raise their kid on his own it
gets really heated why didn't he just
leave at that point he did just leave
they were getting divorced but they they
had issues with it and it's it's it's
insane but it's a great movie
huh on netflix when do you think it is
um defined like when do you think a guy
emotionally cheats
like can i does it have to be he has to
give her resources
like when when does it become emotional
for a guy because i've heard i watch
this one video about this guy talking
about how his side chick was his best
friend i'm like
that sounds like a little emotional
cheating like
i don't wanna
wait when you say resources you mean
monetary
no no um because they okay they say
cheating is different for men and women
right yeah we can agree like a little
bit to some extent still cheating but
it's it's different because when a girl
cheats like she's cheating emotionally
where guys can just have sex
but i'm saying if a guy uh
cheats when does is it defined as
emotional
i feel like it's the fondest emotional
one like you're actually investing like
different things into it so like you're
investing time into it like you're doing
this for her like you're helping her out
like i feel like that's a that's a guy's
you know quote-unquote emotional way of
being
invested
okay so investing time
if he spends the night is that investing
time
yep yeah it can be like
having like
like helping through like helping her
with [__] like you know mentally like
doing
[__] you would do with your girlfriend
but with the side chick
sorry i'm reacting to what torches said
in the chat i know i i was reacting to
what torches said too
i have a question for you about that
best friend thing
okay go ahead
uh do you think that you can actually be
best friends with your partner like do
you think that's something that works
in a proper relationship or do you think
it's kind of
more of a fantasy i considered my
ex-boyfriend my best friend but then we
broke up so that's what you said
the key word is x
no offense
yeah i'm
that's something i had to really think
about last year as i was uh going
through some things
do i think
um
i mean
it just depends so much on the guy
because some guys are more emotional
than others so there's certain guys
where your girlfriend cannot be your
best friend because you
are so emotional that i think it's going
to like drive her insane
you know what i mean
but for like a normal guy like some guys
aren't that emotional so
like i think it just depends on how
emotion as sad as that is it's kind of
sad but it like kind of depends how
emotional the guy is you know what i
mean
interesting personally i think that a
lot of people try to find too many
uh they want their partner to play too
many roles so to speak i mean does that
make sense
no
like you know
some guys meet a girl especially young
ones they expect her to be his
girlfriend his best friend uh
uh it's partially his mother in some
ways
oh
oh my god yeah yeah i know what you mean
it's like you expect you to wear too
many hats and then it just doesn't
yeah you can't yeah
i feel like i come from like a lack of
abundance like just in like in various
ways like like lack of mindset like lack
of resources like a lot of self
development needed like
yeah that should come from anywhere
but torsha you can i put that i can't
figure out my comment won't pin
i don't know why i don't know if i just
like can't
but i put it in the chat so
you can just click the link and you can
come on
um
do i think that men
i oh my gosh the mother-son relationship
i've done that that's not fun
but
if you think that someone like our
fathers and grandfathers who didn't have
access to porn
that they wanted oh that's an i never
thought about that but do you think that
someone like our fathers and
grandfathers who didn't have access to
porn
that wanted a pure virgin woman compared
to compared to today's men in 2022.
i've got some strong opinions about that
subjects in general
go ahead go crazy um yeah porn is kind
of killing us
and that's something
until last year i didn't quite realize
the full extent of it because i heard
people say like it's bad for you or it's
damaging but they would never go into
the specifics of why it actually hurts
it's always like you know something like
you know
you know if you're delivering pizza
she's not going to screw you it's like
no [__] so tell me something that tell
me something new and
i finally kind of got that last year in
the sense that
what porn does at least for young men
it gives you a fraction of what you
actually want
compared to before in the past
generations when they had nothing
like you can
see a naked woman you can
at least for a moment pretend that
you're the guy in the video
and that kind of robs them with the
motivation to actually go out and do the
scary things that would get them a real
woman
that's a really interesting point huh i
never thought about that yeah i'm not
going to get into the specifics because
it's kind of weird but
standpoint like you you're depleting the
[__] out like as far as men and [__]
like you're depleting like the [__] out
your energy you need energy to do
everything gonna be like because you
constantly having dopamine rushes so
your brain be thinking that you're
actually having sex when you're really
not so now you're just building this
instant gratification addiction and [__]
and when you actually deal with it with
a real female
you expecting some wild [__] that's not
even like
you know that events that don't even
happen in real life
so it was like
is that what happened like to you guys
you expected wild [__] from girls
because um
not personally at least nothing overly
wild because i never watched anything
overly wild the
time stuff was okay for me at least at
first so
although i will say that it
hit a
well just like i was saying earlier
rob's you have that motivation
to actually go out and do things that
would get you a real woman so you've
tricked your mind into thinking you're
already getting her because
you know you see it in the video and
you know the human mind doesn't really
distinguish between that and what's real
so it's thinking you're getting laid all
day every day you know why why improve
why why do anything but this you know
you're spreading your seed so we're good
like for example pearl like have you
ever
ate hella food before and like you just
felt tired as [__] you didn't want to
get up at all
like you thought
i do i do way too often that's exactly
how i feel
when um a dude has done like venus [__]
like you know that's like that's exactly
how i feel so imagine feeling like that
24 7. your brain's clogging [__] you
won't feel like doing nothing like you
wouldn't feel like
doing the basic household like chores
and [__]
like that's bad like yeah like that's
terrible you don't like nobody wants to
get that 24 7.
i did not know that i don't
i don't know anything about porn maybe
you never watched it as uh
as a kid no i i watched it one time and
it was because i told this guy at my
dorm that i'd never seen porn before and
he like was determined to show me
and go you weren't you were an adult
when you finally watched it yeah i know
i've never seen i saw it i swear to god
i saw it um
like i was in my my dorm lobby and like
they were talking about porn i was like
oh i've never seen that and then this
guy was like i need to show you and that
was the only time i've seen porn in my
life
oh okay
yeah i'm like very specific um if i
haven't opened a door i try not to open
it like doors that like could lead to
bad things
like
um like drinking i stopped drinking but
i used to drink a lot and now forever
i'm always gonna wanna drink like that's
always gonna be like in my head and if i
can like stop anything that could
possibly lead to something bad i just
try to
so that's why i understand i didn't
start drinking until i was 21. or
however that i started when i was 11.
i was 19. i was i was 19. i was damn
near an alcoholic but i've been offered
like
coke and like hard drugs and stuff like
that i've never tried it because i'm
like i already know that alcohol has
caused me problems like i gained weight
i feel like my skin was better before i
drank and
like if i can keep every door closed
that i can
possibly keep so i don't ever have to be
like tempted
then like i want to limit that does that
make sense
yeah it does and i actually quit
drinking a couple weeks ago for similar
reasons
if nothing else just because for the
clarity aspect of it like it's actually
quiet in my head again which is nice
yeah
i used to
in college i used to drink a lot but
i just
i would get so fat from it that was like
the main reason was i gained like 20
pounds
and i really like i really i'm not good
at eating like i love sugar and i
figured i had to quit if i wanted to
stay in good shape i had to either stop
drinking or stop eating sugar and i like
sugar too much
yeah that'll do it yeah you ever watch
uh parks and rec
no
well you're aware that chris pratt is on
was on the show and he lost a lot of
weight towards the end
i don't know who chris pratt is should i
that's
marvel
guardians of the galaxy i really watch
movies oh god you're like tori well
anyway he's basically he's a big movie
star he was kind of fat and then he lost
a ton of weight and they actually
commented on the show they're like
you had to get in good shape so quickly
he's like oh i just stopped drinking
beers like how much beer were you
drinking it's like i know right
so yeah some of us are lucky some of us
are not with the alcohol thing at least
in terms of weight gain well i would
just do it once a week because i was an
athlete so i we had a rule like within
24 hours so just be saturdays and then
like twice a week during off season but
yeah it would
okay what sport did you play
volleyball basketball and track
[Applause]
okay you must be pretty tall
yeah i'm six foot well five and a half
for being specific
some guys like that some don't
yeah it's very you know what's
surprising i
i i the most guys that approach me are
five five i swear to god
i don't know what it is
but like five five five six those guys
they love the tall girls it would be
like that with my whole team
i wonder how tall lemonade is
would you take somebody serious that was
like like say like they literally know
like you liked how they looked and [__]
but you know everything was cool but it
was like five six
no cause it's like
it's so superficial
but if i'm being honest um
like i i'm six foot i would say like
five ten and taller
is
like in your shoes like being 5 11 and
then like dealing with somebody's like
5'4
it makes dating a lot harder
because
it's like
when you're a tall girl and you're
really only attracted to the guys that
are taller than you
um
it reduces the dating pool for sure yeah
and like those are the girls that like
all the guys you're like competing with
everyone for those same guys
so
i if i was 5'5 i think dating would be a
lot easier but i can't help that i'm not
attracted to guys shorter than me like
it's just it's kind of
i don't know i think it's kind of
biological you know what i mean it is
biological at least from what i
understand i saw a post on tumblr about
this tall woman that was kind of
complaining that
all the guys that were significantly
taller than her were going for these
short girls and there's really no one
left for
i found this is okay so i found and you
guys could tell me if i'm because sean
you're six too so you can tell me if
this is true
i found that guys like six one two six
four
three four
tend to like the girls that are shorter
like five five-ish that's like their
type but then if i get six five and up
they tend to prefer the tall girls like
like five ten and up if they're over six
five like if they're freakishly tall
yeah that's pretty accurate because like
with me right now like my girl is on
she's five four
but i'm six two thousand like that's
like it's okay but
um if i was like six five now this is
like too short like not even awesome
like
just because i don't i don't want a
short girl says that i just i literally
can't because like if i kiss i'm gonna
have to like
like i'm too it's awful so yeah yeah
that's what
like i have a friend that's six five she
married a guy that was six ten
a woman is six five yeah
anyway i played with her in high school
damn
yeah they're gonna have huge kids they
just got married
do you want babies
yeah more like ada
yeah
god
damn sick that's crazy
um do you think that it's discriminating
a guy can't do
anything about it what if a guy says i
will not date any woman bigger than a
size four i think that's fine
you know people always bring up
people always bring it up
yeah you have no problem with that
no no i'm not a size four i'm bigger
than that i would have no problem if a
guy said i was too big for him like okay
i can lose weight it's not yeah that's
what they always bring up that you you
actually can change your size height is
not uh
not so lucky
yeah
like there's a million i don't
understand why girls are offended if
guys don't want to date you
like
i don't there's a lot of guys i don't
want to date and some some guys i
wouldn't date
like
they're probably like
like they're good looking it's not that
it's just like there's something i don't
like like there's a million reasons that
you wouldn't want to date someone
i'd imagine it's because they're allowed
to
like going back to what you said earlier
like a woman's gonna she's more likely
to get someone that she's
attracted to whenever she wants
yeah like like if you're getting what
you want all the time and you still
intently don't get it i mean it's like
what the hell
yeah regardless of it if it's right or
wrong that's how you're gonna feel
um
that's fine sean unless he is 400 pounds
i'd say dream on there's a girl on tlc
who's six and nine oh my god
i i love being tall i wouldn't trade my
height for the world i literally love it
but even i would not want to be six nine
i would rather that's too tall i feel
like that's too tall for anybody unless
you're an athlete where it's an
advantage because otherwise i mean
because i'm 510 myself it feels like
everything's built for me doorways cars
beds
thank you for the donation
thank you i'm broke so i really
appreciate donations
so much england is so expensive thank
you told me you were loaded
what my no my parents are
people think you have access to your
people think that that you have access
to your parents bank account like well
you could be a trust fund kid you know
we don't know
i would very much like to be i will
submit a request
i will
like it's nice i always have a fallback
like if [__] goes bad i'll move home but
i'd really rather not you know
i did last year
but that was different because
i quit
my job to go to england and then cove
had cancelled the season so i had to
wait a year so then i just stayed at
home so it's a little different
you know what's so good to me it's like
people be like talking down and [__]
like that like where's like damn sorry
nigga's not like down bad financially
like this [__] ship
i actually i don't
i would 100 data guy that lived at home
because i'm really cheap so you could
save so much money and buy a house if
you just save the money
that you like get from living at home
like so you were raised
sorry
sorry go ahead i was just gonna say you
were raised rich but you're cheap
no well my dad's the cheapest person i
know
okay so you're like the frugal type of
rich well because my parents were
weren't like rich growing up they made
their money so and plus um i have nine
siblings
so there's a lot of [__] that like other
families did that we did the cheap way
because there's so many of us like like
we never flew anywhere we drove
everywhere did you say nine
yeah so damn yeah
yeah so irish catholic they don't
believe in birth control so
um
crazy
yeah
so but
yeah so i don't know my the richest i
swear the richest people i know are the
cheapest i know someone who's worth
probably like
50 million
and
they the wife drove the same car for 20
years and it was like this old beat up
car my dad drove like the most beat up
car for most of my life
so
there because rich people know how to
stay rich that's the thing
you know most people know money
oh you're saying like are these people
that you know are they all new money
the one that i know
the one that i know it's generational
like he inherited it
oh
yeah he's so cheap oh my god this man's
so cheap
like i don't know what i think it's dad
was in government or something
but there is like that jet like the like
multi-generational wealth where like
those people have been rich forever
that's a different
like we go to private banking events
sometimes and we'll like run into those
kind of people but
it's like more rare than you think it
costs a lot of money to maintain like
the lifestyle that you see
on social media and a lot of it's fake
i'm out of water
there's anyone guys we need more people
to call in there's 33 of you on here
do you normally get into a lot of
callers or
yeah actually i do
i'm surprised that was the first one
no i haven't done a live in a long time
because i went home for a couple weeks
so all my equipment was in the uk
uh
what do you guys think of black pill
yeah like what is um
like how would you define that cause
like red pills like you know truth like
full awareness full consciousness blue
pills like living the fantasy but like
what would you describe black people
that's like
the ultimate everything black belt type
[__]
no this is like the most pessimistic
ones to me
well because they believe you go ahead
oh just say you know if you're not six
feet and all the other requirements you
might as well just give up pack it in
you're done go home
yeah it's just basically that everything
starts with looks and it's your face
and like height plays into it a little
bit but it's all about
like how symmetrical your face is pretty
much
it's like
looks and [__] like it looks some [__]
matter but
you like as long as you're the best
version of yourself type [__] like you
constantly working on you know this this
and this for yourself like on things you
can actually control like then that's
all that matters
yeah the uh the best way i've heard it
explained is looks matter height matters
performance in bed matters but the way
you act the way you carry yourself that
that makes a difference too
not with all women but there are always
going to be some
yeah just put if you just put in the
work
but you know girls so
complaining about hiding [__] like that
but then you have like some 5-4 dude
like really pulling this [__] like he
pulled in multiples from me
like actual attractive female so it's
like
is that it's up to you
yeah um got someone else hi
are they left
oh dude i feel so rejected
bam what did i do
this is not black pill we do this
naturally symmetry
denotes height and fertility you know
what i found out
this one factor if you
if you're in red pill stuff you've
probably heard of this you know your
face is shaped by like if you breathe
out of your mouth or your nose
yeah that's true like mouth breathing
[__] like you get like you can't be
mouth breathing like that [__] really
will [__] you up like it's beyond your
jaw symmetry and like you just
like it's not good
yeah i did it wrong because i couldn't
breathe out of my nose most of my life
so i had to get surgery to like fix it
and i was like
i did not realize i would i would have
picked otherwise if i knew
yeah over time like you can yeah yeah
okay wait
hi guys
hello
hi
that guy left again
um yeah i could hear you i wasn't
talking about you
me
yeah no not yet i was i was talking
about someone else um hi
um so we we're really off topic but
the topic we're talking about is does
body count matter if you never find out
about it so she's a great wife great
girlfriend
has a high body count and you never ever
find out
i mean if i never found out like
if i never knew
that means she's a great actor
yeah
she's award-winning
for me
i don't i usually ask a little question
because i'll bet she tells you a small
number i'm like most likely to believe
it
like three
because
nine times out of ten now if i do found
out great white great mother
i don't know if i stay or not i don't
know
i might think about it
i might it might be a real hard tough
decision to make i might look at the
kids and be like
sure uh
because think about that
because at some point i gotta ask
what if one of one would do in her past
come running back
come running back to her
trying to talk to her trying to get her
trying to get her to do something she's
not supposed to which does happen
it does
which does happen
and the chances and the chances of her
doing something
increased
because
that's why i said um i didn't want to uh
not not to cut you off but that's why i
said earlier like i didn't want no girl
that was like a whole lot or carry the
whole tendencies because like he just
said like it could be some dude that
really hadn't hooked it you know some
months ago some years ago
and all they take it's a simple text for
them to bring back in like [__]
everything else
i agree with that
and that's what i was trying to say
earlier in terms of uh
you know it's not necessarily the guys
you've been with or what you did with
them but it's like once you've had
better can you go back mentally and be
satisfied with this guy that you've
settled down with
yeah i will say like i don't know a lot
of girls that cheat but the ones that i
do know that do
um
it's usually with an x that's usually
who it is
exactly
yeah yeah
that's true
um so but in this case
you don't find out because she doesn't
cheat like that goes with not finding
out
i think it depends on how well they lie
about it for one yeah
yeah i'm very accepted i'm i may
i may be autistic but i'm very
perceptive
okay
because usually usually
tell them to telling me once tell me oh
three
right like some low crazy little number
for your age that doesn't match up with
reality
unless you've been in like a long-term
relationship for all that time it's like
okay two guys in college one after that
and then we recently broke up and i'm
with you like okay that makes sense
assuming you didn't cheat but let's say
you were a single woman it's like a only
three guys i'm i'm in my 30s now like
who are you trying to fool
seriously
being there
sorry go ahead go ahead
i've seen i've seen i've heard i've
heard heard a story where the guy's
girlfriend didn't be together for three
years they were going to get married
one day he came downstairs and said she
said these exact words well he won't be
he's not as big as my ex downstairs
oh god
poor back that bro it broke the poor
bastard
god damn
and it
and
he eventually the good thing he did he
he broke up with her
good for him but here's the thing
it's partially his responses
he has taken accountability as well
because after like i say the fourth or
fifth date the girl broke down about the
guy that dumped her
like nine months ago
she started crying about him all he did
was sit there like oh it's okay it's
okay
like
at that point at that point he still
he's still been with her he still agrees
to be be with her for a year
the question proposes itself is why
didn't you walk away
because at that point
like some of the men on the um thing on
the
podcast
was called
what would you do in that situation the
girl started breaking down about some
about her
when you walk away from that
some guys wouldn't but when you walk
away from that
if you're not emotionally compromised
you will
but it can be hard to tear yourself away
from that situation especially if you
know you've spent years with her
maybe you're married have some kids at
this point like i built my whole life
with you and now i'm finding this out
well i think you said it was the fifth
date right yeah it's the fifth date
oh sorry my bad i misunderstood
when you were first starting out first
starting out first date started crying
about
some guy that dumped her
uh like a couple months ago
when wouldn't you walk away from that
situation
if you don't i have no sympathy for you
yeah
because at that point you earned
everything that came to you
he gave up a big red flag
no i'm just blind
do you guys believe in the benefit of
the doubt like giving a girl the benefit
of the the doubt and vice versa
every day unfortunately
no it depends on the situation because
everything is like okay
what does it depend on
so like um like when would you give a
girl the benefit of the doubt and when
wouldn't you
i can give you an example of the time
when i did
but you want to go first sean
i feel like you had something to say
then i'll go next so like i said the
pencil like um there got to be something
very reasonable like it can't mean like
it got to be like extremely valid type
[__] like i can actually back it over
some real life proof safe [__] like but
you just talking about your [__] now
you you could tell when somebody lying
like
they just talking about their ass trying
to like save themselves and [__]
then it's like no i'm not going
i'm not going to overlook [__] i'm not
going to be blind to [__]
right now
there you go
me i'm trying to i've been afraid of
that like what do you mean
in what context
no no i just meant like
a girl saying like in that situation
that was just something i could i could
see someone giving someone the benefit
of the doubt
like if she like maybe cried because of
something that happened that was like
painful in that relationship or
something that's like a situation where
i could see a guy giving a benefit like
the benefit of the doubt
that makes sense so i was asking like
sometimes
you know you give people the benefit of
the doubt and you get burned and
sometimes you give people the benefit of
the doubt and they prove you to be a
good person like that's always a risk
you're going to take with any person
that you get involved with
wow it is a gamble
yeah always relationships are a gamble
in general especially for men because
we're
hormonally different every single day so
well well for me
it's a little different
since my emotions regulate differently
my emotions regulate differently so
starting like
well
you clearly want him so go back to the
streets
hey if you can then yeah and you mean in
terms of red flags right
like the ones you would ignore because
like you know everyone has something
so i need to give this person a chance
of a red flag that someone like ignored
or not red flag um
something that could have been a red
flag with me so um
like one time i i ordered shoes and they
were the wrong size
okay and the guy i was dating thought
someone else had been there because i
ordered like and if you just assumed
like that i was seeing someone else like
it could have been like gone the
conversation could have went a
completely different way but really i
just like ordered the wrong size shoes
on amazon
oh i see what you're saying does that
make sense that's like that's like a
situation where that could be fishy but
you give someone the benefit of the
doubt yeah because [__] happens in life
it's you know either there's a thing or
it isn't i just i just set them by my
door because i was like oh they're like
how did that end up turning out though
like
it wasn't he didn't bring it up i said i
like was like oh yeah i bought these
shoes the other like i just mentioned it
in conversation
and then he was like oh my gosh like i
thought like that might have been
something fishy i just didn't say
anything
quite about it
yeah he did because he was like what
where did he see the shoes she was that
they were by my door
because i ordered the shoes off at
amazon and they're the wrong size like i
put it what
were they in like a box or like no
that's what kind of shoes were they oh
they're tiny shoes
were they like women's shoes like i
guess not obviously if you thought they
could be amazing they were they were um
they were like women's shoes that could
have been men's does that make sense
like okay it's more of a unisex type
yeah
so you know what i'm saying so my shoes
are big wait what's your shoe size 11
oh okay
so if you get one or two sizes too hot
like it could be a guy shoes
i i can see how that could like be
low-key like a red flag because it's
like yeah
that was not in the box and you got like
yeah well because i tried them on i
tried them on by my door
you know what i'm saying i wouldn't tell
you guys the story if like if i was
lying about something
like i would pick a different one
yeah you know now that i think about it
my story may not be so much better for
the doubt it's something i really
shouldn't have ignored but did
oh yeah sorry go ahead i think i cut you
off earlier oh no it's fine i it's uh
i'm probably gonna get clowned in the
comments for this but whatever i was uh
sort of seeing a woman back in july and
she was telling me about how uh
she actually ended up having an affair
with her co-worker
okay
and then she said like it lasted for two
weeks it was
amazing but i knew what i was doing was
wrong so i ended it
i mean it's like
like
yeah i get what you're saying or what
you're about to say but go ahead
like
if uh let's say i'm dealing with some
some female whatever she's married and
[__] honestly i don't give a [__] but
like
that's because you really like the dude
really can't get mad at me like i'm just
filming just trying to get some chicks
just like any other contest should you
feel me so you gotta
be
talking to your girl but like that's not
on me so i really don't be i wouldn't
feel bad about that [__]
well
i don't uh i don't
know it could get your ass beat up one
day well the thing is
in the example i'm talking about he was
a marine and his wife was a marine so
yeah she was like yeah basically if she
finds out she's gonna [__] kill me
well i don't i don't think she'd ever
find out you
not me but her
yeah okay okay oh god i don't
it's just wrong on many levels man
like me
i've always said never let your knee uh
intercourse morally corrupt you
in this case you let it all you just let
it loose
meaning meaning me personally if if if i
know that she's in a relationship or
marriage and i realize that she she
wants to step out my first instinct is
like hold a minute what's going on here
what's going on here if
you feel that you need to step out of
your relationship just just tell them
hey and break up and walk away because
it's better to leave
then do what you want to do first
it's like i agree with that too but it's
like
um like morally type [__] like i do
agree with that like you might as well
just leave type [__] but
hey bruh it's a dirty game out here but
so it's like she that's how she moving
like [__]
[__] it but like
you got to be knowing what you're doing
like what you're risking this [__]
yeah the only reason i didn't kind of
end things immediately there was because
for once she was very open and upfront
about it
and on top of that it was um
she was just coming off of a divorce it
didn't go so well so i was like okay i'm
feeling bad i'm gonna do it you know
that's that's the 48 laws of power right
one act what's like one act of honesty
will overshadow like 10 lies
very interesting i forgot what it is i
know exactly yeah
i only know this because i was reading
them to my dad the other day and asking
if he agreed or not
and i remembered asking him that
how is that having no code like
because
in the main experience it like you will
see these
you will see these type of um
what would you call it like you will see
this type of nature references all the
time like you know like back you know
hunting and like [__] like that
so it was like but
like if if the [__] girl is choosing
[__] like that
and this very game with me like
everything's all good and [__] like zero
risk like if i want to like at that
point it's gonna be my choice if i want
to like i'm gonna do this [__] right
i mean
i will say this you know whether you
agree with it or not yeah are you not
ever afraid of getting like beat up like
that that's what i was getting to um
like even if we're doing like a
completely because that's
no offense that's like the selfish point
of view like i want i wanna like busting
on it so i'm gonna do it regardless of
if she's taken or not um
that but like if you're gonna do that
like at the same time you you could get
your ass beat so maybe it's only
if he's not that jacked or anything
no i wish that's what i said like it
depends like you got to know um how you
playing [__]
so like if he's
on vacation or something sure he's not
working or whatever and
we uh i don't know some room or whatever
like i'm gonna crack that [__]
and it's like
it's like i'm
are you gonna tell him
do you tell the guy you mean
yeah
i mean sorry do you tell those guys
you tell the guy that he's his girl is
running around with you and has been for
however long is that what you're saying
just a girl you don't know or do you do
you know her
oh
as far as like um
like [__] and [__] um
no i say like say like i just meet out
and like i don't know like starbucks or
some [__] and she's you know in a
committed relationship or whatever like
that that's what i mean
not some people i really know type
channel so the last girl that you slept
with i had a boyfriend
did you did you know the boyfriend
no i never know i've only done that [__]
twice but i've never known
like so you did it so it was just like
random yeah it's always random it's
always written i would never like if i'm
somewhat cool with you
or i'm actually cool with you i would
never do that like that's wild as [__]
huh i was just saying you don't [__]
where you eat basically yeah like yeah
so it's like if i don't know you like
we're not cool at all type [__] i don't
even know your favorite color it's like
i'm gonna do that [__] if i want to
said it's not it's fair game she's never
yours it's just your turn that's what
they say i had a guy threatened to kill
me last year over something like that
really yeah like straight up uh i was at
a place and uh
this woman i asked about and they're
like first of all someone told me up
front like don't talk to her her man
will kill you i'm like okay whatever
like i wasn't trying to mess with her
after that but i was just making jokes
some
she was about your height i'm a couple
inches shorter at 5 10.
so i said something like you know well
all i said was something like you know
height doesn't matter when you're on
your back you know haha
and walked away
you're just as a joke but then the man
comes up to me he's like hey i like you
zach but if you try anything i will kill
you
oh my god
funniest thing happened to me the other
day i was at this um bar with my little
brother in colorado
and he i'm i'm a wing woman i'll help my
little brother out i always talk him up
to the females so i'll go up and talk to
the females and be like this is my
little brother and anyways um this one
girl he thought was cute so i go up to
her right
and i like introduce adam and her
like we're in the middle of a
conversation like she has two friends
and then it's like me and my brother and
her boyfriend comes up like in the
middle of us and like kisses her and
it's like very clearly like
you know it's like awkward have you ever
seen like those guys that like just need
to like mark their territory even though
yeah even to the point like it's kind of
uncomfortable for everyone like we're in
the middle of a conversation he pushes
through and i'm thinking okay so adam
just like brings his attention to a
different girl right my little brother
and i was talking to the girl and i find
out that she's bi and he was worried
about me
that is hilarious like he thought i was
and i'm i'm like very
i don't swing that way so i'm like let
me ask were you taller than him
or taller than her yeah yeah i was i
don't know well i could see i understand
why people think i get it a lot because
i'm kind of like i don't wear makeup and
i kind of dress like a boy so i get it i
mean i can just see that as a man like
you know my girl's talking to some other
girl and she's taller than me and just
looks like it's going a certain way
yeah
i just i
i was only talking to her for my brother
but yeah like you're just trying to help
your brother out
i just thought it was funny i just
wanted
it
okay it's not a moral argument you need
to grow up you're immature who is oh
he's probably talking about you sean um
but not exactly what jay said it's not a
moral argument but it's just like
biology and like two was like
me okay me personally like saying like
all right
just like how i'm in a relationship now
like but she wasn't she on me type [__]
like i found out
some other dude was um [__] that [__]
like yeah that [__] going uh that [__]
gonna hit like that [__] gonna hurt but
at least my eyes open now at least i'm
not five years in type [__] yeah i'm
doing all this and this and this and
this investing this time and sir and
like doing this and that
and this is going on the whole time like
i'd rather be cut off right now
than two years later
yeah
that's how they get you with the
emotional investment
at this point you're my woman and now
you've done this
okay mac um we're off topic i know you
just joined uh because i think we all
really talked about the topic already
but the topic is does body count matter
if you never find out what her body
count is she's a great girlfriend
partner whatever
and you you never find out
and if you do think it matters do you
think it's the same for cheating like if
a girl never finds out whatever you say
so i assume this is for like a a
committed relationship does it matter if
you never find out i mean
it's kind of answers its own question if
you're none wiser
you know
it's
it gets really metaphysical really quick
i i um
not to kind of [__] on the whole
question but i mean like you never find
out i mean i don't i don't personally
[__] care if you show up then
cool okay
as long as i'm not getting any like
[__]
hiv or some [__] on some wild [__] like
i'm good
okay so um as long as you don't find out
you don't like know the guys they don't
care
i mean even like and she's like a good
partner and everything i mean even if i
find out unless there's like some like
yeah i [__] like
an entire school then i'd be like okay
like
all right
would have been nice to know but i mean
but [__]
that would just be so wild that i would
be like okay let me just sit and process
what the [__] was just said for a second
but you gotta you gotta think about it
if she was willing to screw an entire
school
then gotta start put how she feels about
herself into question
think about it if she was willing to
give up her body to mostly every guy in
the whole school you gotta figure out
it's probably affected
probably addicted to socks which
be nice for like two weeks then it would
get [__] old so
now something's clearly wrong
mentally something's clearly wrong
mentally
and
you'd be
you would be crazy the big oh well let
me just stay with her anyway
uh if it's literally in a guy i agree
with you you know if it just happens to
be a ton of guys who are all hot that's
that's different
i mean i don't like if it's like if it's
my own relationship i don't like i worry
about what's in front of me i don't give
a [__] about like other
[__] and what the [__] they're doing
like
if she as long as she's not crazy or
getting me infected or something like
she's her own person like i'm trying to
get this
camera working and this computer is it's
crazy
you're okay i don't i don't require yeah
maybe someday when i'm bigger but right
now like i'll i'll let anyone be here
you're like you're like damn nobody
wants to see your ugly ass but
let me ask you something that guy that's
not what i said
zeus uh what do you think on the topic
it depends on your age to be honest okay
if you're over
like i'm how old are you
i'm 24 28 okay so
if i
i personally date women who are a little
bit older than me
i don't know why
just kind of my attitude attract that i
guess but
i mean if they're around 30
and they've been having sex since
they're 16
that number is going to be a lot higher
than someone who's 20.
yeah that's true clear numbers
not really sheer time in numbers so
assuming other things are consistent
so but but so the question doesn't
really matter like what the number is
what i'm saying is every guy has a
number that's too much i mean i would
say every girl kind of does too but
you know i think
it depends but
every guy has a number that's like that
is too much so whatever that number is
for you and only you can know that
like if you didn't know like so let's
say it was 50 right she slept with 50
guys or 100 guys whatever it is
and she's a great wife great partner and
you never find out does it matter
no like it's not about what the number
is it's about like the concept does that
make sense me personally i don't
care
okay i don't care it doesn't matter as
long as she's doing what i ask of
okay
i mean that's all really
now if i never find out that it's
something i figured out like like
something happens on where i discover it
i don't know man i don't i don't can't i
don't know i don't be paying for
something that everybody had
ever gotten ahead of you
i'm i then i'd be looking stupid like oh
yeah
yeah i put up relationships more than
sucks dude i understand that i
understand that
i understand that wow
this is me
i don't want to pay for something i
i understand that relationship is more
than intercourse but it's a big part of
it especially for dudes
i mean it it depends i mean i get it
like i mean
everybody has everyone has their needs
but it's like
it's one thing i don't get about like
the red pill like all [__] talk
about is like basically like sucks it's
like are we like still in [__] middle
school like
how addicted to sex are we like jesus
christ it gets like a lot of
conversations get old so quick it's just
like i'm not i'm not 13 anymore like
i think i think the red pill the red
pill is based on intersexual dynamics
that's why sex is such a common yeah
that is the topic that's the whole yeah
that's like the basis of red pill so of
course but like
[Music]
and relationships have to do with sex
yeah it would be one thing if we're
talking about the 50s before you know
like people weren't having sex all the
time and like doing that outside of
marriage but we are i mean like i get
that but like i have i have co-workers i
mean i have my mom i'm not thinking
about yeah i'm trying to like [__] my
mom like i mean also you know going out
that's why we don't talk about like the
relationships between us unless we
always we really on
you're saying like well it's sex craze
and we're like okay the topic is sex and
then you're like
okay well i don't talk about my mom well
why would we talk about your mom when
the topic is
i was just giving a side comment like i
wasn't trying to like
hardcore darrell i was like i was like
okay so we got no this this we got
[__] in a chat call me a sub when i
literally say like sex it's not that big
of a deal like okay and like
this is like something
it's like some imax projection going on
right there what the [__]
okay
exactly
okay okay guys guys stop for a second
zach i gotta kick you off because i kick
off the person that's been the longest
and i have another person so thank you
for calling on but i have to kick you
off all right thanks for having me
thanks for coming
okay
i can only have six at a time i don't
wait hold on okay um i don't have
premium yet guys so feel free to drop a
donation so i can afford it
and have more than six people
okay hold on hold on
hold on hold on um hi marcus
you know my house is broke too
are you like what's up guys how you guys
doing thank you
um marcus what do you have to say about
the topic
body count if body count matters
well not that if it matters because i
think like for me that's like like yeah
it does to some extent but the question
is do you think it matters if you never
find out like she does all
everything you would want in a girl
but you never find out if you do think
it matters do you think it's the same
for cheating like if a girl never finds
out the guy cheats
the yes to me i think it does matter
just because of the fact that i don't
look stupid walking around in the
[__] grocery store
or going around in public going to
church or some [__] yeah that's just me
uh because a woman's chastity is like
part of her value besides the way the
fact that she carries herself
it does because
like no disrespect to mack or anybody
else that was saying some of this stuff
but
um it does matter especially for a man's
reputation and his respect especially
his respect among his family members and
his peers
it's gonna matter if a woman is showing
if the woman is showing some type of
like hey you know
value and respect and and the way she
carries herself can she redeem herself
absolutely she can redeem herself
but it also depends on the number of
bodies and the and the way the
relationship is worked out
but like okay i get that but like what
does it mean to like respect with me is
it like how like haha i had your
girlfriend in the past too
or is it like someone yeah cause it's
because you gotta understand mac for
guys it's different than for women
that's that's corny though like i
understand but like like i said double
standards exist for both men there are
double standards for men and there are
double standards for women i mean like
right now and i was i was raised
culturally different and i was raised
more traditional so that's where it
matters for me
i mean like if i if i if a guy comes up
to me i'm like yeah i had your girl in
the past i'm like okay like
i'm not trying to i'm trying i'm not
getting around people like that well let
me ask you this
if your girlfriend
if your girl had videos of her on only
fans or if your girl was a stripper if
your girl had videos of that she has
legal images of her nude yeah you know
but you didn't know about it until later
when everybody started sending the
forward did you mind care about that
that's a wrap because that's like one of
my conditions is like i mean it's cool
you get your money it just doesn't have
to be with me but like if you're lying
about something like that then it's like
it's like [__] what other people are
saying that's like between that's just
even just between me and hurt us like uh
kind of
you like 99 chance you have to go
because like i just can't do that sorry
well that goes that goes into effect
the body count that can correlate with
body count that can correlate with the
past you know i know it sucks but it's
just it's a difference between men for
men if we don't have [__] we don't have
a legacy if we're not responsible and
for bums
what are we yeah cause look bruh it's
like when you out and [__] just like how
marcus said like when you out and [__]
like nobody's feeling like they fit me
they said yeah that's marcus girl
they're not gonna say like oh that's
victoria like now they're gonna say
that's marcus girl like
y'all uh he's a huge representation of
the whole relationship like so they're
gonna be pointing at him and [__] like
laughing but but who the [__] are these
[__] though if it's like just like
random people i don't [__] care
like
i'm not trying to get respect by like
hood [__] like oh i [__] your girl
like cool when i like gold star like
nah it's like it's because you know like
me personally i don't
i don't uh when it comes to like
i don't know i got to say like
unnecessary conversation like i don't go
[__] with people saying [__] but you
still you still gotta like
aspire for that respect just that for me
that equal
respect and [__] because everybody's
like
you ain't gotta know somebody they can
just have that respect for you
i'm not trying to be respected by
everybody like because on that case like
i mean i'm getting roasted by chat which
is cool but i'm going to do what i'm
going to do at the end of the day like i
want respect for my peers coworkers and
other people i consider high class but
like random like like random dawns and
all the people like okay okay so what if
what if it what if it affected your
personal relationships like what if um
what if your girl hooked up with someone
from your work i mean you're like yeah
if it gets to the point where like
people like keep talking to [__] and it
gets annoying then i mean it's highly
likely i want to break up because like
when i respect your point i respect your
viewpoint i respect how you want to live
i respect your boundaries and your
limitations i i will tell you that i
respect it and that's how you want to be
that's how you can do
my only question is what if she's
messing around with someone that you
care for and respect for that she's
messed around with how would you feel
then i don't i don't do poly so like
it's a wrap like you got no no no no no
no he's talking about before
before let's say that she caught bobby
she was like two like two of your
co-workers or a co-worker and appearance
if she [__] with someone i used to know
in the past that i don't like well i
mean
no no i'm talking about a guy
how would you feel that she kept that
from you
like that she did in the past like i
don't [__] care
[Music]
okay but not because with that right
it's like
a woman that's over the age of 25 has
done something already she's done
something with someone already
there's always a man that can one-up you
like that's understandable [__] like
that but that's why i said oh i mean you
wasn't here earlier probably but um
earlier i said like it depends too
because like marcus said um a few
minutes ago you don't want to
be like waking up one day type [__]
[__] got videos of her like
in the gang bang and [__] like that but
that's
that's not
a body count okay but
that's kind of off time
yeah that's like that's like that's like
go for a player i'm trying to speak
the topic is um
if you never found out because i often
hear in the manosphere if he cheats and
never finds out what does it matter do
you do you agree with that first
statement marcus because i've asked
everyone else and if you do
um
do you think it's the same for body
count
like personally personally for me i'm
not going to cheat um if i do it'll i'll
let her know ahead of time
okay
okay because i have a footstep at least
so i have i have a i have a polygamous
relationship right now that's why
um it's a it's polygamous on my end and
it's closed on her and she's monogamous
for my religion my girl
wow
good for you
i mean
i do not know many people that could
pull that off but but i only do it once
in a while though i don't do it
consistently i do like every now and
then
i'm not doing it like every weekend yeah
i get it like i mean because i used to
not like polygamy but i used to like
live that type of lot like i'm still in
college all like just used to have [__]
buddies like get it it's
you know stuck out you know everywhere
every once in a while and well i mean
this isn't a step out this is a range
but like you know get something new
it's cool
i mean here's the thing man if
let's say there's five men in here right
now and each one of us have sex with 10
different women that's 50 [__] women
dude that all have a past at this point
which like how long will it take
you know what i mean until it comes
around
what comes around like uh like like the
clap like what we're talking about here
like
no it comes around like i'm saying like
until
you sleep with someone that knows
someone that you respect like who who
gives a [__] at the end of the day
i'm in college so listen there's way too
many people in the world so it's like
because you know i do what you're saying
but it's like
if we wasn't so populated then oh i
would like i would kind of agree with
that type [__] but now we
it's the way way way too many females in
the world for you to settle with
somebody with like a super high body
account for you to try to like make
peace with that
you have way too many what what what do
you have to make pet what do you have to
make peace with then what do you have to
settle for though well i mean if if a
person person likes that [__] it's like
all right you do you type [__] but i
mean i don't personally like having
someone having a super high body count
but unless like again like if it's like
an only reason i would care if it's like
extremely high i'm thinking like okay
how do
why the [__] are you spending all this
time on this i'm like do you are you
like addicted or something like do you
just have to like you know hop on like
so many like new bodies like there's
something missing there where like it's
it's
it's like a crackhead you can't ever get
high because so his tolerance is so high
that's when i start thinking like okay
like that's the only reason i care about
body count
marcus i have a question for you i asked
most of the other guys already um would
you wait until you were married to have
sex with a girl
um
only if she uh
like if she's a virgin
if she showed me everything else because
of the way i was raised if she showed me
every other value that she could bring
to my life the way she's with my family
that she's respectful little to me
i personally don't mind waiting because
of how i was raised
um but but
she'd have to be like
the one in a million girl for me
okay
um second question would you um
would
actually figure out what the second
question i asked earlier was would you
wait oh would you break up a girl with a
girl if the sex was bad
it can be talk
yeah it could be taught maybe it's a 50
50 that's a 50 50 for me
okay yeah yeah i got a teacher if she
doesn't and if she still doesn't
get my rocks off then i think i might
have to end it
if it's like early and she like has like
no interest and she's being combative
i'm like
damn you know i might have to
be somebody
i'm gonna follow a question
so like what the
like
version of waiting for marriage [__]
so why are you waiting like would you be
uh
[__] with other girls and [__] or not
maybe i don't know man that that's a
good question maybe
maybe but i know for a fact to grow more
now i took her virginity
and i've been with her for the past five
years almost like four and a half years
and she's older than me
okay
how old are you if you don't mind
sharing
well i'm just gonna i'm about to turn 28
she just turned 30 and then when i met
her when i took her virginity i think
she was like about 26.
how did you
um bring up that conversation did you
just tell her from the jump this is how
it's gonna be
uh i slowly teased it as we got serious
as we got serious that's when
i started telling okay like these are
the boundaries for both of us
those are respectable for both was that
after you slept with her already or
before
um both before and after
okay
that's just i don't know any girl
especially no girl that's a virgin that
would do that so that's
good for you you found like
oh don't tell me you remember she has
some problem with it at first but we're
good now yeah yeah
because i know i know i know a decent
amount of girls that like waited until
they were married to have sex
and i i can't think of that's respectful
that's respect yeah no i know like i
grew up in catholics and then i went to
a christian church for a while so
yeah i know like a decent amount
i often hop off the call but i had a
good
good good talk with y'all and [__] okay
thank you
removed
guys i keep putting the link in the chat
like people saying can i call in
um i don't require people to be on
camera so
like anyone can call in and just not
turn their camera on you just click the
link that's in the chat
um
okay uh
i got a question
hold on hold on hold on yeah i
accidentally clicked all right
wait wait okay wait hold on
hi hold on do i say do i say osmosis
yeah that's as well okay cool what do
you so the topic today i don't know if
you heard earlier but we get off topic a
lot so i'm just gonna retell you um is
does body count matter if you never find
out
nah
okay now you don't think so
nah i think it matters and i talked
about this before and i probably talked
about this again i think it only matter
to me personally i only care depend the
only body counts that matter to me are
the body counts within your vicinity
okay i'm not trying to like
if you came from somewhere else and you
don't you're not really like a local but
say we say i frequent a country club or
a bar and you got like five bodies in
that bar
goes by the times matter to me
oh [__] yeah
it might be
you know i'm not worried about your past
cause i i just feel like most women one
are gonna lie about that anyways
so you're never probably gonna get a
straight answer
if you're really overly worried about
anybody it's probably and it's not
trying to like
do shame language like but it probably
says more about you that you just care
yeah
to me it means that you don't have you
you rarely have bodies if you're not
worried about it
yeah hey
i ain't trying to talk over i'm just
gonna just keep it a full [__] stack
like a lot of a lot of people who like
like i would say like the vast majority
of people like hyper obsessed like oh my
god do you like do you you you have more
than 10 bodies i'm like yeah if you're a
[__] if you're [__] like
if you're a woman in like united states
who like if you're not like [__] like
ass ugly like chances are like yeah
you're gonna just
have a few like god damn like it's like
people will get like people like
overdose on a rat pill and they'll be
like oh my god if she has she has more
than three bodies like it's like i'm
like bro like that that eliminates so
many [__] people dude like unless
you're like [__] like um casanova or
like you're you're like in a really
traditional culture you get something
like that you eliminate a [__] ton of
people
yeah i mean i saw somebody in the chat
somebody was saying mia khalifa and a
lot of peace stars i i just like how how
many times are really going to come
across
anybody like that dude we're normal
people man not like that
we're normal people i think like the
equivalent is a girl with an only fans
have you guys met a girl with an only
fans
[__] and uh dude
unfortunately every day
every day what about you i mean like
it's like college like everyone like oh
i have one as a joke yeah like yeah i'm
[__] right
my girlfriend in high school has the
yo i don't know if i gotta like clean my
mind but like wait what no it wouldn't
be anything sexy i just thought it'd be
funny okay yeah i'll support this yeah
no get your mind out of the gutter
it was too hard though i didn't they had
like
i i was like a gay idea
wait so marcus what do you think about
what osmosis
said did i say that right i said it
right right right
i say people's names wrong a lot so i
get kind of paranoid
because you were you said that it
mattered so what do you think about what
he said
are you there
okay also john murray i gotta kick you
off i'm sorry you know the rule it's the
person that's been here the longest
i haven't been here for like what 10
minutes
okay well
i'm sorry you're the longest
um i don't know if you remember me but
i'm the guy that lives in hong kong
so i i do remember
uh talking to you before but i will like
to comment on what osmosis was saying
i live in a different country
so
if
if i get a girl from back in the states
and bring her here her body count means
[__] nothing i don't know anyone here
you know what i mean so yeah
what why the [__] would it matter
as long as he does what i need her to do
here who's who's
his background is that that's very
distracting i don't know oh [__] guys
i'm the [__] nerd with the mechanical
keyboard
you just mute yourself if you're gonna
yeah
you don't
you don't care if you so if you get a
girl from the us and bring her to japan
it doesn't matter because you don't know
a single guy
yeah i don't know anyone here
i just have my business here so are you
saying you wouldn't impress her on what
her body count was
because that's a little different like
i'm on that stance but you wouldn't
press her and wonder what everybody
account was no i mean why a lot i i just
said it earlier
i'm 28 i usually date women who are
older than me
bro
if they're having sex in 16 and they're
30 that's gonna be a lot more than what
i got
so what the [__] what am i going to do
hurt myself
just get what i want to get and keep
going
i don't understand the issue with it
yeah what you want to get is in like a
relationship or you're talking about
dude if if she's down to if she's down
to help me with my business she can take
care of children she could do all of it
why would i give a [__]
um
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna cut you off
just to introduce a new guy
what below
[Laughter]
okay do you want to be on i can take you
off oh no it's fine sorry i just uh i
haven't done a stream yard in so long i
forgot how it works that's cool okay i
just i just put people on um
as they click the link um
okay so the do you do you know the topic
yeah i've been here a while so i
watched everyone else answer
okay what is your opinion
uh i'm still kind of caught in the
middle i'm not really sure what to think
okay uh the trudy part is definitely
wrong but aside from that
the tutti what is that cheating
oh the cheating okay
sorry uh
dealing with something in the background
here but
i can't even complain bro
yeah you got me beat with the typing
thing but i didn't realize it's going to
be that [__] loud i think my my mic's
volume's way too loud let me adjust that
happens to me all the time on zoom yeah
that's fine just mute it if you're gonna
type that's not a big deal people
probably like who the [__] is this
transformer miles [__] like okay
so you said you're you said you're in
between uh
in terms of purely the body count thing
okay so how old are you but you don't 25
i've noticed that guys over a certain
age stopped caring
would you say that's true or false no
i'm saying like
like um true i've noticed like guys that
are younger will ask me where guys that
are older won't ask would you say that's
true or false
uh here's the thing about that um
the guy who was here earlier the the tim
pool guy
i actually kind of know him personally
and uh
oh
damn
i kind of have to agree with what he
said about
you know
not caring so much before but as you get
older starting to care that's why i'm
caught in the middle i was kind of on
the side of it i was on the side of it
it doesn't matter before going backwards
yeah because like at first i thought it
didn't matter now as i'm getting older
i'm thinking you know well why would i
why would it matter if you were older
it's not necessarily that i'm older but
that i've learned more and i'm thinking
about things in a different way than i
did before yeah it is the red pillar
yeah
and i don't i don't i don't have a
problem with um
guys like if they care about body count
like i think there's enough studies that
show that it has some effect but the
question more is like if you never see
those effects does it matter that's more
of the question
because that doesn't offend you at all
if say a guy wasn't okay with like if a
guy wasn't okay with your account that
doesn't offend you at all
no
why would why are girls offended if
someone doesn't want to date you there's
a million reasons i don't reasons i
don't want to date guys i mean i'm still
i'm still stuck on the asking part well
i feel like it's a weird [__]
question i asked i don't want to feel
like deep in a relationship
just straight up ask yes but you know
sometimes guys can kind of connect the
dots and you believe you're going to get
a right to answer out of that when
someone that when you ask one of those
girls what their body counts are
i feel like if you're already like six
months in a relationship and you're like
you're already kind of like at least
semi-committed at that point and you
haven't figured it out or at least have
some signs at that point
this that's already an owl like
i think it all depends on how like a
woman cares herself you'll find out if
she has been one girl that is saying you
know she's for the streets she'll find
out how she kills yourself and how she
walks and how she interacts with people
and
i think that's how you can obviously
tell if a guy that has honest like
true insight to dealing with women and
women's nature
that's the best way to figure it out and
then
hold on hold on listen to women how they
speak let them run on
and max you gotta you gotta meet
yourself man because that's just
annoying hey bro that's not me right now
that is not me who the hell that is
typing we gotta meet you hey
like obviously guys
i think instead of saying like all this
redcoat stuff for a god-ass woman i
think it's just preference i think it's
just a
woman's been around the block this is my
preference i don't want to do a woman's
been around the block
it shouldn't be called rp
yeah i mean i get i get there's
something to someone with less body
counts but i guess worse
if you're if you're asking it's just i
just like six months is way too long you
wouldn't know being around a chick long
enough if she was first
like
like there's a there's a girl i hang out
with that we almost got involved and
just going out the bars and like just
you know hug
many guys and do it's just like okay i
can i got the picture you know
you're out here in the streets yeah
that's what i'm talking about but if you
don't know her like yeah
like see your news and work one of the
best ways to find out i'm sorry because
you are one of those moses but one of
the best ways to find out um if you ever
see women in clubs or like in parties
and you don't let them know you're gonna
be there but then you suddenly pop up
and you automatically like find her
there so you're from a distance how she
interacts when she's had a few drinks in
the system or how to travel with other
people
you can kind of tell how she interacts
with her friend i think that's the best
way to find out
um that's just my opinion to find out
she's for the streets i i mean that
takes two that just takes too much
energy but yeah like no no i'm not
saying like all of a sudden like tracker
and like soccer and do it now i'm just
saying if it whether it happens
or there or from afar you see her
marcus what do you think about what they
were saying earlier um i think you might
have not been like by the screen or
something because i asked you
um what do you think about they said
that they don't care if the guys aren't
close like if they never meet them then
they don't care
and that you'll never actually really
know what do you think about those
because i think you were the
only one who's really like seemed to
care about it like more i guess the most
it's not so much that i care so much
it's just a matter of term respect and
sort of like
sort of like i get it the don't ask
don't tell policy like i thought i don't
even ask for my body count
right
but no i'm asking if if um
say she's from like hawaii
you're never gonna meet any of the guys
you're never gonna does that change
things for you or no
oh well no i mean obviously that's in
hawaii that's over there in hawaii so
i'm never going to fly down how you live
in hawaii so
okay
if she moved to you and sorry go ahead
no no you're again
no so if she like was from hawaii she
moved to you you're never gonna meet any
of the guys
like you maybe go to her hometown once a
year
like
does that so that then it doesn't matter
no i don't really think it doesn't okay
i get then it matters depending on how
when you go back to her hometown how she
moves
yeah it's overly friendly and yeah no
that that's what that's a whole respect
factor like that's not even really about
bodies
it's just kind of like if she's moving
like well she has to see her family so
like no no not the family they say you
go out i mean obviously she's living
long enough you go out you frequently
you know again that's that too friendly
thing like even if she had the bodies if
she wouldn't have the wherewithal to
like
not give guys that overly friendly
energy and your presence if you're
starting to kind of take her serious
then yeah then that would just be a red
flag for me like okay well because then
if you saw that it's too friendly
because i've had got like
too groping too too physical to touch me
okay just do physical touch
and make eye contact yeah
like if i if i saw a girl that was
involved with like i wouldn't like just
not say nothing to her right but i was
just kind of dismiss her quickly like if
she came like oh hey yeah a lot of girls
think they're okay
they're not
like don't try to catch up with me
uh pearl regarding going back to your
hometown and things like that um
i'm currently in a relationship now
actually with a chinese woman
and um
her family lives in mainland china
right so
if i want to meet them
or if
my
significant other wants to see her
parents i would just offer to bring them
down here like to get give them like
some sort of vacation type of thing even
with my parents like i i will never go
back home because i have no business in
the us
nothing going for me there
so like i would just fly my parents here
you know what i mean so like
there's ways to get around this [__] to
be honest
like
i'm just saying like
there's all this [__] going on ways to
get around what
so like if if someone is really worried
about going back to their hometown type
thing
i don't want to go back to my hometown
there's [__] nothing there so
i would rather give my parents a
vacation
you know what i mean where are you from
kids
i'm from
i'm from texas some shitty place in
texas
you mind saying what what town what city
i'm curious uh
outside of dallas area
is it one of those small towns where
kind of like nobody lives there
nothing there
how some crazy [__] happens everyone
knows about it because you're just that
close i don't know much i don't know
much about like uh
fort worth and dallas but i know they're
like there's some some seedy areas in
some places like
yeah
i asked because i've been in that
situation before
i don't know
luzon this comment about my bad the
trying to rationalize wife in a whole
it's not about wife and a hoe it's like
she could probably have no bodies almost
and just the fact that you're
antagonizing with the bodies because you
can't
gauge her
that's what i'm saying if she doesn't
have bodies and you're antagonized over
the bodies then you're probably just
losing a good one
it's like if you can't tell if she's a
whole like whole
mentality where it's like if they really
have that many bodies
they think a little different like
and
commitment for them is weird usually
yeah
and can i can i jump on that real tip
too like uh for me like the reason why i
felt like i don't like really care that
much for me like body count is just like
smoke like smoke can be many things it
can be a [__] building fire it can be
a barbecue like it doesn't always have
to be bad i've known some chicks i find
really [__] annoying way too friendly
can't can't chill out just doing too
much and they and she can have like four
bodies but then i know some people who
just like she just she just she just
hops around that's just what she does
and i'd be like yeah yeah she's all
right so like for me it's just like a
sign but you know
languages is languages are multiple like
signs and
i guess a trip is multiple signs that
you look on the highway well i think i
think what
um osmosis is trying to say is like you
can't really control if she like lies to
you and you're never really gonna know
so why worry about it would you say
that's right
yeah just just go go for what you can i
worry about what i can see and what like
what i gotta deal with like other
okay if like these are kicking down the
door if like because i mean chances are
it's like super high like if there's
like people coming through like kicking
the door down waving the deuce deuce
like okay that's a problem but like
beyond that like [__]
about that like
basically if she looks a certain kind of
way
do you really think she's going to be a
virgin when you met her or have a very
low body account like if she's that
desirable do you really think you're
going to be the first guy to knock on
that door
based on culture though
like isn't that based on culture though
because it does because there's culture
where i live
girls just dressing like girls that i
know that wait until they're married
yeah i don't know i know i think i would
say
not everyone was like you pearl
just not everyone is like you and not
everyone runs in those circles where all
the girls are you know
no i don't i i have hope like i know
girls that are hoes too
that's kind of that's kind of aggressive
like but okay
i was building off of your question sir
where i was saying i was wondering if
the girls that i know that are virgins
are hot that's what i was thinking about
oh
yeah so i was trying to rank like i
would say sixes that i know yeah i mean
if they were super attractive be too
much pressure too yeah i ain't gonna
i ain't gonna lie
wait until marriage like okay like
i mean if you for real for real about
like like for real about the bible i
mean like i can see it but like i mean i
like like the outside so like how am i
if i don't know if you like good if it's
like if like if you like [__] in a bed
and i'm already married like that sounds
like an owl i'm sorry
hold on one second zeus i'm sorry you're
getting kicked off
sorry man
all right i mean i i can't i can't even
say it's not personal you're just next
and
then it's me
it might be lemonade bae if i keep
getting this attitude
i mean i can't even say like because i
was talking all you know it's more than
relationship besides like of course but
like i mean sex is a pretty [__] big
deal like if we get married we can
continue this conversation i just need
you to wait one second well i will
introduce hello cold steel
okay well hello
cold steel ringing twice i guess i'll
wait for them to come on
price
yeah how's the sound is it good
yeah it's good how are you
i'm good thanks
um so do you know what the topic is
yeah yeah my opinion on the topic is
that uh
um
like guys who worry about body code uh
uh are the type of settle for a mediocre
relationship
like as [__] so it's like like being
used for money or favors
the woman not participating
because uh if you're satisfied with how
the how it's going
yeah you wouldn't care about the body
count especially if she's like a nine or
a 10.
for example i have an analogy say say i
just made it made a big purchase and i
know i got a great deal on it
i wouldn't be worried about
uh what the price was yesterday or if
somebody hey
somebody else got it
right okay i'm gonna say nine intense
get flown out and have only fans and
they're the ones that are most [__]
uh
like my point before but like i mean i
would like to say like i wouldn't
don't see myself getting in a situation
but like
it's like is for me like if you're like
if she wastes a marriage like unless
you're not like counting like dome or
anything but if you get married or you
like uh or you're like convincing the
marriage or whatever it's called and
she's like a dead fish in bed and you're
like oh [__] i'm already married like i
i just can't do it but uh
that's why i personally like
like i don't know like a [__] like do
a test drive like like have sex like
once what the [__]
did you know that like statistically um
people that are like wait until they
were married have better sex lives than
people that didn't
i wouldn't doubt that is that
self-reporting
no i've heard that and and it's mainly
because you don't they have longer
marriages too like they have longer
lasting relationships but where is that
information coming from the first part i
mean
like how do you know that they're how do
you how do you know their sex lives are
better is that just self-reporting or
well i think one statistic you can look
at is like the length of the
relationship and the length of the
marriage
um
so i think that's like where the one
part does and i would imagine that
the
the sex is probably like the number of
times you can self-report
probably yeah it's probably
self-reported i can't imagine any other
way
that's just you know someone's word you
know what i mean but length of the
relationship might have some credibility
right
but i'm saying like like how else are
you going to measure it you can't be
there yeah
that would be [__] weird
[Laughter]
yeah this says research has found that
those who waits for sex until marriage
compared to those who don't report a
significant
action by twenty percent
okay
hold on everyone be quiet 158
thank you oh my god thank you i'm so
thank you
what happens when you're a hot girl so
much that's a stacking
i don't know if that's what it is
right i'm like is that a different
currency
thank you so much oh my god thank you
sorry to continue i'm just really happy
i mean
i mean i i don't i i don't either i just
go to club be a [__] goofball like
um
okay i forgot what we were talking about
i got i got so excited
hong kong dollars no
there had to be a catch
pearl so i don't want this [__]
chinese money
gets worse i was like there has to be a
catch there's no way someone donated
they're really hot
i don't know what the conversion is on
that don't tell me don't tell me i don't
want to know let me have this i was just
supposed to open google too like let me
ruin your [__] day
just let me have this all right yeah
you're all right you got it
oh my gosh
that's interesting you know this is a
lot different of a conversation i
totally thought this conversation was
going to go the other way
the
i thought that most guys that were going
to call in were going to say they cared
but the majority said they that if they
don't know they don't care or the guys
aren't near they don't care which is
interesting
i wanted to point out one more thing
go for it because guys guys who who
complain about bodycon
um you have to find out what they don't
talk about so they don't talk about
if they genuinely desire each other if
they have a good time each with each
other
or
if the woman genuinely desires the man
or if she sees him as a confident
all that all that all that other stuff
and the attractiveness makes a big
big difference as well
so far his body counts
oh
whether you care about their body counts
because uh
there's like eliminator that's a nine or
a 10 who genuinely likes who you're
you're probably not really care about
them
a nine or a ten that junior likes you
well it depends how you feel about
yourself they get a lot of attention
have any of you guys dated a nine or a
10 anyone
no i'm [__] ugly i can't do it
in the short term for not like a serious
thing but yeah i was like i don't know
if i'm about this 9 or 10 like because
like i said it's a lot of tension yeah
that's what guys i've always heard and i
don't know if it's because
they can't keep them no offense i don't
i don't i don't know or if like um
it's because it really the juice really
isn't worth the squeeze well it depends
on the on the the girl right the reason
i could do it is because like
the girl that i was with was just like
we'd go to a restaurant and
she loved the attention so like we're
just happy you know she just kind of
like
yo just made me think about something
just like it's like uh are we are we
here are you trying to make sure
everybody's like digging how you're
looking i mean just like yo it was a
short-term thing but it was just like ah
you know i couldn't do this long term
because the mentality is different when
you said when you said restaurant and
like decide not intensive journal so all
right i might not personally like be
like super concerned about body count
you don't want to know one number though
i i kind of care a lot about though
how many followers though on instagram
like check me out because this like
like and this is like and i don't know
how you have pro like so there's like no
no no hard offense but like okay
i'm ready to be offended
she has like 10 000 followers i won't be
like yo i'm not the only one in this
relationship i'm sorry like because she
she might be like she might be always
like oh i need to like i need to like
send out an update to like my fans or
like i need to respond to my dms i'm
like bro i'm trying to watch i'm trying
to sleep in and watch like [__]
movies like what the [__]
hey what does
what is that good like are those numbers
good i'm not really on instagram oh 11
um
i don't
i don't really post pictures i just
repost reels
and all that oh god no i'm like barely
confident enough to wear a bikini in
public you think i'm gonna put that on
instagram oh god no i don't know your
life
if it's just like
i'm just saying i don't know your life i
don't know what you're
no i know um
no it's it's funny though
that
like i i you don't get as many dms as
you would think like unless you have
like a very suggestive profile so yeah
about this because you're rich from yeah
[Music]
yeah because i'm like in college because
like so i don't know i think i have like
like i'm actually not very confident so
like the like stuff people post i'm like
i do not confident enough to like put
that out there like at all yeah it would
be so uncomfortable
why though if it's just like normal
stuff like i'm cool but like i'm in
college where like a lot of profiles are
like pretty suggestive and i'm not
saying like you [__] [__] go to hell
i'm not saying like i'm not like that
but it's just like yeah it's like too
much i see my sister's like generation
it's very much like oh my gosh
i'm like i do not
yeah i could not
but like what
i actually don't use instagram i don't
know 10 000 is a lot i was just thinking
like because i know like some people
here who have like
who are well
i i reserve your right to not want to
date a girl with 10 000 like that's
totally fine i'm not
i mean first first i have to get to the
stage let's be honest
[Laughter]
but like
so instagram followers is important what
about you guys what do you think about
that instagram followers
a girl's instagram what what matters
[__] i've never really thought about it
beyond like the content of the pictures
yeah
depending on the business she's running
the type of business
shoot bro uh what what bothers you more
the body count are being used for money
and favors
being used for money and favors money
what of course yeah money like don't you
can't i'm broke you can't you can't [__]
with the little guy
can be out there and million bodies i'm
okay a million but i mean you get
watched i say and i can just be like one
night thing but if you [__] with the
money like i already don't got a lot
like damn
okay would you rather would you rather
have a girl with all right let's say 20
bodies but you don't know any of them or
five bodies but you know all of them
20 bodies and don't know i need to know
these [__] because those 20
people they could be like some silica so
they can be some real sausage people
like what the [__]
i don't know we'll never meet them
okay if i don't meet them they out there
doing if they're out there just killing
other people then
all right
five bodies you know every single one of
them yeah so every single one like close
like
but it's only like it's five or twenty
right so four times the amount but you
will never meet any of them
what if they share details
especially
are you asking for details no no i'm
saying like what if that's just
something that comes especially if it's
something that you know she did for them
but she didn't do for you if it's a
stranger you would never know if it's
just a friend or something and that [__]
comes out and i was just being corny a
little bit i need this i'm sorry i was
being corny with the whole like fighter
if you're around a woman who genuinely
desires you they you you know it
like they they don't hide it
they don't hide what
is that well
on the uh on the whole body count issue
what if you're the best one
you know what i mean
like if she's been with 100 guys but you
know for sure you're the best one
like you've brought her [__] work
[Music]
how are you finding out if you're the
best one
i'm saying assuming you know
how you're like
you're the best one
you probably won't but i'm saying if you
assuming you did know right off the bat
like just somehow you know you're the
best one does that make it okay
you don't know this isn't a real this
isn't this is a fantasy type thing
bear with cocky fingers
that sounds like a real life thing
so real life coffee real life talking so
if you're the best one
it doesn't matter if you're the best one
assuming
i think if you're worried about if
you're the best night it does matter but
you know
yeah no
you have to think about that though if
you don't get a girl that's on board
with you there's always going to be
someone better than you yeah but no
one's talking about whether the woman
participates or whether it's not making
all the effort you know so it is like
you're the best one up until that point
there
that's more important than body count
which is which can't be determined
anyway
yeah say it again
like everyone's talking about body cod
you're not talking about whether it
makes any effort or if you're making 100
of the effort
it's already
used for money and favors no one talks
about talking about so you're saying
does she actually help you over quantity
is that what you mean
if she desires you you wouldn't be
making 100 of the effort
and
she's just a lazy hoe in there
damn
the lemonade is going in
well my background is as an internet
troll so it's just natural for me
i'm i mean i'm a [__] story too i can't
even say anything
yeah i mean
it sounds like you're leaning more to
like conversations of relationships
well
like if she's at the point
you're worried about the bodycon because
you're settling for a mediocre
relationship
and and you know for a fact that you
probably had a really better
relationship with someone else in the
past i mean but uh i have a question so
would is there any number of bodies that
would bother you so it like it could be
any number like a hundred
a mediocre
uh i don't really think about the body
kind of mediocre relationship is what
would bother me
so okay well basically if he didn't
didn't genuinely desire me
tolerated for a second i'd find a woman
oh yeah
i'm out of 100
[Music]
i think i got him but he can speak i'm
saying i'm saying i think cold steel is
confusing
uh
mediocre was simple and peaceful
are they the same i'm playing here's an
example
as
i was friends with a girl
she was pretty attractive and then
we
went on a date
and i asked her if she wanted to make
cotton no
and then
at that point i didn't care what her
body was
you know
that she didn't want to make out
even on
you said she didn't try
i didn't i didn't care what her body
count was
oh because
you got to add
but you got to add great details though
because like body language the way the
conversation was going you smell good
request made you not care about her body
account is that what you said no it made
me not want to see her again i didn't
notice a body camera
but for me
she's not interested in you i
i mean that's what it sounds like
yeah sounds like a bad day
just take that and learn from it like
you got to understand body language how
you conversate eye contact like what is
the address how you approach like yeah
setting the venue
um yeah
the way she's just the way she's
interacting with you back like if it's a
back and forth thing that means she's
interested with you
but like
if she's very stale and very short then
maybe she's not getting into she just
wants a free meal
oh
it didn't matter
what didn't matter did you still pay
right did you still pay for the date
uh
okay hold on hold on yes
mac it's your time to go i'm sorry
damn i was going to say 50. i it raises
eyebrows i'll be like damn you get
around but that's it but uh okay
i gotta drop off fellas but uh that's
okay mac you get to stay look at that oh
[__] just kidding
i'm surprised you haven't kicked me off
yet thank you brother i appreciate your
sacrifice i do it in order unless you
have your camera on because that makes
better quality so it's like i just do it
in the order of when you got on it's
like i i used to have my camera on i
mean seen how it looked like but
but it's not it's not about that it's
about like it's it's a very
self-beneficial like thing no i i get it
i was just saying right now i see people
it's better so
yeah
yeah i was just saying i can clip [__]
better okay um yeah
okay right now
okay hold on one second uh go for it
um dc hi
what's going on welcome back bro
what's up man i'm good how are you
i'm doing great uh if the other dude who
was saying he asked the girl if she
wanted to make out i was i was going to
say to him you don't have to say no i'm
back i'm just this just me it's just
something i'm saying to you like i
wouldn't ask a girl
um hey do you all want to make out i
wouldn't do it if i was you i would just
let it happen naturally you know
so
yeah oh okay well never mind
but well
at least from a child
who
what are you asking mac
who's dropping a beta song club
i haven't done anything
a mustache is that you you over there
smiling
oh my god this is low budget i don't
have
i don't even have a full phone wall okay
i can't afford to step your game up
you're back on facebook i got the screen
so i'm assuming you have a channel
osmosis
yeah yeah yeah i just started the
channel
okay your setup is nice it's better than
mine actually it's like really nice i
really budget amazon do a lot for you
yeah i'll post a video soon about how
much everything cost but it's not
okay sorry dc what is your uh what is
your opinion on the topic
yeah i think it does affect you whether
or not what i think the buy account does
they know it or not just because take
care like
the people
having sex with people before
having sex people before you're married
the more people you have sex with it
just statistic been proven that your
relation you're you're a lot less likely
to be with a long-term
relationship uh
you'll have more soul ties and your it
just shows that in the case of women in
particular especially females it's just
more difficult to have a successful
relationship when you've had multiple
partners so i think it still affects you
okay so
so you would care even if you never
found out or saw any signs of it because
we're not we're not talking about in
generalities like we're not talking
about like because what you're saying is
like it still affects you because you'll
see the effects of it like you won't as
good of a relationship but what i'm
saying is that didn't happen
i'm saying you you don't see any
signs of that
oh so you're asking like
if you never find out yeah
oh no i would like to know yeah
yeah okay
from the beginning if you want to know
at the start
second question hold on um second
question
um
do you think like it matters if a guy
cheats on a girl
like if she never finds out
yes
okay so you're consistent at least
i'm going to cosign that's bummy as hell
like what the [__] you doing
yes i i do i do think it matters um if i
got cheats on the girl because
man like
they'll talk in the manosphere about how
high value men exercise options and you
know i understand exactly where they're
coming from and that's true that at the
same time if you're going to be in a
relationship with somebody
and you cheat on that person like
the reason okay people talk about how
all throughout history women have been
with high value men they share men okay
those women share men because of
survival purposes
like nobody in their heart wants to get
cheated on you know what i'm saying so i
think it would be negligible to cheat on
your spouse and me personally like even
one of my best friends is a psychologist
with two phds and me and him we're
talking and what he said he's done
marriage counsel he says when somebody
cheats on somebody the relationship is
never the same and i'm gonna be i'm be
real with you if
a female was okay with me cheating on
her
unless she is like from mexico or from
somewhere in saudi arabia or something
like that if she's okay with me cheating
on her um
there there's a problem there because
do you mean like do you mean like paulie
go for it what i'm saying is like when i
say a female is okay with it i'm not
talking about
she'll deal with it but she doesn't like
it i'm talking about she legitimately
like yeah you can go ahead and cheat
like there will be an issue with that
unless she's from like some foreign
country or maybe the way her family was
raised that's how it was because it's
just completely unlike my friend says
the relationship is never the same even
if they're happy again the level of
trust and the level of intimacy once
that's been breached like stuff just
ain't the same anymore and that's coming
from a man with tons of experience so
yeah yeah but you're talking kind of in
two sides you're talking you said high
value yeah they're cheating like if if
if she's aware up front
that's a little different than you just
being shady and being like i'm yeah then
going out and she finds out you're just
dealing with other women because not all
women are about that but if she knows
those are kind of two different things
that you're talking about so which which
side are you really saying you're on
yeah so cheating yeah i get it that's
different because if you have
expectations it's not even just cheating
just expectations in general being
broken
is way different than something somebody
gave you a manual up front said this is
what it's going to be
and then you already have the the chance
to conceptualize that in your mind
you won't feel the same emotion
yeah that's that's different i'm not
talking about that i'm talking about
just straight up just straight just
straight up cheating you know what i'm
saying i'm not talking about where
people sit down and come to an agreement
you know and okay it is different i
still don't think the fear i don't think
any i don't think any female like i said
unless you grew up in
unless you grew up in a certain country
i don't think any female is like oh
you're gonna cheat okay that's fine i
think they'll be like
i'll weigh my options out and then
that's me personally
i think there's a type of i think
there's a type of girl that
just knows that's how guys are and
that's how she feels like oh guys are
going to do it anyway
yeah and that's what i'm saying
i think that's a small i think that's a
small percentage though like i think
what you're saying is true and that
exists but for the most part i think if
a female
is okay with you doing that
i think she's with you for your money it
says if you were an average dude
if you were an average dude and you were
to just do that i don't think a lot of
women would accept it is what i'm saying
so that's all i got to say
so is is it like cheating just like you
like you say like yeah oh baby it's just
me meanwhile you got like six people in
your dms right now like
sort of deal
because being just cheating just being
deceptive yeah like not being not
telling not saying what's really going
on
i'll say that is the that is probably a
slim i i think it's not as much about
uh
[Music]
i think it's more about the you say
average guys average guys
don't want to approach most average guys
want multiple women is that true or not
yeah that's true and they know that they
tell a girl that they're not going to
get
yeah i'm a woman so it's not really
about the woman not being on the program
you don't i think it's mainly about the
guys not even wanting to shoot the shot
to be honest at risk of risking the poon
of what they got right yeah they just
want what's in their bag
they don't want to fumble the bag
i've been and i'm saying i've been with
women that are cool with that
up front and usually when you get into
the relations part of it they get a
little bit like it takes more like
reprogramming
but
up front like if you say it like they're
usually kind of cool about it but you
can only say that if you're cool with
just losing the girl after you say it
yeah
talking about average guys aren't going
to say that and at the risk of their own
detriment of like i'd rather have one
than be greedy that's kind of weird
wait is that what you do you like tell
girls you're gonna have sex with other
girls no i just it's not even like that
there's a whole i mean you have to kind
of
it's not a it's not so overt like that
right yeah it's like first is it like
first date look
like like it's not just
i just got questions i feel like that's
kind of expected it's not first date
it's not even third fourth day it's just
like
you work your way into it right so it's
like first day you're kicking it
whatever
if you kind of gauge a girl like that's
okay with you
i'm gonna say it but just okay with you
kind of like objectifying another woman
kind of in her presence that kind of
gauges what life's about usually so if
i'm just like oh yeah she's kind of
she's kind of hot and she's like
co-signing kind of like yeah yeah she's
got a nice ass or whatever you're like
okay and then you know next date or
whatever you look surprised you you do
it again and it's like okay and then i
was like what do you think about and
like and you just keep going on like
that right and you go out and this this
is where men mess up
you just can't be greedy
and just like you go out say this is for
date you've already
met you've already you know you've
already had it of course you already
been involved
you know you go out or whatever it's
like that girl's cues like
there's some trolling stuff that you bet
you won't get
and most women
because they don't see how we see it
like if a girl told me like bet you
won't kiss that guy it's like yeah of
course i wouldn't but most women don't
see you like that like y'all would do it
and they will more chances than not if
you've been cool and you haven't been
asking about body counts and being weird
with her
then usually they'll they'll go they'll
go do it and that kind of opens the door
up
to be like okay
yeah
so you'll say
like she'll say i bet you won't kiss
that girl or like how does
this i think we're talking i think i
misheard you at first yeah we're talking
about in the setting if we're out at a
ball okay
yeah
and she's kind of obviously we both have
drinks like we've already we've already
broken the barrier of like openly
talking about other attractive people in
our presence oh and it's not like a
weird conversation because you haven't
really pulled back in that aspect and
just been like all googly i like i'm
only about you like obviously we're not
relationship i still see attractive
women i'm out with you
okay but you know and i'm respect you
i'm not
is this just a situation chip because it
doesn't sound like like you're dating
these girls it just sounds like it's not
not yet no no no no it's just games okay
okay playing the foundation right
because because in the long run right
you're not really going to get in a
relationship with i mean this is just
i'm going to speak for myself i'm not
really trying to get a relationship
typically in the world i just want one
night
because women are kind of annoying too
so it's like if they
hang around
and you get in relationships right
yeah but
like once you get into the relationship
aspect already and now you start trying
to introduce these new concepts that
were never
even like dabbled in
it's different because now it looks like
you're trying to be greedy and she's
yeah she's not you're not who she
thought she was
you know those conversations are kind of
weird now because now she's yeah
and if she was even having the
inclination of being open to being about
that life
it's weird if you're trying to do it
she's completely closed off because
she's weird i'm not trying to share you
no more
so it's kind of like that and like i
said like when you do it early yeah you
might lose some people and she might
kind of you know depending on if they
what they say or not you might lose the
girl
overly about it yeah
but then you just kind of you kind of
throw it out there it's not easy i ain't
gonna say it it's not easy it isn't easy
but it just means you have to have the
confidence that how how old are you
30.
okay what percent of girls that you try
this on would you say works
i'm just trying to gauge like age-wise
in a relationship oh like age-wise no
not the girls i was just getting them
it's a pretty low percent shot it's like
a three-pointer i don't know
i'm not just like out in a relationship
twice and i'm just out and about like
it depends like if you're just casually
dating yeah it happens way more casually
than you know right yeah
i'm trying to okay
one of those ones
like i'm not happy
i'm not winning tough people i'm not
like i'm not trying to get into your
business or nothing but you know you've
been vulnerable enough at this point how
many females
have you tried that on that's what i'm
trying to figure out i'm saying out of
like oh have i tried any triathlon i've
tried done it twice in a relationship
one was dramatic and that's because i
handled it wrong because i was just
being way greedy about it
and
and then the other one was cool because
i was more upfront about it after the
disaster the first time
and then outside of that i think four
other times when i was in relationship
just like we're hanging out and
we're kind of
not a relationship but we've seen each
other on a regular basis like uh i'm not
claiming that my my girl nothing like
that so yeah that's what i'm talking
about
and that happened that happens more
often in that scenario when your
relationship is a little different
because
obviously
you can't like
there's more uh massaging of the
emotions when you're relationship like
they gotta kind of know like yeah i'm
not running off with nobody i'm not this
is a us thing it's not like a me thing
like yeah
and that's that's that's what i'm
talking about from that standpoint
i get the percent thing the percent
thing's weird but i just felt like
yeah i was just i was just curious
that's all i don't it's not like like
that i'm mainly saying you don't know
until you do it but because guys are so
scared
yeah do that up front yeah i didn't
think that magically after you get this
girl in love with you that she's just
going to flip the script and be like i
want to be a freak out for you it's not
it's not
[Music]
yeah
and that means borderline disrespectful
at that point because you haven't
established something it's like a
culture shock and like now she's
she's losing basically everything she
invested because she just found out that
you're trying to push whatever like most
women don't go it's almost kind of like
fraud a little bit like she was
investing but then you kind of like oh
this i'm gonna change up real quick yeah
you caused it to pull back
yo pearl like
this this is my question for you if you
had a dude and he approached you
like
you had a dude and he approached you
and
like he took the perch to osmosis said
he said that you're going to share me
with other females you can just say it
like that but he took the ease into it
option that he did
let's say if a dude who was
five foot eight that you liked
just all the way in the street that's
five for that i'm like yeah that's
that's he's already lost
yeah
it's that it's it's not i'm six foot
like
okay so that would automatically be off
okay but what i'm saying like i just
think that
if a female and this ain't everybody i'm
just talking about most
if a female
is okay
and
and in terms of not okay as in mentally
i enjoy it but if a female is willing to
go along with the man cheating on them
i think
it has to do
more with his status and his money
because if a average dude let's say if
he did have the guts to say that
i don't think the female would run with
it and that's why i would be leery if a
female would be willing to try that with
me that's why i say that
can i answer that real quick or try to
go
i guess uh my interpretation is kind of
like yeah you got to be the reason why
you can't be over with it like take for
example like if i just went into like
some random club like hey anybody trying
to [__] it's like yeah i mean like and
y'all everybody can see how i look so
i'm not i'm not like ass ugly so there's
probably going to be at least like a few
people in there are going to be like
yeah you know oh mac that guy he's a
little cute but if i just go in there
and be like hyper like up front just
like kick your door and like it's just
hella weird so you can turn off a lot of
people when you're trying to like have
these conversations i don't know
i went to a pickup boot camp
bro they have those yeah but even though
i did yeah i saw a video yeah i saw the
video but like even then like unless
like okay unless you're like a
hypothetical like chat thunder [__] or
whatever people said like unless unless
unless you're like like chat starter
[__] if you just go up to like if you're
like me regular guy you go up to a girl
like hey you just you're trying to [__]
you're going
she's gonna look at you like
oh yeah [__] who the [__] are you
unless like she's like really horny then
dennis
also saw us because it's like okay why
did you say yes like
that's not what osmosis is about oh my
god i didn't mean i didn't even know
yeah
i was just like yeah that doesn't work
unless you're a female and you're
talking about matching physicality for
physicality like women don't operate in
that manner
where are you man you can't
no dude is going to walk up to a chick
and say that in a like a girl can do
that and she'll probably
have to be attractive
and she'll get to do that about that
life but dude
i'm not saying you're not being sneaky
i'm just saying
you just you just it's like building
rapport with her yeah that's what i yeah
yeah
depends on the dude it's not i mean
he taught money right like when all
these situations happen to me i was only
making 80k 100k yeah
that's like the top like 15 percent of
earners well
it's not like they knew how much money i
was not like i i showed like
what's your job title
uh naviance
aviation avionics tech like a driver
pretty good job
yeah i think like girls like we kind of
go off of jobs so yeah job like we just
what's the best one but then yeah i
didn't mean to misspeak i was just
trying to say like if you're so like
blunt about it in a way that that can
kind of hurt your rapport because like
it's like just with like certain
conversations like if you're just like
super blunt about it it's it's very
different to what everyone's doing so it
starts getting other people thinking
like damn why is he so [__] fun about
it at least that's my interpretation i
mean blind there's there's there's
there's spaces where blunt works with
women it's not yeah yeah not like that
like
you can be blunt i'll go ahead oh just
hold on one second john
hi
how are you
fine
um
so do you know what the topic is
i believe i think i got the gist of it
it's about
the sharing
yeah like do you um we're actually a
little off topic does body count matter
if um if you don't know
okay or did you have something else you
could talk about what we were talking
about now that's fine what did you have
to add go ahead
well
well the only time i think most women
will accept the guy being honest
if like honesty like honesty is only
accepted by from like women only except
honestly if the guy is like tall and
good looking
uh
i'm five he's not a good looking guy
it's a higher percentage she'll accept
it right away
she's more likely to accept it from him
doesn't mean she'll
all do it all the time
but the chances are a bit higher for him
for
he has to have something it doesn't
necessarily yeah
he does have to have something like that
like no girl's gonna
yeah
what's the number one thing i have seen
girls sent for bombs so i'm not even
gonna
homosexuals is a thing you know that
exists but it's not no it's not i don't
think i got somebody like
yeah didn't you say you're an engineer
i'm just i'm just i'm just
trying to keep the banter going but
yeah but i'm saying like the guy has to
have something like he's not he can't
have nothing and the girl's gonna simp
for him like
he has to have something
so
um
like he's either like a good face i
don't know a good job like the way he
carries himself like no girl's gonna
simp for a guy that has nothing going
for him like i think that's just common
just like you guys aren't going to simp
for a girl that's 300 pounds
like i would i mean
you don't know what i see
oh [__] oh [__]
he over here like i like that uh
6 000 life or whatever it's called on
tlc
look at it it just comes with the girl
values like yeah exactly like
like for example i have a friend who
values like relationship with god like
that's her number one thing it's like
what is his relationship with god like
i have another girl that's sent oh my
god she would cheat on her boyfriend
with this guy that was like
i don't even know why he was like kind
of cute i guess but
like he was literally going nowhere in
life but it just depends on something
wait what was he doing was he like
working at mcdonald's or like
no he just he was at my college and
he was just one of those guys that you
know he couldn't afford to like be there
so like because there's a lot of damn
no no no no i'm saying this like in the
most like empathetic way possible like a
lot of people don't know what that
they're signing up for when they go to a
private university
like like i got lucky my parents could
afford i felt hella attacked by that but
i'm not no i'm knowing i'm saying this
like you're you're getting listen listen
before you get like
one of
what i'm saying is that
like if you get a degree with a good roi
that's one thing but like he didn't and
he was still filling out of his classes
and i like he didn't come from a great
area
so like i can't imagine that's like the
road to success
right
but
for you he was like charismatic so i
think that's like he had like game or
whatever like charming
it could work for him right well that i
mean i'm just saying it depends like
what the girl
values i mean yeah for one mostly
situation i've been in i've never
forced anything like i basically i'm not
usually in the pro i don't usually
approach like if they're not showing
interest i'm not talking
so that's another thing like they're
already kind of semi interested in you
yeah yeah and it's just like i don't do
really a lot of validating in the sense
of like i'm not being like a dick or
nothing but i'm just not like
overly complimenting like and i've had
like a girl come up and then like
literally all night try to bait and
switch you to like boost them up like i
had a girl kind of talk and just we're
talking we're chilling and she's like i
think i said something like i gotta walk
to my truck i'm not going back to your
truck and i was like why would i want
you come back to my truck i said i'm
walking you can yeah i'm like my man
kept doing that she was like just kept
coming further in to like he's not
giving me the attention i'm wanting and
she just and like i said it's like that
not forced interview kind of opens those
doors up
i'm not nothing crazy well it's
you're treating her like she's human
yeah girls don't want a guy that like
puts us on a pedestal
like i used to be like in high school
like writing the letters and doing all
the
the letters no
look you know
well man
my mom made she grew me up as a good man
as a sweet boy i used to believe in all
the love stories until like you take a
couple l's and you realize like you went
all new edition on them yeah um
okay sorry bc go ahead
all right so i just want to know from a
female perspective i have my ideas but i
want to know from a female perspective
you know female locker room talk how
emotional
[Laughter]
like how strongly are you pocket
watching a man
females like your experience you know
what i'm saying
um
how are you watching
the tour show that it matters a lot i
thought she was gonna say a different
statue bro because you said locker room
talk i'm just gonna keep it up stack
uh well i think
to me social status and like um
income or different things
um i would say i would say that it's
more like if a guy has his life together
than like income alone
um but i don't know i'm like young so i
would never expect any guy to make
anything crazy at this point in my life
i'm 25. i think i made like 50 000 at my
old sales job so like
you're only 25
yeah i thought you were uh never mind
damn what are you gonna say okay you're
gonna get
i thought you were 26 which is close
because tory's 26 sorry
was that a gunshot
i don't i don't take that too seriously
i don't care it's not like i thought you
were like 30 or something yeah i've i've
been oh my gosh i get it
i've always been told i look older also
i'm going to say that
this is going to sound hella sauce but
wait pro i believe early you say you
don't you don't wear makeup right
no not really
wait really
damn that's right i have some good skin
thank you thank you thank you no i mean
i got like this on my head so i don't
know
it's like i'm just not very girly it's
like a bad thing like i'm kind of lazy
and i'm cheap so it's like a really bad
combination yeah i know i really hate
spending that [__] is not cheap
it's so expensive like they're trying to
they're trying to use four or five
different types of makeup just to cover
up my skin yeah you gotta get like just
try to eat better and get better you
gotta get like concealer
contour eye shadow to get rid of that
i only know i know i know my focus i'm
like wait why does mac know all this
like i'm a stagehand so like i
mean plus i go to dermatology all the
time i i gotta fix this somehow so
anyway
do you use filters hey progress is the
process
now right now this is just my camera um
on the only place i use filters on is
tick tock i do use the smoothing on
there and it's because i feel like the
videos get better views i would probably
do it if i knew how to do it on youtube
i'm not gonna lie
but yeah that's it
i probably would i'm not above it i'm
just lazy so
money's money i can't
i can't i can't hate nobody getting
money like
you know hey
man that's right you know girl yeah wait
what's your question for pearl again
i think dc laughed and he was asked the
question
like i feel like a lot of a lot of
people keep mentioning the money thing
and it's just like but also in the same
woman to use you for your money
and just like if that's how you're
coming in the game why would she not
want that like why would she why would
she want anything further than that
[Laughter]
i 100 agree i just i'm lazy i'm not
going to i know me i am who i am
it just is what it is
we all got our own hustle so i can
it's like because you have to like
invest time into like following the
trends and getting good at it now i mean
i know so i'm like [__] bolding too
like i gotta do a lot i gotta work on a
lot of [__]
i'm sorry but i do think you're right
like i know a lot of girls that sympt
for very broke guys like very broke
i gotta i got a question too today do
they like let them uh move in with them
because i i got a theory like i've seen
that a lot no no yeah homosexuals bro
like what the [__] is up with that [__]
didn't you do that once
oh my god he's dead
but he was he was a millionaire i just
he was like a homeless god damn
holy [__]
y'all being aggressive i'll tell you no
i'll tell you that uh i'll tell you the
story it's like kind of a crazy story he
was homeless when he blew up on tick
tock so he was um
he it was it was i i kind of like fell
for him because um i felt he like had no
parents and i felt like like i never met
someone that had that lack of like
little like parental guidance i guess so
i was like trying to help him because he
had all this money but he didn't get an
apartment because he didn't have an id
yeah because and he couldn't get an id
how do you get an id you have to live
somewhere but he was living in his car
before he got like famous
i
so what i did was i like brought him to
my parents house and they put him on the
lease so he stayed there while he got
and then uh then like that way i helped
him get an id
and then he got an apartment
and then like i helped him like figure
that so i kind of but
like how long were you together after
you helped him out
a year like we were together a year i
think i did that the first
like month we were dating i i was kind
of i'm kind of a sucker like not a
sucker but i'm very empathetic so did he
get his id
yeah
we'll see that's a little different like
if there's like that's different it was
only a month like then he got yeah
yeah and for me that's not for me a
homosexual is like a guy who like only
like sleeps around just to have a place
to live like if you're like in an actual
relationship that's something different
like that's that's so that's why when
y'all like brought up her boyfriend i
was like damn that's hella aggressive
right now like
i'm like
i didn't date him because i felt sorry
that was just one of the ways i got to
know him yeah i was like yeah y'all
didn't have to go there
something more oh my god
oh [__]
what are you saying
for that
i didn't even hear it
he did the beta girl
oh [__]
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up
are you trying to fix this poor man
no not the okay the first no the first
guy was in college that was normal like
he wasn't he was a normal guy i just
like he was looking for jobs and like
you criticized the other guy that didn't
have his life together though a minute
ago
no i'm saying like a lot of times like
that's the turn off i guess not for me
maybe i got like issues i don't know
but um
i'm saying like like both of those guys
there was still like captain saber
oh
he held that job for like five years
like he's had it for a while like it
wasn't so he was just having a rough
month and you helped him out no okay no
no but you have to understand my parents
are in the top like half a percent of
earners like i know a lot of people so
why would i not help you if i can
that's what he said
like
i'm just saying like
i'm like a helpful person like i always
like i know these girls helpful i'ma ask
for a job
they didn't ask like i just do i mean
i mean [__] i mean i'm i mean [__] i can
pull up my wells fargo i'm [__] broke
what's up
[Laughter]
you're giving off that vibe right now
you don't grow out of things like that
at 25.
damn
you're gonna get you're gonna this sass
is gonna get you botted i'm not even
gonna lie to you it's gonna get me what
hey i get it it's not it's not true
i got it
i know it's gonna kill me
i can't
read faces but i can't but i can't read
voices
from your voices
pearl how did she meet tori by the way
how did i meet tori yeah
i met tori i dm'd her and we figured out
we lived in the same area like we're
from the same area
so you're like oh you you um one mile
away if you know what i'm saying but
wait no no it was not it didn't land
my bad that was that was that was the
air ball but um
[Music]
i was just i just saw her pop up in like
my video feasible i was like like who is
she like and then she was associated
with you i guess or
so she's the crazy red pill lady but
she's cool
not me
huh the crazy black lady
no
i mean if she if she's black then like
what what where do i live in like not as
white as pearl but still white damn
and you know the fingers
gonna kill me
today
she made me promise i'd be really nice
to you and here i am just
you know
being a dick damn did we do we gotta
give tory to n word pass like it's okay
i wouldn't say that okay
i don't know if you've noticed i don't
really get offended that easily you
don't
like
other people rant about the things i say
but you're really chill about it
lemonade is over here rubbing his hands
together like oh you don't get here
here's the thing i already like don't
have high self-esteem so like you can't
knock me down too much because it's like
oh that's swift
not in like a bad way like i just feel
like like you should be aware like i
don't know
like the shields are up like like i'm
not too good to be made fun of like
did you know that people have siblings
growing up
i did i mean i did what i was thinking
of each other that's i have nine
siblings i'm just i'm just
i'm just a cornball like i just don't
[__] care so like
i think
six feet tall has to be tougher
i think it's more just having like
growing up between two boys i don't
think i'm ugly oh my gosh no you're not
ready
i don't know
no that's just the comments i'm just
like i don't think oh [__]
i just like i just genuinely feel like
like
i'm not too good to be made fun of like
if you're on a public platform like
you're gonna get made fun of who cares
yeah i mean i already know people's
people's talking [__] that's cool
because i talk [__] about them too is we
all joke about each other it's all good
so yeah but you gotta know
what yeah because some people be yeah i
i get you because some people be like
really mean and action i'm like okay i
mean that's fine if that's just how you
play around but if someone's not like
that and then you come at them like that
like i've done that to people i've done
that to youtubers and they're like yeah
yeah badly they're like what the hell
dude and i'm like
i thought you were tougher than that
here's the thing like if people get
offended i'm not i'm not going to even
be like oh man i was joking i was like
i'm like no i'm just an [__] like
you're gonna jump on so
like
i don't know because for me for me
since pearl uh didn't i tell you what i
did was i mentioned it before
what say that again i mentioned it
before didn't i tell you what i deal
with on uh deal with
oh
i don't i think i remember you um and
like
well
what was that wait what are you going to
answer or
wait what what's going on
um i'm saying like
since i deal with autism
oh yeah
yeah
it's for me for me some sometimes is it
sometimes since
since i can't read facebook but i i
focus on voice
vocal inflections i kind of i i kind of
read the emphasis
the basic
basically the level of most you put on
certain words
that allows me to tell how you're
feeling
so like so like when it comes to people
joking i usually just stay quiet but
most of the time i don't i'm not too
keen on catching catching on to it
yeah body account determines that you
know
we all got our own hustle and
i don't mean this comparison or our side
side track in a defensive way at all but
um it's like some
active more active viewers i guess
probably know
um what was it yeah so 13 months ago i
had a
stroke on the right side of my brain so
this is obviously
autism is just a learning disability
it's not a cognitive impairment so
that's just to say for myself i have my
own difficulties with communication now
like i mean because like a year ago i
had to like learn english and i'm
american and it's my native language i
lost german and french those things are
just [__] gone
so like now nowadays it was just like
you know i'm gonna be and say and look
how i'm gonna look like i i ca i can't
only worry about so much [__] so like
i'm just out here having fun so that's
all i really wanted to say i'll probably
either make people really depressed
really offended or really
creeped out or all three so there you go
you said you're in a relationship
who me yeah oh [__] no
no i'm too i'm too uh down right now uh
mentally and i'm just busy so
like i gotta
my friends told me since i'm too blunt
most girls will take what i say the
wrong way or as being insulting
i don't think that's true
i'm i'm pretty blunt when i mean
my friend my friend's girlfriend
oh brow bat i first met her first do you
know what the first one that came out of
my mouth
did you call her fat
no alien
damn
your friend's girlfriend
yeah like yeah
[__]
i met her i was like oh she looks like
an alien
well that's not a girl i mean that's not
great trying to get though what about a
girl you're actually trying to be i
would have been like bumblecloth or some
[__]
i wasn't trying to be mean or anything
it didn't it just did that's the first
thing that popped into my head and just
blow that out can you just say it it'd
be like that sometimes i i couldn't
relate sometimes
sometimes i just say some real [__] up
[__] out loud and people look at me like
i'm like uh
or or like people people like all
throughout high school people with
people i was known to be like less
emotional less emotionally more
more
like logical i guess i guess that's kind
of like yeah go for it
more more cold more cold like
meaning if a girl asks me do you think
i'm ugly like i'm fat i'm like yeah yup
yup
you're literally asking for it you know
what's the worst that's what i do i'm
like yeah [__] you [__] like
there's a time in the place for that
okay if it's like in the middle of a
class and i'm no one talking i'm gonna
be like yeah [__] you ugly but if it's
like me just like joking around like
yeah
you're actually trying to do this
you're not that bomb like not like rude
but you might just have to drop it you
could do better
my mic's still on
i like it
like you could do better than
i do
because
because at some point because at some
point
i kind of got in trouble for it
so
yeah yeah yeah i think it's more about
how you say things than what you say
actually
yeah
if you say it kind of yeah i don't know
like i said you said that same thing and
said though you could do better but like
yeah
it kind of would leave her with a pause
of like is he seriously not serious but
like i think he's locally serious
because that's how she probably really
feels and this is like trying to get a
job right like trying to get a
relationship right
sorry i was having mic issues
like girls and stuff okay yeah like that
type of trouble i thought i thought it
was like hr or some [__] i was like oh
damn better
evening was dealing with because dealing
with women is
for me since since um
what i deal with game or having charm is
harder for me
yeah harder for me will be off bad
so what i'm trying to so
you be amazed you how many girls hit on
me and like like like a year later like
oh
she was hitting on me like it was it
took me a whole year to figure it out
and they expect you to figure it out
and they stuck around and then huh
i hate that [__] low-key like figure it
out i'm like [__] i want to play
okay
okay there's this guy that i worked with
sort of like he was at a different
branch but like i was in sales so
sometimes you bring like another sales
person with you that like specializes in
a certain product because we sold like a
lot and he um
yeah and then he
asked if we could get coffee
like before or after something i forgot
and
i didn't i just didn't realize until
later like he asked me on a date like
until he texted me and was like oh it
was so fun
i was like
was that a date i was like
the shot was too smooth
the shot was too smooth like was there a
second date
no no
no
there wasn't even a colonel referral
there was never a first date
i i wouldn't have even been opposed if
he was more like i don't know just the
way he went about it i was like you
almost said hot didn't you
like you would have been more you
wouldn't have been supposed if he was
hotter but he kind of stopped he wasn't
a bad looking guy i just didn't yeah
i was moving too so it kind of made like
i knew i was moving to england soon so i
was like i'm not
i don't know
yeah he's playing the that's the thing i
was talking about earlier about being
for like he's obviously like being too
overt but if you were moving i probably
would if he was he should have been way
like more aggressive yeah
he didn't know that i wasn't telling
people in my work how do you how do you
know that like why would i well i'm
saying because no one at my work knew
because okay okay so we thought he
thought he had time to take his time is
what you're saying like why would i why
would i tell people i'm quitting like
soon but that follow-up text is weird i
would i mean i would never do that
that's just weird you wouldn't tell
someone you had a good time on the date
well i mean if if you thought he was
going to play the long game like that
because he's completely broke in the
movies like you just kind of like most
women you grow on like you just
invite it to coffee that's next time and
kind of elevate the scenarios and where
you're inviting her to no i wouldn't
just text her after a coffee date
afterwards and be like i had a great
time
like people go out after work all the
time like yeah
if it's a work thing it definitely
starts off with like a like a hangout
and then it's like you know
gotta use it and we didn't we didn't
live like i thought it was just to get
to know each other before like the
appointment because we didn't like live
like he was in the chicago office i was
in milwaukee so it was like we're not
i don't know
milwaukee
what
i've been to milwaukee
yeah
yeah yeah i've lived here for like two
years what's it like
not much to see in my opinion
i actually like it
that was all right
if you think he was more honest about
being interested in you intimately you
would have entertained it
yeah i think no no i think i would have
if i wasn't moving i wasn't trying to do
anything because i was moving
yeah i've been there but
everything
well and like you got a million things
going on but i actually didn't end up
moving for a year so had he been
because my season got cancelled
so that was like in the fall and then i
was supposed to move in january and i
quit my job in like october
and then um
yeah so
by then i kind of forgot about it but
yeah if he was up front like probably
i hate being in that position because
uh it's so weird like both on your end
and his end it's like i'm also what's
weird
just like well like being in the
position of pearl you're thinking you're
like about to move because that's like
my current position and i spent my
position for like the past two years
because i was originally i was uh not
only do i study engineering but in the
past i was also a german study major so
i was going to i was planning to study
abroad to finish out my education in
germany uh i think you guys all know how
well that went i mean it's uh
like tennis here i'm not i'm not in
germany right now
and
like i was always just thinking like oh
you know not getting any sort of
relationship i'm not really doing
anything because i'm gonna be overseas
for two years
and then now it's like well [__] i'm
gonna be graduating and i'd i've kind of
did that been there with the whole kind
of like sleeping around at least here so
i was like uh now i'm in just like in
this position where i just like say
whatever the [__] i want and i just kind
of get known as like the class clown
slash [__] so
blue pill unplugged my bad little
comment about being aggressive he said
he said if you're aggressive you should
report your hr i didn't say groper she
can't be more honest yeah
all
right i just had a friend to get report
someone to hr that actually just
happened to someone i know
was it like
was it like something serious
was it just flirting
[Music]
okay i'm gonna mute you because
um
you just unmuted yourself with
oh i that the captain now
uh sorry
sorry my sister my little sister walked
walked up to me and said can you make me
pisa and i was like uh i was trying to
get her away from me hey bro what time
is it over there
damn it's kind of late to make a [__]
pizza but all right
yeah
if she feels uncomfortable you'll have
to have a discussion with hr
yeah i think he just basically like hit
on her
and she failed
but i think she told them to stop a
couple oh okay
okay
i think it was like i think it was like
they were friends and he would like
flirt with her and then she'd be okay
and he had a girlfriend and so
and so
when it like went to a certain point she
would like say stop
oh
and then like a couple weeks later he
would just like push it a little further
and then she'd be like okay stop and
like i think it just happened like too
many times like where yeah he felt
comfortable because they were friends
but then she was like oh that's weird
well
i don't know i
i thought you were saying it like this
girl or this chick went up to hr and
like hey can you can y'all get this like
little ugly [__] from asking me out
like
what do you guys think of that do you
think she should have reported him or
not she gave him several chances
yeah i was like
he that dude is weird like i don't i
don't really feel bad for him i'm not
gonna lie call me blue pill or whatever
no that's not blue pill it's just common
sense i respect it i mean look
i think most women should give
give the opportunity to tell the dude no
before you go to hr like if you tell him
no and he can persist i'm not mad at it
that's on the dude like if she said no i
just don't like when a girl is like
you know like girls kind of like what
she says why doesn't that yeah
semi segway flirt with you and you're
kind of trying to gauge what life she's
about so you take that plunge and be
like hey so what's
good he's like nah and it's like okay
cool i'm gonna fall back we're just
co-workers like that opportunity should
be able to exist yeah if she does not
know like that that's the hard deny and
you continue to push like yeah you
deserve yeah you were weirdo bro what
the [__] doing
okay okay now now i'm going to give you
another piece of information oh man oh
[__]
and complete story
i know now she did do all these things
right but i know the like behind the
scenes a little bit
okay and i know she had a little crush
on him
did she act on it in any way or express
it like anything that would be confusing
um i think girls have a hard time not if
they feel a certain type of way about
you but i don't think she actually like
did anything
i mean you said the guy has a girlfriend
so that right off the bat you know yeah
and i would have been around where he
shouldn't be that would have been a
little
i think
is she would probably like kind of i'm
guessing i don't know but i just i think
as a girl if you're like
friends with a guy and you feel a
certain type of way and you guys like
hang out like
i think
you're gonna have a hard time like not
flirting at some point
you know because girls are kind of just
flirty in general so what i'm guessing
happened is like she would probably
flirt like a little bit but he would
like push it like keep pushing it
further and then she'd be like stop you
know what i mean yeah
again being too thirsty
but he did get more than one chant like
he did tell him like okay like i feel
like you're flirting with me like you
have a girlfriend like whatever
women don't naturally first off her
walls are already gonna be up yeah
it's like yeah the long range game like
kind of like i'm just like kind of dip
dip dip into like we end up like saying
a a social party or something where she
might act on that because her feelings
are so involved now but like most girls
are not gonna
if you
if you have a girlfriend that they're
not going to just
want to feel like they got that
projection on them from judgment yeah
do you guys think that no means no with
a girl i mean for me unless you have a
safe word no means no
okay
i always hear guys say that if the girl
says oh i'm not going to sleep with you
like it's more likely that she's going
to sleep with you yeah
yeah
yeah i just i just keep it moving i i'm
my language deficit is too big right now
[Laughter]
well i mean like in a sense like i'm not
like
i'm not i'm not about to disengage i'm
just going to like not push
yeah i'm like okay
yeah whatever and you're just like on
your little flirty jazz but i'm not
going to like because when they say that
and again
what was the other oh he's off the
stream now but he's talking about the
high value man woman and a lot of stuff
and cheating it's like this is kind of
like why high value quote unquote men
don't prefer women that have a job
because the work husband thing exists
and like i haven't broken
8 hours a day 10 hours a day
like i'm with you more than your spouse
i'm just i'm i'm naturally just growing
on you all every day it i don't have to
there's no risk
because it's like you have to be around
me and i'm just going to charm you
eventually then until you you know fall
down but like when a girl say that just
like
that's almost them saying they want you
to try harder but what we're saying
about the whole hr thing it's like you
just don't try harder yeah
i'm just not going to be pushy until you
make a move i'm not about to like hey
because that's what i do i'm trying to
start impressing you because because
really like i said yeah women just
respond from just being around you so
it's like if you're just in the vicinity
and i don't recommend this typically
with workers i don't really get involved
with co-workers like that but
but yeah if you're just in well when i
was a server i used to all the time but
yeah okay okay yeah you're doing here
i see
infinity yeah it's just you you
naturally win just again like outside of
work inside of work like the pushy
thirsty like i want it now i want it now
thing just because she maybe gave you a
nibble like girls play games like that
all the time like they'll give you a
nibble to do with it and i swear as soon
as you bite they're like
i knew you was thirsty and they just
pulled it
and then you lose
the longest
that's i had a guy say this to me once
he's like girls are easy you just wait
three weeks
and don't try anything for three weeks
was he right
is there document evidence that this has
worked
where are the states i want to see the
facts so if you have
you have a girl right
you're you're complaining about your
girl this is a lesson i learned you
complain about your girl like
i don't like your friends i don't like
your co-workers you're talking this guy
and it's like whole time she could be
like
head over heels for you like while
you're doing all that bantering with her
like those dudes are just waiting in the
wing they're just like eventually and
then soon as like you get into it enough
with her and she's like done with you
those dudes are first in line and that's
where she's going so the dudes that you
were trying to stop
from from you were trying to you were
trying to aggressively stop her from
getting with once she's done with you
complaining about them she's going to
them anyways because they're just
orbiters like and a lot of women do this
like they just yeah they're not going to
be involved with these guys even if
they're interested in them if they like
you enough
but
eventually once it all falls down your
emotions get evolving like you've
already
pooped because you're being insecure
about it
those dudes are just like
like this this happened the other day
and it's not good this woman was married
but a friend of mine texted me in a
group chat oh [__] i wasn't expecting
that he was like oh uh that's something
you mentioned this girl like five months
ago or something like they kind of have
like this flirty thing
okay well whatever and he texted me like
two weeks ago i was like hey uh that my
neighbor like her husband just got
kicked out the house like the police
came and kicked him out and she said she
wants to talk it's time
now mind you that's six months of just
not being pushy and not trying and it's
like when her situation uh you know
dissipated
the door was open for him
no i that's that's actually true because
a girl feels comfortable with very
interesting she knows you like for me
it's like
i'm much more like likely to date a guy
that i've known a long time than a guy
that i just like met off of an app or
yeah
yeah women only do that when they're
heartbroken when they hop on the absent
like just blunt
yeah
broken when they plunge on dude like
that but so what are some
so what are some ways to mitigate that
risk of her doing that
wait the risk of ever basically
mitigating the risk of her going to
going to orbiters
oh no you can't
yeah i just can't be yeah
look you can't stop her bro like i gotta
you gotta grow your respect for her like
you know if you're cool like i guarantee
you if you were just like
don't [__] with them i don't care she's
gonna be like the hell
and she's not gonna do it because you
just don't care like even if you
wouldn't care
i don't
i don't always get people's emotions
so yeah
emotions aren't confusing to me
yeah me
oh you were saying earlier about the uh
the um
autism autism yeah yeah yeah
since emotions are confusing to me i
can't always read faces so that's
so
you know
if a chick is trying to cheat on you
that means you've been screwing up for a
long time
yeah you already
know
what i've seen i've seen i've seen i've
i've seen cases where the guy when he
was a good man
she still cheated that didn't really
matter if it was a good guy
define good guy
yeah
i know i know
he wasn't
he wasn't really
he wasn't getting cute he basically was
a good guy like he was friendly to
people he was friendly to her
he was never really
he didn't make her tingle
did you want it
no not really no
no he didn't give her everything she
wanted he gave her everything she needed
like well like rent or like
hey i'm gonna just hop in real quick uh
marcus is trying to get back into the oh
is he okay there we go hey there we go
hey guys i thought you guys are done
already continue no i don't i don't have
a life so
me neither talking about um
going john run the script
yeah keep running
basically what i've seen is he was a
good guy he was a good man but like for
some odd reason she still stepped out of
me
together they had their kids together it
was a good fall and all of that good to
his family doesn't care
okay look so
so what you sound what it sound like you
just told me is that he put on a
pedestal
she got nothing to chase for
and she's bored
that's how it goes boredom [__] over so
many people i gotta go on like a slight
rant about that but continue i don't
wanna
when you when you're saying like she's a
good man this is the tough part and
sorry no no disrespect to pro but it's
like bro women are sick in the head like
that like you can do all that
and and because
[__] again at the perfect time
bro
so so here's the thing you come in like
you see when women commit to you if
they're impressed with you right there
was something about you
maybe it could maybe it's not your
height maybe it's not your
your and all that stuff maybe something
there's something that she made her
commit to you right
when she gets that from you and you stop
kind of like being the guy like as soon
as you like drop down from like i was
trying to get her to
like i'm pedestal i want to make you
feel special
she's basically done with it like
there's no more like she's too secure
yeah it's like and she's going to chat
about how how are you going to keep that
up for like a lifetime you can't like
yeah you can't it's it's like a it's
like a drag habit like
what i mean
just like that like like he's chasing
you forever like i don't think she can
yeah but
this because because if you like her too
much and it's not like a chase i mean
it's not like a game i'm not talking
about strategies or games like you
genuinely have to like feel like you're
decent enough to have enough value to
the point that she should want to keep
you like if she doesn't feel like
there's a reason like that she needs to
keep you around then she's going to mess
around
you stay for a lifetime right about kind
of like trying to hunt and keep
interested
it's just like
all right you got you gave her the kids
you gave her the stuff and like
sometimes you just got here with the
just not doing it for me yeah not like
in those words but like if she's not
having to hunt for you then it's going
to be over for you she's going to look
for something else and then after she
gets it she'll probably come back after
she messes around but your pride will be
broken and you're not going to i don't
can't but can't but can't think for so
long
we ain't talking about that generation
can't that just be a woman to just
taking
that for granted the relationship
because you cannot you like you can you
could you could not be pedestalizing
somebody and the woman like you said
could be just getting bored as long as
you're pedestalizing a woman it could
just mean that she found simple and the
woman will confuse simple and and basic
and peaceful for boredom and then like
you said i agree with you when women can
somehow be twisted in the head that way
but can't the woman just take it for
granted and just not be grateful
well that's what i'm saying about we're
just like so
it sounds like he was better from his
scenario sounded like he's better spies
but yeah you're completely right
but it's just like you got to stop
giving as much like at some point you
got to be like hey i'm about to go out
and not explain why you're going out
yeah wait that's amazing i don't the
other thing i don't understand why do
you say that it's that generation when
that generation has like a 50 divorce
rate like they didn't do yeah right well
i'm gonna say look like let me pull back
it's not like like like i think i
mentioned this earlier about like how my
you know parents like raised me to be a
good guy and that it gave me all these
tools it's like a lot of the rules they
gave me to be successful like they were
successful in their particular
relationship right
was not stuff that worked for me
when i started dating when did they get
married
i'm probably
yeah i mean my mom was 19 and he was 21.
i think there's something about like
if people keep themselves to like a
certain level of innocence that like
like can't be undone once you do it like
on both ends actually like if a guy's
hooking up with like
all these girls for all of his twenties
like what are the odds yeah she's able
to stop cold turkey when he gets married
but it's it's it's like an addiction
also girls too so like
what well i don't
no it's um
but i think it goes both ways and it
seems like people that found their like
significant other when they were younger
seem to have like higher success because
my mom was 17 when she met my dad
um yeah and they've all and they both
like only had sex with each other like
don't ask me how i know that i don't
know why they told me but
i mean you're here so
yeah but i'm saying like it seems like
people that like get married younger
seem to like
have more success i don't know
can i speak on that real quick yeah go
ahead
so like my parents um my mother
when she got with my older siblings dad
because we have different dads and older
siblings than me
but when she got with them they were in
mexico they were in baja california over
there
um so she met him when
i guess she was like us in high school
16 17
yeah or a little bit before that and
then later on
she got pregnant while she was in high
school over there and over there in
mexico in certain countries you get
married at a younger age then i guess i
guess the my older siblings baby father
was a bit older than my mother like a
couple years older
they got it they didn't work out you
know obviously he was like he would get
drunk and then he would like hook up the
women
do this thing over there while the
mother my mom was a stay-at-home mom and
housewife and stuff and then later she
met my dad
and my dad was the more responsible
dutiful father he never cheated on her
number one behind her back never did
things like that
um
and then as time went on my mom became
more
i guess she carried that toxic baggage
from the original relationship
and then she put it on my father and so
she'd always like take me out of school
uh throw me in and like you know you
have to go spawn your phone make sure
he's not cheating on me i suspect he's
cheating and like why does he have to
send money to mexico i was like mom i
found out he's sending money to mexico
because it's his family relatives like
his mom my grandma his cousins he's
building a home over there that's why my
father was a he started his own like
blue collar job company construction and
landscaping
so he would be sending money over there
and then turns out my mother was the one
having an affair my mother was only
cheating on my father classic projection
projection
yeah so like the thing was
i got i you know who told me was my ex
that my mom had the audacity to tell her
and not me
when she was the one throwing me in the
fire pit
going out there with my father even
though i love my father he taught me how
to build a
business like that from the ground up
my mother was the one doing it so my
mother was a great mom to us to me my
little sister but she was a terrible
toxic wife to my father my father ended
up going to jail for things for he
didn't even do basically false
allegations false crimes and just for
him to like go through all that and he
was an illegal alien he was
no citizen didn't have no paperwork he
couldn't get registered to be a u.s
citizen here because of that
and um my parents ended up splitting
back in 2015
uh
and then my father ended up going back
to mexico a couple years after that
uh but it was weird because like just
like osmosis like the thing about these
relationships
that people forget is it's about duty
first and it's mainly about the kids and
then and then after if you want to
separate split up that's understandable
but right here a lot of people they tend
to do is in america it's so incentivized
to have a backdoor exit to break the
relationship and the woman thinking oh
it's like you know it's what makes me
happy it's what i should do it's what
you know it's about feeling those [__]
your feelings
your [__] happiness comes third if
you have kids if you have no kids then
your happiness comes second it's because
of the other person that's just the way
that it works that a lot of couples now
especially these young generations they
forget that it's about duty not about
love and happiness
it's not the vows
yeah it's
how do you think that it is
it's like i'm happy some days and pissed
off some other days if you're gonna well
if you
i think if you take away the
consequences in a society
like then people tend to do the wrong
thing more and that's kind of what's
going on with court and like divorce
court with women
there's less consequences for leaving
just like birth control like women sleep
around more because there's like there's
not that don't what do we this is my
show this is my show
um but like just like with birth control
women um
like there's less consequences for
sleeping around so they're going to do
it more you know
yeah i was going to say because i i've
worked in california law firm but i've
interned in these like like county
riverside and i've worked in some of
these law
uh like criminal court in the family
court and stuff and i've seen some of
the most
like great parents and like individuals
who to the responsible thing is they get
destroyed
usually it's the man being destroyed in
like the court fees and that the woman
is like one day she wakes up saying no
i'm not feeling this i don't want to do
this anymore i'm done i want to try
something else i want to live my city
girl life or
or this other guy and like he was
listening to me while the guy is doing
his duty of busting his ass at work
providing for the kids and putting a
roof over their head and paying the
bills and providing security and stuff
and i've seen these things and there's a
reason why some people end up
self-deleting themselves from it
well and people don't realize you can't
have everything you you can't and that's
what i tell i tell people when they say
oh i want a top like one percent guy i'm
like do you think you could handle him
because my mom never sees my dad like he
he's a workaholic he's always gonna be a
workaholic
so yeah he's like made all this money
but what does it matter if like you
can't see him all the time
but like everything you get comes with a
price like you can't have everything but
girls seem to think that you can
it's not true
did your mom know you're dead like that
like when he when your mom first got to
know him before you guys were born was
he your dad operating like that like his
work schedule
he's
my dad is
he didn't even understand my dad almost
killed himself from covid not because of
like the disease but because he wouldn't
stop working jesus like that is just who
he is he is wonderful
he he literally like almost died because
he would not rest
oh
was it like carderock arrest or
something
no it was kind of a long story basically
like
he got covered and then um he like kept
working in our backyard on all these
projects and whatever and then um
he got so dehydrated we had to take him
to the hospital and they gave him water
like they gave like an iv or whatever
and he realized it made him feel better
so then he drank so much water that like
i forgot what it does to your blood
but like it
make like your sodium levels are either
super high or super low i forget which
but that is so his sodium yeah was so
low
that um he his main symptom was my dad's
never had like mental health issues at
all and he like wanted to kill himself
like that was like the first symptom and
that's like a symptom of your sodium
being low is like you you get suicidal
and so we took him to the hospital and
then it turned out like he just drank
too much water so he was fine but he was
over hydrated yeah but like indirectly
because he just wanted to work
like and so none of that would have
happened if he just rested but he would
say wow then he got a iv
yeah he was fine like he's okay
but he if we didn't bring him in that
night he would have died
yeah so yeah have you talked to your mom
about
how much networks
yeah um my she hates it like it drives
her crazy
because i like doing that for his whole
life whole life yeah but you can't
that's what i tell my mom i'm like
you picked your poison like you wanted a
guy that like
worked super hard and like he you know
he gave you like 10 kids giant house
like like five like five different
houses like everything we could possibly
want but that's who he is
so i'm saying if you if you pick a guy
like that that's totally fine but you
have to understand what you're signing
up for
and like can you handle that my mom
could you know like she's fine but like
it's probably it's frustrating for her
yeah i think that's the issue with
people thinking that like once they get
in the relationship they think okay like
i understand where i see this but maybe
i can change it or change him or her and
like flip it and i think that's the
issue where people say okay at first i
think i can get used to it but then i
think later i can convince him to not do
it or somehow manipulate him to not be
this way
and my mom was good with it for most of
her life she's a really hard worker too
like those guys don't want a girl that's
lazy like they want to get something
like she always cooks she always like
she helped him build his business but
you know um
it's just everything comes at the cost
and that's what that's like that's it
most of the girls that say they want
these high value guys they could not
handle what they require i swear
oh most of the time what i've noticed is
the question i've always asked is do you
really think you you you'll have them
all to yourself
very few very few men at that caliber
only have one mother
my dad does he my dad's number two my
dad doesn't drink he doesn't have social
media he doesn't cheat but he's a
workaholic that's his advice everyone's
gonna hear that that's part of the
attraction that's a talking point i mean
like the whole
man has to have another
uh like i kind of work like that like
how you're saying your dad works and in
the relationship i was in i was trying
to step up from basically a 100k job to
a 200k job
i mean i was traveling
280 days a year
so
and that was it was cool like we were
taking the trips and did the money but
then like that was a big problem
relationship once i started working too
much it's like well i don't have any
time and then she kind of started
feeling like some way about it didn't
turn a bunch of arguments and then so i
turned down the job
and that's why i turned down the job i
turned down a new opportunity because
hey
this is me on some blue this is me going
real beautiful
and and that was very nice but but it
turned out jack is like okay i want i
value this relationship with that's why
i say guys should prioritize just get
into that
because once i didn't do that that
started a whole nother set of issues
like okay you're here too much
and we're not you can't we can't afford
to do stuff that the leveling up was
going to do so i just implore you know
what makes women happy nothing
nothing makes them happy
you gotta practice your happiness bro
cause look i wasn't stepping out i
wasn't messing around with nobody else
like you're saying you're making this
money you're gonna you're gonna want
another girl it wasn't like that i'm
just wanting to progress and progress us
but like
women's emotions like your mom's solid
for holding it down and like you know
obviously it's not easy for your partner
to not be around and to everybody
faithful and whatnot
but
um if you're not properly
i guess um
uh
translating what this hard work means
outside of the money aspect like or if
there's not a dead end there's not like
a goal to where like you're going to get
to because that was probably my that's
the only thing i take credit for there
was no communication it's just like
i'm just going hard i'm getting after
the bag and that's it and you just kind
of have to like deal with that but there
was no communication on the other end to
be like
i'm gonna give you this for having this
like i'm not gonna you know there's no
like i'm gonna give you time there's no
like dates and that's some stuff you
have to start working out but i would
never do it again i wouldn't turn down
the money
yeah yeah i think i think
women do want that super hard work and
she did like that oh it's a bragging
point like oh he's making us money such
a hard
but once you don't have the time that
does come with it
well and it even comes like this is what
i always say it's about trade-offs like
my dad i barely saw like when i was
growing up because he was working all
the time like he would go to india like
because they have an india branch and
like for like a month at a time but you
know now i have no doubt like i got my
college paid in full like everything
what kind of you know it's like and
that's what i'm saying like
everything comes with the price sorry go
ahead what
no i'm sorry to put you off um
uh
what kind of what kind of job field is
your fathering because it sounds like
like very like engineering or high-tech
or something
yeah he um they own a software company
so they started when they were when my
dad was
22 maybe and they sold it right before
the economy crashed so it was really
good timing
um
it was like right before coved so like
two or three years ago
they just did the same thing for like 25
years oh okay
impressive my dad my mom was the same
way like he worked all the time like i i
remember not really seeing him a lot and
never really thinking of it because my
mom was so involved with us yeah but um
i guess when we were talking about
earlier about the difference between
then and now i was kind of getting that
back
because there is
like my mom doesn't work at all now and
she just kind of like does whatever she
wants and i just you know she loves her
life now the kids are all out the house
and that's kind of the payoff and i
guess now
it's tough because women for the most
part don't want to be that woman that's
in that position to have to deal with
the early stages
and i guess you get a little less
respect from a man if you're not there
trying to like
be understanding about the the upfront
grind like when you come in on that back
end it's a little more difficult to get
a man to like that's what john comes in
like a man's gonna have other options
most men that deal with the woman like
that don't look for other options if
they started with them and they built
with them
like they're not trying to quote unquote
exercise options
yeah i want i watch this gets pretty
[__] old too
what is that noise
i don't know sorry it was something on
my end
just i wasn't trying i said i said
most men most men who reached their
most didn't they all say most
so i mean there are some men who only
have one woman
they're all sad are some men who only
have one woman right for the most part
for the guys who reached there
like if
if they wasn't getting no play for women
when they were younger didn't have much
money
now the moment they reach it to the top
the chance of having one woman
is almost slim to none
too
much yeah why wouldn't i
well you're talking about
this but they're not in the relationship
you thought they built themselves to the
top without having another
uh those guys are easy prey for a
relationship
like a predatory one
yeah too much is given much is tested
you know
like i don't want to talk to you before
and then wait what i mean
uh not intentionally
let me explain
basically this the kind of guy that you
know very few women want to talk to when
he's really young and
he gets older he really works himself he
has a lot of money you know some status
all of a sudden you know someone comes
along like the the brittany render
situation if you guys are familiar with
that
then yeah that's nothing
it's not quite the same but it's it's an
example of a guy who kind of just kind
of pursued his passion and then it's
like okay we'll deal with the women
later the one comes along and completely
screws them over in court i don't know i
don't know
i can't imagine the star basketball
player being that deprived of women yeah
that's not just you can correct me but i
i went to a d3 college and those
basketball players got girls like a lot
of girls and that was a d3 school that
was that they weren't going anywhere
yeah that's different that was a bad
example he's been on for a while and and
like i went to baylor and like there
like you go went to a party
and like the basketball players
even the scrubs were like
they had no problem picking up women so
i can't go to parties anyway so
our clubs are bars
yeah but you got like i got a a lot of
guys gotta understand too the ones
listening in the chat like because i've
i've played whether it was high school
on someone collegiate level
a lot of these women when they look at
men that are the athletic like prime
like apex predators like
in the jungle these guys would be like
the top athletic
you know whether it's the silverback or
the mountain like the lion or something
they look at the athletes like that
where okay he has a talent he's
ambitious he's hard working in that kind
of way he's the one with the spotlight
or you know etc so they look at these
guys like they're well built they're
genetically good
um they're [__] in good shape
they're somewhat attractive to handsome
you know so that's why these women flock
to them usually well that's a given i
guess well that's different than what
lemonade was talking he was talking
about someone that didn't get women and
built themselves up and their prey for
relationships that's like a nerd
like that's not like i guess
on that i understand
like those guys i mean yeah they could
be predatory but
that's i mean there's got to be some
accounting i mean maybe they're just not
aware that women are predatory but
there's got to be some accountability at
the point like they wanted these women
like where they were
it's whether they're predatory or not
it's still transactional like i wanted
that
attracting this and they want your money
i don't like it
i wanted to ask pearl like pearl like
because since you're you're in the
athletic uh department of well you're an
athlete so you play sports and stuff so
like
for you did men were men more
confident able to walk up to you or did
did you approach men more
because i know like a lot of times a lot
of people when they joined sports their
confidence raises and like discipline
the respect
did was that it was easier for you to
maybe go up to a guy or guys go up to
you
well it was a small school so it's kind
of like a different dynamic because
everyone's friends
so
um
the guy i dated in college like we were
friends first
so
just one guy
what
you only dated one guy in college i
would just ask him
there's nothing wrong with that
mysterious relationship with college in
college that's what she's i'm sure she's
referencing yeah
um
no i just dated one guy in college
okay that's all i was asking yeah yeah
no i wasn't i said that's fine i'm not
offended um
but
[Laughter]
what she said there when we talk about
the body count thing like i said like i
dated a girl kind of like that like that
wasn't a long-term relationship i think
maybe like five years it's like
just because pearl was in college that
doesn't mean like you'll take it like
maybe assuming she has a lot of bodies
like you could catch a chick that was
just in long-term relationships and like
bodies
i was old like i had lost my virginity
like halfway through college like i was
kind of old to be honest
oh and then i had the wrong idea about
you pearl at first yeah like i was
literally almost 20. we should call you
instead of calling him lemonade day we
should call you salty bae
damn
why
what did i say
because you you admitted you admitted
that you're uh you're a troll you're
like you're an act controller on social
media so i should call you salty bae
someone's got to do it i don't know
though
the way i do it makes the other people
salty
you know
you got you on you because you don't get
offended i don't i do think like
athletes though like
um
i would say like like the athletes just
tended to date athletes at my school
like that was like typical like common i
guess sounds about right because they're
helping out i've seen that
um yeah i mean you're just around each
other all the time like that makes sense
like at a small school it's such a
different dynamic because you know
everyone and especially all the athletes
like you hang out with each other so
it's like every weekend you're seeing
the same people so you're not really so
much like guys or girls approach you
it's like we've hung out at the pre-game
like i see you i see you in class like a
couple times a week we eat together on
campus like it's such a different
dynamic than like interesting at a big
school where you like approach each
other because i think there was maybe 5
000 at most people that went to my
college whoa do you think do you think
that influenced your dating
after college
dating after college do you think being
in that kind of environment influenced
your dating a lot after college we're
like okay i've hung around all these
guys
excuse me
you said you hung around guys before you
dated them so is that kind of like
what you're programmed to do now
like you'll be around somebody a lot
before
rather than you know just someone you
just met well you don't just yeah no no
for sure yeah like i prefer to date
people like i already know yeah i
thought you mentioned that earlier so i
thought it did yeah like i prefer to
date people that like i i've known for a
long time to be honest or if i haven't
known them a long time like i've spent a
lot of time with
you don't even have to be the most
attractive person if you're just
spending time with someone especially
like we talked about the work
environment before just inadvertently
people just grow kind of attracted to
you
and and then i mean like like
like like mac you're kind of like
dogging yourself a little bit for some
reason but say you were just working
and you just felt however you felt but
that's not to say like you couldn't get
an attractive woman at your job if
you're just being yourself and she likes
your personality and like
just from the proximity of being around
her she kind of grow you growing her and
somebody somebody if you got with this
girl would be like how the hell did mac
pull that chick and she's like yeah just
just grows you just grow on people being
around in the same circles well and it's
really attractive to girls if we see
that other people like you it doesn't
even have to be girls but a social club
yeah like
that's real like that's that's two
that's a little too effective to be
honest like if we see like you're really
good at your job and you work hard or
like we see you in an environment where
you do well like that's so attractive
yeah i noticed when i was younger
i've seen when i used to be like i don't
know i was like 15 you seen guys are
like in their 20s
and they'd have like a moderately decent
looking chick or a very attractive chick
and their chicks look at them and it's
like okay like not only is this social
proof but it's like oh this guy can
possibly pull attractive women
other attractive women will look at the
guy um
and i'm not i just i'm saying that a lot
because there's men here listening as
well
on the panel but i've noticed that
before when i was younger
and and it's like
the social proof is true
um but it's also like i guess how you
carry yourself how you communicate your
communication skills and not looking too
thirsty or too eager
like yeah that's really that's like oh
my gosh i hate it when guys are too
thirsty there is nothing that'll turn me
off quicker than ever guys too thirsty i
can't
and i know
yeah like like guys that are pushy
like when you when you said like oh you
have to like pull back i'm like that's
really good advice because
well what's too thirsty
like where's the line um
it's not a set in stone line it's gonna
be different for every girl but i'm just
asking your personal one um
like i don't like it when i tell a guy
that i like i know and he doesn't listen
like he keeps pushing it like i get mad
yeah like i told you not to like the hr
situation
no not that that would be yeah probably
yeah
okay or
if i tell a guy like if he asks like to
go back with me and i say no and he
keeps pushing it i'm like but no like
you're not yeah i i i strictly
i've strictly told guys like don't don't
try to get involved too personally with
like
women at your job because i always tell
guys like don't don't
chase a woman over your check i know it
sounds calling like that that old that
other hip-hop song whatever
you know like chase it check never chase
a b
yeah you know what i'm saying
i'm just i'm just keeping it youtube
respectful and it's her platform that's
why i try not to cuss that much but
um like
uh
you know i i always
there you go yes chase a check never
chase a chick
and
i do tell guys that i teach guys i was
like don't don't do that because
you know this this day and age this era
of the hashtag me too and you know false
allegations or things can be taken
misconstrued and like a big
misunderstanding and
you know things like that like but i
just don't you know just there's plenty
of other women outside your job outside
of your your work you know yeah you know
so just deal with the woman outside your
work don't do it don't deal with women
inside your work at all i mean how good
is the job how good is the job is the
question believe me
you can always get a new job regardless
of the job pays you 40 50k 60 kid no
like it doesn't matter it's just
if that's putting and that's paying your
feelings like a server job like you can
always get another circle oh okay yeah
yeah it's kind of harder
remember remember like 40 50k could be a
lot to somebody it could be a little bit
to you you know what i'm saying
to me not everyone has the connections
you just get a new job like pearl you
know
well she know she was saying like if
it's just like a low-level job like if
it's like you're working at mcdonald's
just like probably another mcdonald's
right down the street sort of deal
basically if you're not on a salary job
it's kind of you know you can get it
it's like i'm not going to have like a
salary and be trying let me know my job
it's not going to happen like
yeah
but as far as you said
oh my god you should pee people you
should peep my series where i went door
to door looking for jobs you should
people oh oh there you go oh my god
i might need to do that because like i'm
just i just don't get call spots it's
really annoying i just i just went to a
rich neighborhood one day i just wanted
to see if i could get a job and i did
a sales job i went door-to-door in like
a rich neighborhood i knocked on the
door of a ceo's company yeah yeah i
think when i got an interview but i
actually sorry sorry i i misspoke i
didn't get a job i got an interview but
i didn't actually want a job i just
wanted to see if i could get one
interview is pretty damn good
that's what i'm saying like it's like
it's like crazy things i used to in
college go door-to-door at like
businesses and like just ask like for
internships if i didn't
yeah so
what's the i had a question though on
the internship the what's the ratio
depending like i don't know what your
job feel you were looking into but
what would have been the ratio to get
marketing or sales one day okay one day
going door-to-door saying hey can i
shake someone's hand
and i got an internship every single
time our intern is not that hard no no
that wasn't that wasn't my question
no my question was what's like the
closing rate to actually get it is it
like a five percent chance of getting it
if you're the intern at 10 15 like i
went to maybe 10 businesses
and then did you get did you get any of
the jobs from there like was it 2 out of
10 you like where you got the job
they're more i like honestly
i usually take the first one i got to be
honest
um i know that's not smart so
yeah i'm trying to think because i
didn't
um
where did i work it was that zumba group
in college just in elmhurst so it was
i i went to like well i mean i don't
work there anymore like 15 places 10 15
i would say and then i got one job for
the summer
okay
i think about
for it college trip
in high school
zumba group
no
elmhurst
oh yeah
yeah i don't know
people get really impressed when you do
[__] in person
i always just go go in person and like
try to shake hands
my teachers
what i mean
sorry go ahead
there was one guy when i went to elmer
for like a college trip like i pointed
out i bought i accidentally voted it out
i said the back of his boy had like a
hot pocket or something like that
like because he had a weird thing in the
back of his head back of his head like
back back up here i almost got in
trouble but like my what my teachers
pulled me insanity i agree i was like
really
can you hear me
yeah i can like a playback
yeah sorry
like
i i went there like i didn't want to go
i i didn't want to go there for some
reason i just didn't like that i didn't
like it
oh
okay
yeah sometimes you get a bad vibe in a
place
yeah
i mean i want to go to ferris state in
uh
with in uh michigan
okay bro somebody ever talked talked you
out of like you've been super interested
in somebody and they just talked too
much and
they talked you out of it
[Music]
that's happened in a few days
yeah like you were just like oh man i'm
kind of feeling this you're having a
great time and then he just kind of like
just gave too much information
oh [__]
i've heard horror stories of that
happening
that's a regular basis not even a horror
story that's every day i mean
i do that very often
oh wait you you talk yourself out of the
thing or the girl yeah that talks me out
of it i just i really
really like
hate when guys are too pushy so
there's guys that like i maybe could
have seen something with like
down the road but they just were like
so cool like they just like and maybe
that's because you know they didn't want
to spend time on me past like that you
know night or that day or whatever but i
would say for me the biggest turn off
and like it's not even them saying too
much it's them like
not listening is what pisses me off to
be honest
not listening
yeah like just like not um just like
what he said when i
like to say no not like respecting it
and like keep pushing it because then
i'll like get mad
and let go
so you're the time to use what she says
i said like you're the type of girl who
means what you said you're not gonna say
something like you know why the hell are
you keep going you know yeah that's what
i'm saying like i mean it's i don't
understand and i'm not the type like i
don't go up to guys on a date and be
like you're not coming home with me but
if they ask and i say no i don't
understand why you like they push it
but then i'm finding out but then i'll
do that then i hear about all these
girls that like are doing it anyway so i
guess i don't know so you're not one of
those but you know you're kind of
dealing with a lot of that like that's
cap too because a lot of girls i've been
out with like
on the first night
and then they do
and it's just like
i was like yeah i mean a lot of women
say that not that you should just like
come in with the mentality that i just
like went yeah
just like okay
i get it it's confusing for a guy very
text messages i i understand i is that
is that is that
i'm sorry guys
no no because i was going to say that
this isn't like the saying where like
women say but they do the opposite type
thing is that what osmosis is getting at
if they say it but then they do the
opposite but what guys have an issue
with is they have an issue with that
like if you understand that it's not a
problem yeah yeah exactly i don't have
an issue with it so they try to combat
it in a way and like force what they
think the opposite is instead of just
letting them just flop and just like say
whatever they're gonna say and just
continue have a good time yeah
and then that's what kills it and then
like oh that girl was like bs at me it's
like well she probably
her pride might be involved you know so
it's like you just kind of let her come
to you but dudes just try to like jump
the gun and be like i think you're going
over there so i'm going to get there
first and that
or i had a guy that wanted to be
exclusive with me too soon and normally
like
like it just he would like wanted to be
exclusive with me after like
two days two dates
i didn't like we'd never like we'd never
done anything like sexually at all so
i'm like
no like what the [__] like what you just
kind of like this weekly you know
yeah does it annoy you he's trying to
i was gonna say pro does it
does it don't know you want a man
go ahead i was gonna say pearl does it
annoy you when you give a uh you tell a
guy like details in a like in a date
where
you're like letting him know about you
like your dislikes your likes but then
you try to like ask him if he's paying
attention does that annoy you if you
didn't or like he doesn't show the
interest of listening
does that bug you
i'm kind of oblivious yeah i don't i
don't really notice someone i've i've
been on i've gone on a few days where
i've heard of guys and they go on dates
where like
the girl was like you know what's my
favorite color but you didn't listen or
i hate this or i have a pet peeve of
this and stuff and like
you know like
they they had like a certain like damn
it like what the hell like you were
supposed to pay attention to me and
listen to me
[__]
yeah she goes because i i intently i
intently listen just in case that i were
to get tested like by a woman to say hey
like you remembered this and it's like
bonus points or whatever it's like oh he
cares or he gives a [__] but then it's
weird because then some women like they
don't want you to care as much
i learned that when i was younger
interesting
it's just interesting you bring that up
because as you guys can imagine i have a
very terrible memory now so it's like
when people
i would say like yeah i forgot like some
days i forget when my own birthday is
and people like how do you not remember
that i was like
why the [__] would i lie about that so
it's like it makes a lot of
conversations like
pretty painful to be honest at least on
my own i haven't had that come up on a
date but if it did like
it's gonna be so awkward
yeah i wanted to hear pearl and osmos's
opinions on that what i just said like
if you guys have ever dealt with that or
had friends or certain individuals where
that happens to them
on
that uh saying that that that they um
you said wait say again
you know how like when like you go with
the opposite at the opposite sex you go
out you're on a date and they tell you
about them like their likes dislikes the
pet peeves etc and then they kind of
like expect you to know or test you to
remember it later
there's like and then the woman they
like gets thrown off by it has that ever
happened to you or do you know anybody
where like they don't like it or like
they kind of
like try to disqualify you for that
like [__] like that
i just don't let them i just don't let
them have it like if they tried to like
do that you know and i know like you
know it sounds like a lot of people hear
rare people talking about like if they s
test it's just like i just i'll just
play him i'll just be like i was like i
wouldn't listen to you anyways and it's
like a joke but it's like they're like
audacity of you to act like and they
just i'm telling you it sounds weird but
i'm telling you they're sick this way no
you're right you're right because i i
literally said at the end of the point
what i was saying like i noticed like
some girls they want you to act like you
don't care like
it's not it's like
i don't know how to get it it's like a
guy that doesn't take himself too
seriously and will like banter with you
so basically i can't like guys can't
have a stick up their ass okay yeah and
that's like when a girl when a girl
rejects you it's all about how you
respond
like if you get all butt hurt about it
it's like the girl sees you're like
demonstrating your value but if like if
you just brush it off
oh
i tried it a couple times where a girl
like was getting annoyed and like butt
hurt and like she was getting mad that i
wasn't paying attention
and then she was like you know what like
i don't want to talk to you no more like
you're being mean or something so i'm
like all right fine so then i walked
away and then i just started talking to
some other girl that she saw physically
like she physically saw me like talking
with some other chick and then all of a
sudden she came running back
it was weird how it worked
when i was younger it was like six seven
years ago i don't even think girls i
don't even think we understand ourselves
yeah
i'll listen to and i'm like damn is that
what happened like
yeah if you understand that's like
that's really counter to my experiences
if you understand that you won't be
salty about it just like once you
understand they don't even get it you
don't have to play
just like
just like whatever yeah i i i saw
something i missed because like i'm not
salty about it but like if i like ask
someone out or something
and i hardly know them it's that's like
the end of conversa that's like the end
of me like interacting with them like i
put in zero effort i
they're that's me i won't be like oh
[__] you [__] how could you i'm so blah
blah blah but it's like okay you said
you don't we don't see each other the
same way so like well bye you don't have
any purpose in my life anymore so i just
go on and do something else and that's
usually the end of it i'm completely
cool it's like
i mean i get i can see how it's annoying
it's like you're a chick and like guys
are like your so-called friends i guess
they're constantly asking you out and
you're like bro i don't see you like
that so it's like keep it [__] moving
i had i had a small question for i had a
small question for pearl hey bro when it
comes to like guys dealing with women
um
do you think it shows a lot of a guy's
like emotional side if a guy were to
block a woman
like let's say on social media like
let's say like they get into it but they
start dealing with each other but then
all of a sudden something happens
and then they block each other on social
media and then the guy blocks the girl
but the girl doesn't block the guy does
that show the more the girl
no it's more like not a breakup but they
were just like uh
hooking up or they were dating or
something but then like with the guy
like just block her because it's like
i'm i'm done dealing with you
and then all of a sudden would that show
that the girl was like okay i got him to
emotionally react to me or is that just
like the guy just not caring um girls
look at you for being like that comes
off as weak they're not gonna yeah okay
thank you okay i would agree because
you're having this homework then
you know it's kind of like you're
triggered right because that's how i was
looking at it like it looks like the guy
is triggered by it
i've done
like react get her to react and then she
blocked me too and then like i'm blocked
the tactic didn't work and then it was
like she'd never unblocked and i was
like whoa what happened
because you can od on it like she can
come back sometimes they'll do it it's a
shock like oh damn he's moving on and
they'll come back but if you keep going
too hard like they literally just move
on
people over the over just come in and i
don't do that no more because they
usually come around you just never know
yeah because i like there's been guys
who have tried it where like i know a
few of my friends where they tried that
and they don't block the girl but they
just they stop messaging her they may
even unfriend her or something or they
just she'll be dming the guys and like
the girls will be blowing their dms up
just because the guys
you see them partying in the club or
going out to dinner with different women
different dates
and then the girl's like interesting end
of the relationship that does happen but
that's not like
no no no and like when i when i'm when
i'm talking about the situation it's
like guys and girls hooking up like a
friend's benefits or they were casually
dating there was no actual title to it
yeah i would just not i would keep
reading the messages i just wouldn't
reply
yeah oh really
so you leave her on red
yeah i wouldn't block because you might
still eventually like it just yeah when
you start doing that just shows you you
care it shows you care too much
like i just unless you're a writer you
kind of have to actually mean it like
once i get what i want you to the point
where you're getting out of tactics
you kind of actually mean what you're
doing like guys chick's kind of goofy
and you just kind of move on
and like she's not not that she's
attract not not that she's unattractive
and you wouldn't mess with her again
just like
you just move like kind of lame and then
you move on
you
their ego can't take that hit
i want to hear pearl's opinion on that
yeah
i guess i'm lame i
i definitely block people but go ahead
and
not want to hear a pearl's opinion no i
would say don't block
um
i i would say women hate to be
oh gosh i hope
women can't handle leo
no there's someone i really don't want
to see this stream but i would say if
you really want to drive a girl crazy
to ignore her to be honest i would say
if like
yeah that's probably the best way just
let it let it let her exist in your
world still but just don't give her the
energy
act like you don't care
[Laughter]
like ignore her don't put on a pedestal
don't don't treat her as a priority
treat her as an option
more just like if there's a consequence
for like bad behavior basically and that
concept like it's almost like she's a
kid
yeah just so and like the consequence
for like bad behavior is ignoring her
like that's like to me like that's
i hate breaking news pearl just calls
females little kids yeah kind of we are
okay
i'm telling you
that's crazy though the week before your
girls period i feel like i'm not even
the same person like i'm telling you
like you can't even
don't take anything personally she says
or does and
i'm glad i'm glad you just said that i'm
glad you said that about the about the
time of the month thing because
i was gonna ask you this if a guy that
you're dealing with or dating or in a
relationship with and he tells you hey
that i understand you're a woman and you
go through your time of the month you
can be a [__] to anybody else just not
to me and we won't have any problems
would you be okay with how he told you
like that yeah that'd be fine
damn yeah cause sometimes
that won't happen for me
for me i'm not gonna even lie i don't
[__] like him
you guys don't even understand
like she's doing good how mad you get
you get so mad over nothing and you
can't help it yeah
you got to like learn
that's what early on like in my like 20
25 like i used to have a real problem
like i would argue on a period then i
started learning like it's not even
worth like just take it and just let it
roll off because like literally that's
what it is it's going to be a completely
different person like if you can just
kind of like keep your distance and just
weather the bs that she's going to kick
i mean if she says something like
offensive or just like like really
you're just it's bye [__] like
and i know that sounds cool hearted but
it's like she says i'm on a period
yeah like get the [__] out yeah i have a
long road you're gonna have all right i
can't say i underpersonally understand
it but i take psychotic medics and all
the time i'm coming off a huge brain
injury i get i used to be a far bigger
[__] than i am now but i don't care
if your
entire family just got murdered you
don't say cross things against right
what's across the
things are they saying yeah i'm just
talking about like i just get a little
yeah
you can get in general because i it's
just like how my last thing ended she
went
way off the wall and i just was like
what were you doing on the wall with
something no i made i'm making this no i
made the mistake of turning down a deck
appointment after taking two engineering
finals and working an eight hour shift
and cycling home well here's why i say
mac that the the mistake wasn't turning
down the deployment the mistake was
engaging in the argument
i just blocked and said well bye i said
see you later
yeah i mean like with your date you were
dating that girl no it's just like it
was just a casual thing
like you're involved with a lot this is
something i usually do i just kind of
keep track like loosely when the period
is because i just kind of know when it's
about to get goofy and
not reply to a text message it's about
to turn into a three-hour argument and
just like all right you know you you
learn eventually just let that roll like
just let her have it because you
apologize most girls will apologize no
all you ladies listening now you
understand why us guys die quicker
because you women are trying to like
destroy us
hey hey but like i i'm glad that you
guys are saying these things because
these are things that i've learned
seven eight years ago when i was dating
women frequently more and i was doing
these things back then
because my brother would teach me this
stuff and then other men that were more
i guess higher value higher quality guys
that were successful and good looking in
chats and tight rooms
and i got to learn from them
about the young dating like market even
though it was different back then like
2014 2015 2013 it's different now
because of how globalized the internet
and the marketplace and women getting
flown out and like instagram and the dms
you know
and all these things were because even
back then i didn't know what pof was i
thought pof was a game like a [__]
game app i thought plenty of pictures
like you're a fisherman oh okay plenty
of fish i literally thought it was a
video game back then because i wasn't
using it i was all
all the woman that i picked up was cold
approach
yeah i don't it was straight direct cold
road yeah i i was just saying like yeah
it's okay but literally like
i could use a dating app for months and
like i literally go out and i'd win more
just being out and about in real life
yeah exactly
that also shows uh that shows confidence
social proof and that shows that
you can actually articulate a
conversation and you're not a socially
awkward you know weirdo
the competition is different and they
can feel the confidence and they can
feel something about you they won't feel
through that app well and guys um guys
don't really approach like not that
often especially in like broad daylight
like not in like a bar
oh like right daylight
i'm not against a person but normally i
mean uh more times than i would do you
should almost like when she showed like
she was obviously like a girl really
out of her way to show interest from me
yeah i'm not about to like cold approach
somebody that
never said
[Music]
i've been approached before by girls too
for some
odd reason it happened
it happened
i like one girl
i was actually i was thinking about
doing a youtube video on it to be honest
camera guy hire a camera guy and do that
and like see how many guys that's the
thing is i need to find well i wouldn't
like i just wanted to see
like
like a girl versus a guy approaching in
public i was thinking about that video
i'm like really awkward so you might win
to be honest
i if you're in um no i what i think a
girl will win pretty tough in london in
general most people tell you to [__] off
so oh that was the other question when i
asked you pearl what's the differences
in women's standards like are they more
higher egos in uk versus compared to
america is it more easier more
approachable for women for again for men
or for women to have the balls to go up
to somebody on cold approach like is it
very is it different
oh well i'm i'm kind of in a little
bubble because one i live in the hood so
we don't
i'm in east london
[Music]
yes i'm telling you i live in the hood
do you take the tube to get around by
chance
uh i don't know i take the
train station that's by my house all
right
so
okay um
but
yeah so i don't and most of the girls on
my team are american so it's kind of
like a little bubble
but i'd like to make some british
friends so i'm working on guys have guys
hit up on you over there or like you and
your friends since american friends
since
i had a boyfriend most of the time i've
been here like i've only not had a
boyfriend for
like a month and most of it i was home
with my family so
okay i guess we'll see
dang she's out there guys send your dick
picture of dms please
just kidding
yeah
i was just thinking like you know
london's a very large city so most
people
especially uh the english are
far uh i think well i would say far more
computational but
you know just going about their day
london's a very busy city it's a lot of
finance going on or people running
around trying to get about and stuff
like if you try to like code approach a
woman or someone on a on a tube or
something just going to tell you to [__]
off because like it's kind of like going
almost a little bit like if you were
trying to do it in new york city it's
like
you would you would you're shooting
you're shooting precision this would be
sub one percent
i would say that hurt to try well it
kind of depends on how you code
approaching i've heard i heard that
most i mean when you
i heard that the hottest women in new
york are single
like they're like they're in the early
40s i'm really successful all that i
wonder why it
doesn't mean they want to meet you in a
tube though like imagine like
what's up
no i'm currently in athens i grew up in
atlanta but what's up new york people
get around so
yeah i mean you gotta get around but how
how many times do you see like a
relationship born from on an mat where
it's like people are just like
you're like squished in between crack
heads and other people just commuting to
work
well i mean it depends on your intent
right like if you approach with i think
the problem with people co-approach is
that they have a specific intention in
mind and if it doesn't go the exact way
they thought it was go in their head
they just
kind of like get upset about it like
that yeah we need to stop having high
expectations people that's what that's
my issue with people when you complain
yeah if you approach them friendly with
kind of like like with the mentality of
i'm okay with nothing happening here i'm
just gonna talk and we're just gonna
like joke around
and like
i'm talking about on a train platform
train park doesn't really matter it's
just like you're just like being a
regular person most women are cool with
that because it's not invasive
interesting they don't feel like if
dudes were cool with just getting like
the like being friendly and getting the
number like okay like no big deal like
most women would be like okay you can
have my number like on some friendly
stuff
develop something from there but most
dudes go from like go from zero to like
hey baby i'm interested in you what's
good and like most women shut down like
they're not gonna
really engage with you
i think i remember i think i remember
i
i think i remember i was
i had a sudden impulse like i'm very
impulsive set an impulse to talk to
somebody and i ended up talking about uh
uh talking about her hairline
how about hairline she laughed a bit
she laughed a bit i'm like
i don't even know why
but then i walked away after that
wait she said something about your
hairline
no i said from the bottom hairline oh
[__] that's where you [__] up
do chicks even have hairlines like that
like i know mine some of them do
damn was she in a is she in the army or
some [__] like buzz cut
no
[__]
where her
where your forehead stops
when your hair begins
okay yeah i got you now i'm thinking
like me like
i was gonna say because i meant you're
attracting women i messed them
attractive women that have like no hair
like less hair like
i like
some [__]
yeah like i met someone i've seen some
men some very attractive whether they're
african-american whether they're uh
european or whatever like i already well
you know like i met some very attractive
women
i've you know dabbled in that a little
bit but
not his own i don't get the point it
just depends i guess how it looks or the
interest of the person the guy
she laughed a bit and i'm gonna lie
um i think
when i the reason i started looking at
pickup a little bit like i did the
pickup video was because it reminded me
so much of my sales job
like it's kind of like sales
that may be a thing too because i used
to do door-to-door sales for a lot of
companies and just once you get used to
being told no yeah
it's just like no all right
and it's just like yeah people just like
literally don't even care yeah you don't
care just like yeah when i sold vacuums
we had a um
like i would knock on the door if
somebody didn't like
like my approach basically like they
just told me no like
we had girls that came with us in our
crew and like they would go set an
appointment
because like people are more receptive
to women usually like we'll have like a
cute girl with this just like i'll show
up an hour later like hey i'm here to do
that appointment like that they thought
it was going to be the girl that
couldn't do it so like
yeah once you get into sales it's the
same way as like when they tell you to
like go out and like just talk to women
and just get over that thing
because you just got to take some no's
and just kind of get you know
like not even
[Music]
i yeah
i tell guys i tell guys it's kind of
like kobe bryant when he would take his
shots and he would take like 30 and like
hey there's only so many shots kobe will
take until they all start falling in
you know so you know who cares if you're
like 10 for 30 or you know 10 for 40.
it's at least sooner or later the shots
will go in and it's just
closing right that's when it starts
that's just my problem no penalty for
losing
you know from like me
like
i guess i'm like have like a very
anti-cell personality like usually
people come like door to door and unless
it's like um
i believe it's called like isaf where
you like donate money to like children
over in africa or something
like 99 of the time it's [__] off i
don't want your attention
go away like i'm extreme
that's one of the problems i have
especially now after my stroke i just
have absolutely no patience it's like
and like most of the time in my day i
get like
calls from oh i have extended warranty
and i'm just like
keep saying you have no patience because
you you're pretty patient on here you
kind of like let people talk
yeah you seem very true like for the
most part
i'm getting something out of it just to
be
completely transparent if it's like i
usually when i'm like on a bus
people are always trying to like sell me
[__] and it it's legit have been grandma
sometimes they're like hey do you want
to sign up for like this like bitcoin
course i'm like no no i keep doing it
i'm like i said [__] no shut the [__]
up jesus christ
and then everyone will meet well look at
he looked at me on a bus and i'm like
i tried being nice so it's like
do you get social anxiety do you have i
don't think social anxiety i just get
pissed off because like the way i have
to communicate now after having my
stroke is that i don't interpret like
very long form combinations very well so
to be very brief and usually when people
like ask me a question like you're
if you if it's like a real question like
it means you're in part you're something
that one answer saying that can be no so
if i give you to know and you're
suppressing me then that's where i just
get angry because you're this becomes
disrespectful at that point and i know
like it's like something i have to work
on it's just
therapy but unfortunately it's
especially right now getting into that
stuff is
very hard because like practically every
medical service is
not um a
er room is like shut down right now so
it's very fun
yeah
that was
that's why like honestly with like what
checks like if they select no that's
like cool like i don't get i don't
that's not no
like i don't
i don't be mean unless like they don't
accept like my like just like no or
whatever but like whenever like it's
like the last
with benefits when she started saying
like a bunch of like racial stuff i was
just i didn't even say anything back i
just blocked and moved on i was just
like okay
oh that guy
if i got it
like conversation took a turn
like
leave like i it's like my it's just
something i don't in that situation no
i'm not going to change but like that's
why like honestly i find like a lot of
like uh stuff to do with like
relationship like i know i'm like not
very successful it is what it is but
it's like i mean that's just how to live
my life now like just be very blunt and
just like if you're not cool cool that i
like i completely get it but like i'm
not trying to be everyone's cup of tea
not to make like you know english slash
british puns but
like i am who i am so it's like well i
mean there's no issue with that but you
said you're busy you said you're 22
right you said you're busy you're trying
to okay i mean if you just let stuff
come to like you mentioned multiple
times that you cold approach
i knew i did
i never thought i did
it's always been pretty
like not even cold approach you've
talked to somebody i'm not trying to say
cold person like i'm just okay that's
cool you went and talked to people and
then you didn't like the engagement
that's what you were saying earlier yeah
and i'm just like i just like yeah well
it's cool you know
but it's like i've also like
one of my things is like i guess
in a few ways i've kind of been i guess
people call like the orbiter or
something where you're kind of like
trying to beat a friend before you like
ask her out i've just been recently like
okay well you know i obviously feel this
way about her and i'll just like ask her
out and she'll usually say like i mean
so far it hasn't really succeeded i'm
not very good at shooting so she'll
still like no or just like no response
and i'm just like oh okay well
check her off enough have you ever
thought about not trying to like take it
further like like literally so this so
this right this is this is one girl i
know right super yeah like easily a 10.
and a lot of guys like why won't you try
to hook up with her like we've like kind
of got
we're solid friends and it's just like i
don't try to do it because you kind of
have to gain that comfortability yeah
at that time it was just like you got to
kind of gain that comfortability just
yeah i get it do you just hang out with
these women like just literally as like
i'm not trying to score i'm just trying
to like get yeah that's the thing i
would just i would just like hey you
just want to like grab some coffee
i'm just
for like if you're just if you're just
hanging around do you think you waste
your time at all like well no it's not
it's not obviously
the comfortability in the sense like i
mean it's a waste of time if you have it
depends on your intent right like if
your intent is like you're trying to
hang around to get something out of here
versus like a genuine like yeah i'm just
enjoying the presents with the female
and just getting used to the female
interaction like their social cues type
thing like you kind of need some of
those women in your pocket where you're
not
yeah
you know what i mean
honestly for me most of the time it's
like hey like i'm free
well between blah blah blah time you
want to go grab some coffee at blah blah
blah library blah blah blah hall at uga
and it would just be like no response or
anything and they're just like and i
want me i'll just like okay well
yeah no i was gonna follow up early no
follow-up
but you were talking before that like
engaged before that like you were
talking regularly
like on a daily basis it's kind of it's
been so awkward because uh i've
yes but like i took last spring off from
school so i was just in my home old
bubble for like six months and then i
kind of came back
summer and polish just started talking
to a bunch of people
and then
i'll tell you this most times when you
do that like even if a woman's like kind
of into you
if you like give her your availability
and tell her to fill in the blanks
they're not gonna do it
well no i'll usually i'm not saying like
oh i mean if you're like yo
who taught you these secrets
i'm not questioning
the same thing
you take enough losses you kind of just
start picking yeah i get what you're
saying i'm not saying like hey you know
i'm hey i'm mac i have nothing [__]
going on i'm free between saturday to
saturday do you want to hang i'm usually
like hey i'm free between like 12 to 2
on friday can you make yeah yes no blah
blah blah well i want to say that but
that would just be like a response i
guess
but even in saying that that just says
you got nothing going on what what that
i'm free for like an hour and a half
between 12 and two well it's just kind
of like for instance like okay i don't
have anything going on if she just and
that's honest but like that's honest
that's what i'm trying to say if i'm i'm
going to be honest like i have nothing
going on if that's a turn off that's
completely cool but i'm not trying to
put on a minnesota show for anybody hey
i'm
i got some brief times in class i'm not
going to really be doing anything but
reading emails so you just want to grab
some coffee and talk yeah like osmosis i
think osmosis i think his point i think
his point is that he's trying not to
pedestalize the girl and also he also
has a life he's basically trying to say
like he has his own things he's his own
players correct me
i'm not trying to judge it too hard i
guess they did that that's cool not just
like it's completely fine it kind of
comes down to the because you're not
really giving us the prior how much she
was interested in you
because more
girls would be more lenient if they're
already interested to you in that aspect
like communicating the way you girls
will make time the girls will make time
if they really are interested to you and
they yeah their schedule will open up
believe me the girl that's underway yeah
that's fair that's the way i would think
of it and it would be like yeah we would
we used to be pretty close friends or at
least i would think it kind of depends
what it depends what the girl
categorizes you as like if you're a guy
that like
there's guys that win in the long game
and guys that win the win in the short
game so it just depends how the girl
categorizes you
which one's better yeah
the short game does but
we can't we can't we can't all be short
like not every guy is gonna
so
it's kind
and you're going to graduate this year
so yeah
what are you saying bro
no it's like um it's kind of like girls
will categorize you like if there's a
guy that has
sometimes i question if i should say
these things live but i will
like there's like guys that like you
just like
categorized as like i mean it's kind of
like okay if a victoria's secret model
asked you out you're gonna prioritize
her probably higher than the average
girl i mean like the girls categorize
you that way too and like depending on
their level of interest hell yeah i'm
gonna post that [__]
yeah yeah but it's not to say that like
you can't get to that level of interest
but some guys like have to build it more
yeah it takes like
yes
i think it can be
skeptical
like i do i do think it's genuine desire
but like like okay it depends where i
know you from like if i don't know you
at all like it is gonna take a while
because i don't know yeah you're you're
a stranger to me
but
what go ahead so like who would be your
celebrity crush your athletic celebrity
crush
and he would have taken you out you
wouldn't have a genuine burning desire
for that celebrity or that crush that
you've been wanting for
a genuine desire um well i still don't
know i don't like chris hemsworth or
some [__]
no i've had you
yeah i've had like
like
there's like there's nba players i could
have hooked up with but i didn't like i
don't know you like i was just at
i was just like names
what cause i said you're not gonna name
names
don't name trump
tortorsha name dropped once well but
then
like i was just i was just at a rapper's
house that had like like if you saw my
recent video like that and i literally i
literally was so awkward that was
socially awkward that video
that's true that's true but i don't i
didn't know that going but i brought my
dad like it's not
um
for i swear to god i did
no i'm not saying you're lying i'm just
like no oh yeah yeah i got you did you
ask him or did he kind of insist on
going
oh what no i asked him oh
like i'm just saying like as even like a
normal girl like has access
um
normally i don't know homogeneous got a
lot of access i was going to say the
average suburban girls now like like
there's like a only fans chick she has
like the average urban suburban look to
her she's not she doesn't look enhanced
or qualified or whatever like hi
like she looks like your average urban
girl she's like the highest earning like
only fans percentile like earner
and it's because of the fact that
like for example yeah like my point was
like um
because of these women that looks more
they look more attainable they look more
like logical more more more reasonable
to get for a guy so that's why these
guys are like shooting their shot with
these more
average or your average suburban shake
who's like a seven or eight
because they're more attainable to the
human eye and so it's like okay this she
looks more reasonably hot
yeah i have to ask one thing about that
pretty attractive i i i want to jump
back in too but uh go ahead
like okay so you said you know someone
that you know say is like a six or a
seven but you know they're getting all
this attention if everybody wants you
are you still a six or a seven or does
that push you up to like a nine or a ten
a woman's ego will go up a woman
but like
if everyone sees you as that's just
being so much higher does that make you
that higher
you know what i'm saying are you talking
pearl i think you're not talking to
anybody
no
well i mean i don't know how to say that
i mean i don't want it
it's hard to think that people's egos
nowadays can get even higher like i've
seen some crazy things
so i just wouldn't i just wouldn't i
just wouldn't treat even if
even if the girl was a 9 or 10 i just
wouldn't treat her like she was
yeah that's yeah big goals and so that's
the key
you gotta try she's average to every
other girl
yeah
[Music]
it would be like sort of warm these
would be like
used to be like chicks that have been in
like multiple of my classes and all like
like take for example one day was like
career day and she would know like like
quite a few of them would come to like
hey like night like your suit and
everything and
or i would just like pass her off some
give her some notes and then the
conversations would be a tiny bit longer
than you think it should be so i'll be
like hey you know just like one day you
just want to
grab something to drink or something
and but i don't know it's just like a
lot of it has to do and i hate to use
this as a crotch but a lot of it has to
do with like my
my brain injury because like my ability
to handle like complex like social cues
is very poor so if it's like yes or no
and if it's not a yes then well i can
go back to being alone because i'm i'm
i'm pretty chill like i got enough
things to distract me as i got midterms
i can find more jobs and stuff so it's
like
so i don't know i'm saying the brains
anything like that you sound like you do
engage with women i mean maybe not
talking about sexually but you still
engage with women right
yeah i'm not like i don't like just
it's not like we're like holed up in
like our apartments or dorms all day
long anymore so like and it's really
weird like because half of my classes
like coming at this point even though
it's engineering because college in
general it's just not a lot of dudes so
yeah well
the rule of thumb is just if you talk
less you're probably gonna get more
yeah as i say let the women talk more if
you let them talk and it's not even just
you i do this all the time too like
sometimes i just catch myself like
giving a little bit too much information
on somebody like
like sometimes i just be too much myself
and i'm just like giving too much too
early and some women were just like okay
well he's showing me too much interest
and i'm out
and you're giving her more information
to disqualify you right yeah
yeah and like
you don't because you don't know
yeah like if i was if i was on a date
with someone you don't know what my
requirements are
and the more you talk like the the more
information you're giving me to figure
out because yeah like for me like the
way it works is like
like there's like maybe five or six
things that i look for in a guy
so when i talk to you like i'm trying to
figure out like those five or six things
and the more information you get but you
don't know what that girl's five or six
things is
show the more information you give her
the more like opportunity you give
yourself to that's why that's why i've
always i've always i've always told guys
like hey like the more she talks the
less you talk the more she's either
gonna disqualify herself to you or the
more that you can finally realize okay
this is how i'm gonna move
you know this is how i'm gonna be able
to be around her maneuver around her and
that's what
guys guys realize a lot of guys that
understand that once you start going out
more and more women you start just let
them either sink their own hole or
hopefully they find like a life raft
where you can pull them in
and it's just uh first approach or first
date because i usually
it's overall overall everything
overlapping approach the perspective
i usually with like approach i usually
just try to keep it pretty casual and
brief because i'm not trying to it's uh
best words i can find right now i'm not
trying to like like shoot my whole like
game like tell me everything about me
like it's like no because i wanted the
first date to be like pretty interesting
learn about each other and actually have
things to say on the first day this is
actually interesting
i suggest you do one thing how i got a
second date was just spoke speaking
german but uh what's up what i suggest
you would do you should do on a first
date go to somewhere that doesn't
require talking like go skating
go do something that's like interactive
like yeah you know video games something
you can like be involved with because
because when you get on that first date
and like you're saying like you want to
kind of get to know each other like
that's not
that get to know you like like like
pearl saying like the disqualifying is
like it's always on the brain like
they're probably that that's cool like
do it i i accept it like no no no no no
no no but you wanna you wanna put
yourself in the best positions yeah
exactly succeed and it's not
it's just like they don't hate you they
just that's just how they operate
yeah it's just like
i don't know like mac do you do you do
you conflate like relationship with
sexual like like sexual value and
relationship value like it's like no not
really
no you don't so you then so then your
overall goal when you're out with your
girl is that to smash is it to
potentially get a girlfriend and
potentially be a
like do you prefer to be in a
relationship or just have something
trying to get into a relationship right
now because my last thing was as you
guys can judge was kind of toxic and
plus
for other reasons it started getting old
and shut so
because i understand i understand that
you have a boundary and but you also
have to understand you can have to work
on some of the patients as well so i
understand where you're coming from
because at first i was thinking like no
and don't take this as a fence but i was
getting like some asperger's vibes where
you're very blunt and direct
but because i've dealt with i've worked
with people on the spectrum and i'm not
saying you're on the spectrum i'm not
saying anymore
you're saying because you're so
yeah you're forward and direct which is
not bad i love people i i rather hang
out with a lot more asperger's people
because they're more blunt and direct
and honest
but at the same time you gotta
understand it's um
it's gonna become a
self-destructive in the relationship
market in a dating marketplace
it could be for you yeah i mean yeah
that's favorable
i i can only just see like
because i can't see how i would be
without that so like i can only just
know how things are going as i am so you
gotta kind of know yourself right like
you seem like more of a long-term grower
on the on a girl so like
like then we say like the less is more
like the more she kind of grows into you
when you kind of get in the days and you
start you know prolonging like like like
pearl was saying earlier like there's
some short-term guys which is like it
kind of seems unfair like the chaz and
tyrone all these guys like you get it
like
automatically like i'm trying to jump a
[__] right now that's not always the
guys you think yeah
guilty and you just kind of it's just
kind of like knowing what you're back
like like i have a friend like like i'm
i'm i'm five eight probably five seven
and a half and like
six four like we go out like i'm aware
if he's just gonna get a lot of
attention like in fact he's talking yeah
it's like probably i don't get out of my
pocket and try to compete with him like
i stand or work like i said i'm cool
with talking and and kicking it and not
being
yeah people and that's just my pocket
and that means i'm going to have less
options than him but i'm still going to
have options that are going to like it's
going to come your way they're going to
come away and there's going to be gene
when they come you're probably right uh
probably like the cop because for me
like getting and i thought for like a
lot of other college students were
probably not i thought it was like
fairly casual you know to sit both
[__] both feet on our laptops
checking emails i don't [__] care
like i thought it was like fairly casual
like hey look i'm not i didn't think i
was actually asking people to like hey
hop in my bed first day i was like you
can come and go but maybe maybe that was
a bit too forward
maybe you so maybe you're right you can
just do like bowling or something like
that yeah
i was gonna say the same thing that
osmosis was saying because i'm like five
nine five ten
maybe five eleven with jordans and like
i know the guys that my home the homies
of mine that were like six two six three
six four
while they were getting the nines and
tens i was getting the sixes sevens and
eights there's a reason why they call me
king of the sevens but
you know
the yeah like like but you gotta
understand like um
social cues patience like
i know because i there was there was a
time where i was such an adrenaline
junkie i'm still kind of am now but i've
i've calmed it down and i gotta
understand like you gotta have me
somewhat patient and i throughout the
years i was just i think that's what
women have told me like yeah they like
me because i'm very chill and very
mellow it's like you can sit down and
hang out with them and then for some
reason i end up in the living room or
end up in their bedroom and you know
next thing you know
and and guys confused that that's not
genuine desire and i and i think like
the red pill gets this wrong like if a
girl doesn't go for you right away just
like
sometimes like a girl it takes time for
her to see like your value you know what
i mean because a girl can't possibly
know right away when she meets you
if like like what you're good at what
you have to offer all that stuff so like
the best advice i could give to a guy is
like take her somewhere where she can
see what you're good at or be around her
where she can see what you're good at
because girls like like to look up to
the guy that they're with so
like if you're if you're best if you're
best like if you're smart then like try
to pick up girls in school if you're if
you're good at sports like try it like
that's probably the best but because
like it's like very attractive to us to
see like a guy doing something he's
passionate about and what's good
i'm gonna take her to the computer lab
i'm laughing but it actually might work
i don't know some some skills are some
skills are easier to show off than
others yeah i was gonna say like if
you're if you're good at like like um
athletes i don't know like art or poetry
or like you're good at rap singing or
something or being a comedian
take her somewhere like a comedy where
you're like a great comedian and that'll
show your talent you know or like if
you're a great art like a chef take her
to like a cooking demonstration and then
you still see you get down as a chef and
then she'll be like oh wow like he's
passionate ambitious about something
or even just being around people that
like like you i would say mike so
i lost like a [__] ton of my friends
it's so awkward what's up oh i was like
i was gonna think about the bowling
thing and stuff like i'll go places like
that and i you don't even have to talk
to women right i'll go
i gotta take a girl bowling just kidding
some and i'll just be very social with
the men in the area like yeah i was out
of my way just be like super friendly
and like joking into it and and most
women see that as like one not invasive
you're not being like she's not taken as
a challenge because you're overly giving
attention to the woman but just like it
just says like you're social and like
people kind of accept you and like yeah
when you talk to random men men are way
more accepting to strangers than women
are so essentially what i would do in a
club i would just i ain't talking about
a club that's a little different yeah
i guess like over here is we call it we
call them clubs but they're
it's more like college students standing
around but
got to be more social and it's easier to
be social with men and her to be like oh
wow people actually like them and like
they kind of see that as like social
proof even if yeah
because what i would do is just like i
would just start you know just
fine i guess i should say borrow just
fine go in you know just
talk to everybody have some jokes have a
good time and then just oh if i happen
to talk to each other you know it's not
even like me stopping out or stepping
towards someone it's just like oh hey
then keep it kind of flowing i was like
kind of like my thing was kind of like
whenever i would just like out it was
really just like with like classmates it
was for i was just like hey do you want
to like study or and if they just like
don't because a lot of times like
they'll just not respond or whatever i'm
just like okay that's cool but i would
just like kind of just leave it at that
i wouldn't really like get upset or
anything but like i'll take it it's just
like a missed shot
and if something picks up that's cool
but you know what i mean but usually
what women's study implies that
i mean i mean i was in college it's like
coming to study using applies sexual
intent
uh well it doesn't
well yeah
i would just say like let's go study
yeah but i also get you though when you
say hey
let's let's go study i i i definitely
get that because it's like
i mean i've had a sock on my door before
in the dorms i would just not take it so
seriously you're 22
like you're in college still figuring it
out i would just literally just
just focus on taking someone nice that
seems interested in you
and just go do something fun like
something you genuinely believe is fun
with like you kind of got to get the
dating aspect
just like go have a good time and that
will more than likely get you more
results than just kind of like
thinking you need to hit a home run on
every girl
yeah i mean
i only stop being friends or stop
talking with people who are already kind
of like on the edge for like me what's
going on
what do you actually like doing for fun
what do you do for fun
oh [__] man that's very good
bro i'm [__] boring that's my problem
right now what i like to do for fun man
i like to [__] i like [__] cooking
i mean that shit's fine
um i'm getting
that's not fun that's just something i
do i have to do i work out i used to be
huge into mountain biking that's kind of
hard to do group
plus i kind of have to say i was going
to say aren't there aren't there group
bikers like or isn't there like a bike
crews where like they go out biking for
miles together like there's like 20 of
them i see them around california all
the time
i haven't found any over here you can
always invite the girl to go with you
yeah
like i said like i said another social
group like it takes the pressure off of
you it's why we're giving telling you
that's what i'm saying yeah because like
i said like a great like for me
one of the best first dates i would take
women on would be like a dave and
buster's there's food there there's a
bar there we got activities we can have
fun relax it's not like a huge stick up
your ass there's a pool tables around
there you can talk that was usually like
a go-to for me like or like a yeah i'm
going to play mini golf and go go
karting and stuff like that
and just be like open to talking because
it's a social proof area you find out
how she interacts with you she can relax
you cannot actually if you you can
you can tell if a woman is being
interested in the moment in the
activities if she's not you can you can
read off her energy like her personality
if she's vibing with you she's very
direct if she's too direct
um yeah so stuff like that like the
physical space like if she's close to
you she's kind of like being physically
touchy and that means she's actually
digging you more
the eye contact and
positivity some people talk about like
and i think this is kind of holding you
all the game i'm trying to help you out
like i smell this is me like pearl we're
helping you
some people talk about like feet like
where where their feet are pointing is
that like a thing or not yeah scratch
all that sometimes yeah i thought that
was weird i thought that was weird
you're not even there to be thinking
about all that stuff okay okay
what we're basically saying is just like
not take it so serious like just yeah
focus on having a good time like go hang
out with some guy friends make some guy
friends get in little social circles
like that mountain biking people do all
that stuff all the time like you just
gotta like
get out of your room even female friends
aren't even a bad thing to have because
they can connect you with other girls
and that's what i was saying that's the
one thing i don't understand why the
menosphere is like no female friends i'm
like you realize like
i'm not with that one
say i friends and a guy i have
i don't know 20 attractive teammates
exactly like it's like are you genuine
friends are you gonna be cool with them
you know you know
and i've i've set up guy friends with my
teammates like i've said i've set up
like plenty of
guy friends like with the girls i know
like girls want to if we like you
yeah yeah
the way the way i look at it with women
is like either they can be uh someone i
can get intimate with or they can be
like a social like a like a networking
business like
that's how i look at it so with women
yeah sex sexual or networking business
maybe in the future like it's all like
who you know not what you know so it
could be like a job that i want to get
into maybe i can call this female friend
who yeah who is in that same degree of
that business on that job field or the
third one is you know like like pearl
was saying uh she they can be great
women in certain ways and they can help
you connect with women and then other
women will see okay well this guy is not
a weirdo he's not a freak you know he
actually women can't stand him being
around him
and then you know i'm just i'm i mean
moss moses pearl and me have been giving
you game
to help
that girl that like i said my friend
she's a hard time and all the dudes
around me just kept saying like to try
to sleep with her and that was my point
like pearl saying like i'm not because
her network of friends
will get me way more results than trying
to get this yeah
and then like that's the end of the road
here i think that's what i need to work
on i
[Music]
yeah you definitely
i need friends
because uh oh man a lot of mine have
graduated because i had to
i kind of got help back a year just had
to take some time off
and a lot of old friends just kind of i
don't know they kind of see me as a
freak
that's like
like um because i
almost
[__] them it gets it
you're choosing to put yourself in that
label though the more you hear it the
more you're starting to believe it
because
it's not a belief though it's it's it's
not um young a lot of people my age who
are like 21 22 people who like and it's
completely cool for them to like get
like like busted off their ass every day
meanwhile like a lot of like my old
friends who like when we do like crazy
stuff together they see me as a guy who
had a stroke at 21 so they don't see me
as
saying that but like if you know that
i would have never thought but it's not
it's not something i have to mention
it's something all my my friends know
about me it's like i can't hide being
hospitalized for three months
did they say that to you
they said like no it's just yeah it's
just it's just obvious when you we used
to do certain things i would be able to
do or willing to do nor i just can't do
anymore
or i just have like like just certain
boundaries like hey like hey like let's
like talk about like certain things like
hey uh like it's kind of made me a
little bit uncomfortable
and then i would just like eventually
just get bite it less and stuff like
that and just when you when you have a
massive uh
why am i using that word so much it's
weird uh but when you have a uh
traumatic brain injury your personality
does tend to change quite a bit
so that's actually what people told me a
lot is that like hey man like
you know man you chan they were just
like you changed a lot you're like a lot
more serious and a lot more mature now
and i'm like oh i i legit will like not
even notice
so i was i thought it was just like me
you know going about my day
and so it kind of just like kind of
creates attention and it's like i'm not
saying i'm like well because i i miss
being able to like you know goof around
and kind of it just sounds like you need
new friends man because you've been
around here you've been personable here
you've been [__] like yeah
all the stuff you're saying i haven't i
haven't gotten any of these cues or
these negative things you're saying like
you've been the kids yeah i need you i i
cause i can speak on this because my
mother suffered a stroke in the brain
injuries
and if you look at her and you see her
how she is now but both physically how
how it's [__] her up and how all the
pills she takes you know she's changed
you you got off easy the way i'm looking
at you right now you got off light
compared to what happened to my mother
depending on the severity of the scale
did you have a brain surgery do you have
a brain injury yeah
yeah
okay so how what how what number of
pills are you on because i was the one
taking care of my mom for that
pills
i had to up my dose uh because i'm uh my
uh fun
christmas one of my fun christmas
presents is i found out my uh
anti-seizure doses wasn't high enough so
okay so you stop so you still go through
that nonstop from time to time yeah that
yeah that happened over break so that
knocked me out of driving for six months
but i'll get back to it
okay it'll come it'll come up
the reason why i'm asking these
questions
i gotta take them so
yeah the reason why i'm asking this
these questions is because um
it'll paint more of a picture to
understand where you're coming from and
also understand why your tolerance is
even lower than before because
um these things what what mac is saying
is true
it does play it does play a factor it
happened a lot to my mother other people
patience of that
but it also depends like what osmosis
was saying and pearl was saying it's
also the the group of men you're around
you got to be around confident men and
men who are worth a damn and men that
have
have a certain set of balls
and and have a certain set face like you
got to be around these kind of men that
are worth integrity character
that you know i actually don't just talk
to talk but walk the walk and get you
some female friends
yeah that you're really friends with
that you're just not trying to like yeah
that's what yeah yes
yeah that's really hard to do huh
that's the part about female friends
like is it it's not hard for me now but
i had to actually get rid of him if
you're a child
they weren't really
yeah
this should be an easy thing because it
seems like like you're saying like
females try to like friends on you
anyways like just accept that and just
be cool with them and just kind of i
mean it's like hey like hey if nothing
happens like um is this no
it's no damage we still cool it's just
like on that aspect i'm not like pushing
or trying like that anymore so
pearl put them
i said i feel like girls love attention
is it really hard to make females oh duh
that's an obvious woman love attention
but like i'm saying like it's it's just
like you're using her for her friends
all okay all relationships are in
general like about trade-offs
no matter how like genuine the
friendship is you're getting something
whether it's like they're funny or
they're charismatic or whatever
like i don't see why it's bad to like be
friends with someone because you like
them one and you think that they also
may have friends you like
why is that a bad thing
i'm not saying like don't be around a
girl you can't stand but if you think
she's cool like yeah that's bigger you
think she's cool and she thinks you're
cool and then be friends and benefit
from it
yeah
i find i find being friends like just
like
pretty easy i gotta
and and get some new friends that don't
know you before you're a solid dude you
just gotta
you just gotta accept that all right so
just you know um yeah i mean you knock
it out
hold on first day of class tomorrow
i'm so i'm subscribed to your channel so
i'll be getting your notifications more
so thank you i i hit the link like share
and subscribe to pearl it's just pearl
things osmosis if you can please enter
your youtube channel in the chat so i
can subscribe to you
um oh yeah
come on bro
rid of that oh
yeah well he did leave at one point
didn't he to go and coach like an nfl
team and it didn't work out so no you're
thinking of urban that guy's a clown no
the same thing saban did the same thing
but it didn't work out i knew it
yeah go dogs
yeah but anyways pearl thank you i
appreciate it thanks for letting me back
on after
i originally left
no one called in so
i got first day of class and a
championship tomorrow so
go dogs
best of luck guys
yeah okay so yeah we need to bless them
out because we [__] lost them first
yeah osmosis did you did you put in your
youtube channel in the private chat
oh in private
yeah so i can subscribe to you
pearl i know that you posting your your
volleyball games and stuff are you are
you in uk right now
yeah i'm in the uk i just got back
all right well make sure you spike it or
you slam dunk it or you touch down
whatever the
volleyball terms is right thank you
thank you play professionally
semi-pro i'm trying to go pro next year
possibly we'll see let's go
yeah good luck get that money
i could
it's like you don't make [__] as a girl
though so we'll see
oh
it does seem that way raging feminism
raging feminists
no it's fair
it's not raging it's like i mean
could you do baseball uh
yeah i was gonna ask didn't you play
basketball before
i played both in college
um
i i was gonna go to school i was gonna
go to england for basketball um i was
gonna play at bournemouth but then i
switched schools and their basketball
program was ass so i switched
so i'm picky can't be picky unless it's
a full ride
what no i just wanted it to be like
decent play
like it was i would have got a
scholarship for whatever sport but it
was just like the team was so bad
pearl's like y'all [__] suck
in your high school team in your high
school team no no no here in england
like i was supposed to go but i played
in college basketball and volleyball and
track
yeah i made it all the sports damn you
could track
yeah it was d3 i was really bad at track
though like no i was about to ask what a
bit did you run because i used to have
400 800 oh damn we ran our worst [__]
races
well they're
yeah it was bad like they're so hard
they just need they needed people but
high school this chat has been great
though
i'll be heading out though thank you so
much pearl for the chat later guys
yeah i
i desperately need sleep and pro i can
only match how early is
[__] i'm not used to the time change yet
that's why i just got back uh so you're
probably everyone probably thinks you're
like the you're the crackhead that's
open what
so
i'll see you guys oh it's just me oh
[__]
bye
um
okay
bye guys thanks for watching i cannot
believe i was on this long
oh my god i can't believe i was on this
long okay bye